real-time data has been growing rapidly
over the last few years majorly because
of the internet social media platforms
website traffic sensors online
transactions and many more storing
processing and analyzing these vast
volumes of data was a major challenge
until apache spark came into existence
hi guys welcome to this complete apache
spark tutorial by simply learn
apache spark is an open source data
processing engine to store and process
data in real time across various
clusters of computers using various
programming constructs
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update in
this video you will learn what really
apache spark is the architecture of
apache spark and how to install spark on
windows and ubuntu
then you will understand in detail about
the various components of spark such as
spark streaming spark mlib and spark sql
you will also get an idea of analyzing
data using pi spark with the help of a
hands-on demo
finally we will look at the important
interview questions in apache spark
now let's first look at a small animated
video to understand big data in five
minutes we all use smartphones but have
you ever wondered how much data it
generates in the form of texts phone
calls emails photos videos searches and
music approximately 40 exabytes of data
gets generated every month by a single
smartphone user
now imagine this number multiplied by 5
billion smartphone users that's a lot
for our mind even process isn't it in
fact this amount of data is quite a lot
for traditional computing systems to
handle and this massive amount of data
is what we term as big data let's have a
look at the data generated per minute on
the internet
2.1 million snaps are shared on snapchat
3.8 million search queries are made on
google one million people log onto
facebook 4.5 million videos are watched
on youtube
188 million emails are sent that's a lot
of data so how do you classify any data
as big data this is possible with the
concept of five v's
volume
velocity
variety
veracity
and value
let us understand this with an example
from the healthcare industry
hospitals and clinics across the world
generate massive volumes of data 2
314 exabytes of data are collected
annually in the form of patient records
and test results
all this data is generated at a very
high speed which attributes to the
velocity of big data
variety refers to the various data types
such as structured semi-structured and
unstructured data examples include excel
records log files and x-ray images
accuracy and trustworthiness of the
generated data is termed as veracity
analyzing all this data will benefit the
medical sector by enabling faster
disease detection
better treatment and reduced cost
this is known as the value of big data
but how do we store and process this big
data to do this job we have various
frameworks such as cassandra hadoop and
spark let us take hadoop as an example
and see how hadoop stores and processes
big data
hadoop uses a distributed file system
known as hadoop distributed file system
to store big data if you have a huge
file your file will be broken down into
smaller chunks and stored in various
machines not only that when you break
the file you also make copies of it
which goes into different nodes this way
you store your big data in a distributed
way and make sure that even if one
machine fails your data is safe on
another
mapreduce technique is used to process
big data a lengthy task a is broken into
smaller tasks
b
c
and d
now instead of one machine three
machines take up each task and complete
it in a parallel fashion and assemble
the results at the end thanks to this
the processing becomes easy and fast
this is known as parallel processing
now that we have stored and processed
our big data
we can analyze this data for numerous
applications
in games like halo 3 and call of duty
designers analyze user data to
understand at which stage most of the
users pause restart or quit playing this
insight can help them rework on the
story line of the game and improve the
user experience
which in turn reduces the customer churn
rate
similarly big data also helped with
disaster management during hurricane
sandy in 2012 it was used to gain a
better understanding of the storm's
effect on the east coast of the u.s and
necessary measures were taken it could
predict the hurricane's landfall five
days in advance which wasn't possible
earlier
these are some of the clear indications
of how valuable big data can be once it
is accurately processed and analyzed
so here's a question for you which of
the following statements is not correct
about hadoop distributed file system
hdfs
a hdfs is the storage layer of hadoop
b
data gets stored in a distributed manner
in hdfs
c
hdfs performs parallel processing of
data
d
smaller chunks of data are stored on
multiple data nodes in hdfs
what do you think will be the most
significant impact of big data in the
future let us know in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video it would only
take a few seconds to like and share it
also to subscribe to our channel if you
haven't yet and hit the bell icon to get
instant notifications about our new
content stay tuned and keep learning
i hope you're excited to learn more
about big data and spark now we have
ajay who will take you through this
journey of learning apache spark in
detail with that over to you ajay
welcome to this tutorial on apache spark
one of the most in demand technologies
and processing frameworks in the big
data world and here we will learn on
apache spark history of spark what is
spark hadoop which is a framework again
wes spark components of apache spark
that is spark core spark sql spark
streaming spark ml lab and graphics then
we will learn on spark architecture
applications of spark spark use cases so
let's begin with understanding about
history of apache spark it all started
in 2009 as a project at uc berkeley amp
labs by mate
in 2010 it was open source under a bsd
license in 2013 spark became an apache
top level project and in 2014 used by
databricks to sort large scale data sets
and it set a new world record so that's
how apache spark started and today it is
one of the most in-demand processing
framework or i would say in-memory
computing framework which is used across
the big data industry so what is apache
spark let's learn about this apache
spark is a open source in-memory
computing framework or you could say
data processing engine which is used to
process data in batch and also in real
time across various cluster computers
and it has a very simple programming
language behind the scenes that is scala
which is used although if users would
want to work on spark they can work with
python they can work with scala they can
work with java and so on even r for that
matter so it supports all these
programming languages and that's one of
the reasons that it is called polyglot
wherein you have good set of libraries
and support from all the programming
languages and developers and data
scientists incorporate spark into their
applications or build spark based
applications to process analyze query
and transform data at a very large scale
so these are key features of apache
spark now if you compare hadoop west
spark we know that hadoop is a framework
and it basically has mapreduce which
comes with hadoop for processing data
however processing data using mapreduce
in hadoop is quite slow because it is a
batch oriented operation and it is time
consuming if you if you talk about spark
spark can process the same data 100
times faster than mapreduce as it is a
in memory computing framework well there
can always be conflicting ideas saying
what if my spark application is not
really efficiently coded and my
mapreduce application has been very
efficiently coded well then it's a
different case however normally if you
talk about code which is efficiently
written for mapreduce or for spark based
processing spark will win the battle by
doing almost 100 times faster than
mapreduce so as i mentioned hadoop
performs batch processing and that is
one of the paradigms of mapreduce
programming model which involves mapping
and reducing and that's quite rigid so
it performs batch processing the
intermittent data is written to sdfs and
written red back from sdfs and that
makes hadoop's map reduce processing
slower in case of spark it can perform
both batch and real-time processing
however a lot of use cases are based on
real-time processing take an example of
macy's take an example of retail giant
such as walmart and there are many use
cases who would prefer to do real time
processing or i would say near real time
processing so when we say real time or
near real time it is about processing
the data as it comes in or you're
talking about streaming kind of data now
hadoop or hadoop's mapreduce obviously
was started to be written in java now
you could also write it in scala or in
python however if you talk about
mapreduce it will have more lines of
code since it is written in java and it
will take more times to execute you have
to manage the dependencies you have to
do the right declarations you have to
create your mapper and reducer and
driver classes however if you compare
spark it has few lines of code as it is
implemented in scala and scala is a
statically typed dynamically inferred
language it's very very concise and the
benefit is it has features from both
functional programming and object
oriented language and in case of scala
whatever code is written that is
converted into byte codes and then it
runs in the jvm now hadoop supports
kerberos authentication there are
different kind of authentication
mechanisms kerberos is one of the
well-known ones and it can really get
difficult to manage now spark supports
authentication via a shared secret it
can also run on yarn leveraging the
capability of kerberos so what are spark
features which really makes it unique or
in demand processing framework when we
talk about spark features one of the key
features is fast processing so spark
contains resilient distributed data sets
so rdds are the building blocks for
spark and we'll learn more about rdds
later so spark contains rdds which saves
huge time taken in reading and writing
operations so it can be 100 times or you
can say 10 to 100 times faster than
hadoop when we say in memory computing
here i would like to make a note that
there is a difference between caching
and in memory computing think about it
caching is mainly to support read ahead
mechanism where you have your data
pre-loaded so that it can benefit
further queries however when we say in
memory computing we are talking about
lazy valuation we are talking about data
being loaded into memory only and only
when a specific kind of action is
invoked so data is stored in ram so here
we can say ram is not only used for
processing but it can also be used for
storage and we can again decide whether
we would want that ram to be used for
persistence or just for computing so it
can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics now
spark is quite flexible it supports
multiple languages as i already
mentioned and it allows the developers
to write applications in java scala r or
python it's quite fault tolerance so
spark contains these rdds or you could
say execution logic or you could say
temporary data sets which initially do
not have any data loaded and the data
will be loaded into rdds only when
execution is happening so these can be
fault tolerant as
these rdds are distributed across
multiple nodes so failure of one worker
node in the cluster will really not
affect the rdds because that portion can
be recomputed so it ensures loss of data
it ensures that there is no data loss
and it is absolutely fault tolerant it
is for better analytics so spark has
rich set of sql queries machine learning
algorithms complex analytics all of this
supported by various par components
which we will learn in coming slides
with all these functionalities analytics
can be performed better in terms of
spark so these are some of the key
features of spark however there are many
more features which are related to
different components of spark and we
will learn about them so what are these
components of spark which i'm talking
about spark core so this is the core
component which basically has rdds which
has a core engine which takes care of
your processing now you also have spark
sql so people who would be interested in
working on structured data or data which
can be structuralized would want to
prefer using spark sql and spark sql
internally has components or features
like data frames and data sets which can
be used to process your structured data
in a much much faster way you have spark
streaming now that's again an important
component of spark which allows you to
create your spark streaming applications
which not only works on data which is
being streamed in or data which is
constantly getting generated but you
would also or you could also transform
the data you could analyze or process
the data as it comes in in smaller
chunks you have sparks mlib now this is
basically a set of libraries which
allows developers or data scientists to
build their machine learning algorithms
so that they can do predictive analytics
or prescriptive descriptive pre-emptive
analytics or they could build their
recommendation systems or bigger smarter
machine learning algorithms using these
libraries and then you have graphics so
think about organizations like linkedin
or say twitter where you have data which
naturally has a network kind of flow so
data which could be represented in the
form of graphs now here when i talk
about graphs i'm not talking about pie
charts or bar charts but i am talking
about network related data that is data
which can be networked together which
can have some kind of relationship think
about facebook think about linkedin
where you have one person connected to
other person or one company connected to
other companies so if we have our data
which can be represented in the form of
network graphs then spark has a
component called graphics which allows
you to do graph based processing so
these are some of the components of
apache spark spark core spark sql spark
streaming spark mlib and graphics so to
learn more about components of spark
let's learn here about spark core now
this is the base engine and this is used
for large scale parallel and distributed
data processing so when you work with
spark at least and the minimum you would
work with a spark core which has rdds as
the building blocks of your spark so it
is responsible for your memory
management your fault recovery
scheduling distributing and monitoring
jobs on a cluster and interacting with
storage systems so here i would like to
make a key point that spark by itself
does not have its own storage
it relies on storage now that storage
could be your sdfs that is hadoop's
distributed file system it could be
a database like nosql database such as
hbase or it could be any other database
say rdbms from where you could connect
your spark and then fetch the data
extract the data process it analyze it
so let's learn a little bit about your
rdds resilient distributed data sets now
spark core which is the base engine or
the core engine is embedded with the
building blocks of spark which is
nothing but your resilient distributed
data set so as the name says it is
resilient so it is existing for a
shortest period of time distributed so
it is distributed across nodes and it is
a data set where the data will be loaded
or where the data will be existing for
processing so it is immutable fault
tolerant distributed collection of
objects so that's what your rdd is and
there are mainly two operations which
can be performed on an rdd now to take
an example of this
say i want to process a particular file
now here i could write a simple code in
scala and that would basically mean
something like this so if i say val
which is to declare a variable i would
say val x and then i could use what we
call a spark context which is basically
the most important entry point of your
application so then i could use a method
of spark context for example that is
text file and then i could point it to a
particular file so this is just a method
of your spark context and spark context
is the entry point of your application
now here i could just give a path in
this method so what does this step do it
does not do any evaluation so when i say
val x i'm creating an immutable variable
and to that variable i'm assigning a
file now what this step does is it
actually creates a rdd resilient
distributed data set so we can imagine
this as a simple execution logic a empty
data set which is created in memory of
your node so if i would say i have
multiple nodes in which my data is split
and stored imagining that your yarn your
spark is working with hadoop so i have
hadoop which is using say two nodes and
this is my distributed file system sdfs
which basically means my file is written
to htfs and it also means that the file
related blocks are stored in the
underlying disk of these machines so
when i say val x equals sc.text file
that is using a method of spark context
now there are various other methods like
whole text files parallel eyes and so on
this step will create an rdd so you can
imagine this as a logical data set which
is created in memory across these nodes
because these nodes have the data
however no data is loaded here so this
is the first rdd and i can say first
step in what we call as a dag a dag
which will have series of steps which
will get executed at later stage now
later i could do further processing on
this i could say val y and then i could
do something on x so i could say x dot
map and i would want to apply a function
to every record or every element in this
file and i could give a logic here x dot
map now this second step is again
creating an rdd a resilient distributed
data set you can say second step in my
dag okay and here you have a external
rdd one more rdd created which depends
on the first rtd so my first rdd becomes
the base rdd or parent rtd and the
resultant rdd becomes the child rdd then
we can go further and we could say val
zed and i would say okay now i would
want to do some filter on y so this
filter which i am doing here and then i
could give a logic might be i'm
searching for a word i am searching for
some pattern so i could say val zed
equals
y dot filter which again creates one
more rdd a resilient distributed data
set in memory and a you can say this is
nothing but one more step in the dag so
this is my tag which is a series of
steps which will be executed now here
when does the execution happen when the
data get when will the data get loaded
into these rdds so all of this that is
using a method using a transformation
like map using a transformation like
filter or flat map or anything else
these are your
transformations so the operations such
as map filter join union and many others
will only create rdds which basically
means it is only creating execution
logic no data is evaluated no operation
is happening right now only and only
when you invoke an action that is might
be you want to print some result might
be you want to take some elements and
see that might be you want to do a count
so those are actions which will actually
trigger the execution of this dag right
from the beginning so if i here say
z
dot count where i would want to just
count the number of words which i am
filtering this is an action which is
invoked and this will trigger the
execution of dag right from the
beginning so this is what happens in a
spark now if i do a z dot count again
it will start the whole execution of dag
again right from the beginning so my z
dot com second time in action is invoked
again the data will be loaded in the
first rtd then you will have map then
you will have filter and finally you
will have result so this is the core
concept of your rdds and this is how rtd
works so mainly in spark there are two
kind of operations one is your
transformations and one is your actions
transformations or using a method of
spark context will always and always
create an rtd or you could say a step in
the tag actions are something which will
invoke the execution which will invoke
the execution from the first rdd till
the last rdd where you can get your
result so this is how your rdds work now
when we talk about components of spark
let's learn a little bit about spark sql
so spark sql is a component type
processing framework which is used for
structured and semi-structured data
processing so usually people might have
their structured data stored in rdbms or
in files where data is structured with
but particular delimiters and has a
pattern and if one wants to process this
structured data if one wants to
use spark to do in-memory processing and
work on this structured data they would
prefer to use spark sql so you can work
on different data formats say csv json
you can even work on smarter formats
like avro parquet even your binary files
or sequence files you could have your
data coming in from an rdbms which can
then be extracted using a jdbc
connection so at the bottom level when
you talk about spark sql it has a data
source api which basically allows you to
get the data in whichever format it is
now spark sql has something called as
data frame api so what are data frames
data frames in short you can visualize
or imagine as rows and columns or if
your data can be represented in the form
of rows and columns with some column
headings so data frame api allows you to
create data frames so like my previous
example when you work on a file when you
want to process it you would convert
that into an rdd using a method of smart
context or by doing some transformations
so in the similar way when you use data
frames or when you want to use spark sql
you would use
sparks context which is sql context or
hive context or spark which allows you
to work with data frames so like in my
earlier example we were saying val x
equals sc dot text file now in case of
data frames instead of sc you would be
using say spark dot something so spark
context is available for your data
frames api to be used in older versions
like spark 1.6 and so on we were using
hive context or sql context so if you
were working with spark 1.6 you would be
saying val x equals sqlcontext
dot here we would be using spark dot so
data frame api basically allows you to
create data frames out of your
structured data which also lets spark
know that data is already in a
particular structure it follows a format
and based on that your sparks back in
dag scheduler right so when i say about
dag i talk about your sequence of steps
so spark is already aware of
what are the different steps involved in
your application so your data frame api
basically allows you to create data
frames out of your data and data frames
when i say i'm talking about rows and
columns with some headings
and then you have your data frame dsl
language or you can use spark sql or
hive query language any of these options
can be used to work with your data
frames so to learn more about data
frames follow in the next sessions when
you talk about spark streaming now this
is very interesting for organizations
who would want to work on streaming data
imagine a store like macy's
where they would want to have machine
learning algorithms now what would these
machine learning algorithms do suppose
you have a lot of customers walking in
the store and they are
searching for particular product or
particular item so there could be
cameras placed in the store and this is
being already done there are cameras
placed in the store which will keep
monitoring in which corner of the store
there are more customers now once camera
captures this information this
information can be streamed in to be
processed by algorithms and those
algorithms will see which product or
which series of product customers might
be interested in and if this algorithm
in real time can process based on the
number of customers based on the
available product in the store it can
come up with a attractive alternative
price so that which the price can be
displayed on the screen and probably
customers would buy the product now this
is a real-time processing where the data
comes in algorithms work on it do some
computation and give out some result and
which can then result in customers
buying a particular product so the whole
essence of this machine learning and
real-time processing will really hold
good if and when customers are in the
store or this could relate to even an
online shopping portal where there might
be machine learning algorithms which
might be doing real time processing
based on the clicks which customer is
doing based on the clicks based on
customer history based on customer
behavior algorithms can come up with
recommendation of products or better
altered price so that the sale happens
now in this case we would be
seeing the essence of real time
processing only in a fixed or in a
particular duration of time and this
also means that you should have
something which can process the data as
it comes in so spark streaming is a
lightweight api that allows developers
to perform batch processing and also
real-time streaming and processing of
data so it provides secure reliable fast
processing of live data streams so what
happens here in spark streaming in brief
so you have a input data stream now that
data stream could be a file which is
constantly getting appended it could be
some kind of metrics it could be some
kind of events based on the clicks which
customers are doing or based on the
products which they are choosing in a
store this input data stream is then
pushed in through a spark streaming
application now spark streaming
application will broke break this
content into smaller streams what we
call as disk criticized streams or
batches of smaller data on which
processing can happen in frames so you
could say process my file every five
seconds for the latest data which has
come in now there are also some windows
based uh
options like when i say windows i mean a
window of past three events window of
past three events each event being of
five seconds so your batches of smaller
data is processed by spark engine and
this process data can then be stored or
can be used for further processing so
that's what spark streaming does when
you talk about mlib it's a low level
machine learning library that is simple
to use scalable and compatible with
various programming languages now hadoop
also has some libraries like you have
apache mahout which can be used for
machine learning algorithms however in
terms of spark we are talking about
machine learning algorithms which can be
built using ml labs libraries and then
spark can be used for processing so ml
lib eases the deployment and development
of scalable machine learning algorithms
i mean think about your clustering
techniques
so think about your classification where
you would want to classify the data
where you would want to do supervised or
unsupervised learning think about
collaborative filtering and many other
data science related techniques or
techniques which are required to build
your recommendation engines or machine
learning algorithms can be built using
sparks mlip graphics is spark's own
graph computation engine so this is
mainly if you are interested in doing a
graph based processing think about
facebook think about linkedin where you
can have your data which can be stored
and that data
has some kind of network connections or
you could say it is well networked i
could say x is connected to y y is
connected to z z is connected to a so x
y z a all of these are in terms of graph
terminologies we call as vertices or
vertex which are basically being
connected and the connection between
these are called edges so i could say a
is friend to b so a and b are vertices
and friend a relation between them is
the edge now if i have my data which can
be represented in the form of graphs if
i would want to do a processing in such
way this could be not only for social
media it could be for your network
devices it could be a cloud platform it
could be about different applications
which are connected in a particular
environment so if you have data which
can be represented in the form of graph
then graphics can be used to do etl that
is extraction transformation load to do
your data analysis and also do
interactive graph computation so
graphics is quite powerful now when you
talk about spark your spark can work
with your different clustering
technologies so it can work with apache
mesos that's how spark came in where it
was initially to prove the credibility
of apache mesos spark can work with yarn
which is usually you will see in
different working environments spark can
also work as standalone that means
without hadoop spark can have its own
setup with master and worker processes
so usually or you can say technically
spark uses a master slave architecture
now that consists of a driver program
that can run on a master node it can
also run on a client node it depends on
how you have configured or what your
application is
and then you have multiple executors
which can run on worker nodes so your
master node has a driver program and
this driver program internally has the
spark context so your spark every spark
application will have a driver program
and that driver program has a inbuilt or
internally used spark context which is
basically your entry point of
application for any spark functionality
so your driver or your driver program
interacts with your cluster manager now
when i say interacts with cluster
manager so you have your spark context
which is the entry point that takes your
application request to the cluster
manager now as i said your cluster
manager could be say apache mesos it
could be yarn it could be spark
standalone master itself so your cluster
manager in terms of yarn is your
resource manager so your spark
application internally runs as series or
set of tasks and processes your driver
program wherever that is run will have a
spark context and spark context will
take care of your application execution
how does that do it spark context will
talk to cluster manager so your cluster
manager could be yan and in terms of
when i say cluster manager for yarn
would be resource manager so at high
level we can say a job is split into
multiple tasks and those tasks will be
distributed over the slave nodes or
worker nodes so whenever you do some
kind of transformation or you use a
method of spark context and rdd is
created and this rdd is distributed
across multiple nodes as i explained
earlier worker nodes are the slaves that
run different tasks so this is how a
spark architecture looks like now we can
learn more about spark architecture and
its interaction with yarn so usually
what happens when your spark context
interacts with the cluster manager so in
terms of yarn i could say resource
manager now we already know about yarn
so you would have say node managers
running on multiple machines and each
machine has some ram and cpu cores
allocated for your node manager on the
same machine you have the data nodes
running which obviously are there to
have the hadoop related data so whenever
the application wants to process the
data your application via spark context
contacts the cluster managers that is
resource manager now what does the
resource manager do resource manager
makes a request so resource manager
makes requests to the node manager of
the machines wherever the relevant data
resides asking for containers so your
resource manager is negotiating or
asking for containers from node manager
saying hey can i have a container of 1gb
ram and one cpu core can i have a
container of 1gb ram and 1 cpu core and
your node manager based on the kind of
processing it is doing will approve or
deny it so node manager would say fine i
can give you the container and once this
container is allocated or approved by
node manager resource manager will
basically start an extra piece of code
called appmaster so appmaster is
responsible for execution of your
applications whether those are spark
applications or mapreduce so your
application master which is a piece of
code will run in one of the containers
that is it will use the ram and cpu core
and then it will use the other
containers which were allocated by node
manager to run the tasks so it is within
this container which can take care of
execution so what is a container a
combination of ram and cpu core so it is
within this container we will have a
executable process which would run and
this executor process is taking care of
your application related tasks so that's
how overall spark works in integration
with yarn now let's learn about this
spark cluster managers as i said spark
can work in a standalone mode so that is
without hadoop so by default application
submitted to spark standalone mode
cluster will run in fifo order and each
application will try to use all the
available nodes so you could have a
spark standalone cluster which basically
means you could have multiple nodes on
one of the nodes you would have the
master process running and on the other
nodes you would have the spark worker
processes running so here we would not
have any distributed file system because
spark is standalone and it will rely on
an external storage to get the data or
probably the file system of the nodes
where the data is stored and processing
will happen across the nodes where your
worker processes are running you could
have spark working with apache mesos now
as i said apache mesos is an open source
project to manage your computer clusters
and can also run hadoop applications
apache mesos was introduced earlier and
spark came in and as existence to prove
the credibility of apache mesos you can
have spark working with hadoop's yarn
this is something which widely you will
see in different working environments so
yarn which takes care of your processing
and can take care of different
processing frameworks also supports
spark you could have kubernetes now that
is something which is making a lot of
news in today's world it is an open
source system for automating deployment
scaling and management of containerized
applications so where you could have
multiple docker based images which can
be connecting to each other so spark
also works with kubernetes now let's
look at some applications of spark so
jpmorgan chase and company uses spark to
detect fraudulent transactions analyze
the business spends of an individual to
suggest offers and identify patterns to
decide how much to invest and where to
invest so this this is one of the
examples of banking a lot of banking
environments are using spark due to its
real-time processing capabilities and in
memory faster processing where they
could be working on fraud detection or
credit analysis or pattern
identification and many other use cases
alibaba group that uses also spark to
analyze large data sets of data such as
real-time transaction details now that
might be based online or in the stores
of looking at the browsing history in
the form of spark jobs and then provides
recommendations to its users so alibaba
group is using spark in its e-commerce
domain you have iq here now this is a
leading healthcare company that uses
spark to analyze patients data identify
possible health issues and diagnose it
based on their medical history so there
is a lot of work happening in health
care industry where real time processing
is finding a lot of importance and real
time and faster processing is what is
required so health care industry and iq
vr is also using spark you have netflix
which is known and you have riot games
so entertainment and gaming companies
like netflix and riot games use apache
spark to showcase relevant
advertisements to their users based on
the videos that they have watched shared
or liked so these are few domains which
find use cases of spark that is banking
e-commerce health care entertainment and
then there are many more which are using
spark in their day to day activities for
real time in memory faster processing
now let's discuss about the sparks use
case and let's talk about conviva which
is world's leading video streaming
companies so video streaming is a
challenge now if you talk about youtube
which has data you could always read
about it so youtube has data which is
worth watching 10 years so there is huge
amount of data where people are
uploading their videos or companies are
doing advertisements and this
videos
are streamed in or can be watched by
users so video streaming is a challenge
and especially with increasing demand
for high quality streaming experiences
conviva collects data about video
streaming quality to give their
customers visibility into the end user
experience they are delivering now how
do they do it apache spark again using
apache spark conviva delivers a better
quality of service to its customers by
removing the screen buffering and
learning in detail about network
conditions in real time this information
is then stored in the video player to
manage live video traffic coming in from
4 billion video feeds every month to
ensure maximum retention now using
apache spark conviva has created an auto
diagnostics alert it automatically
detects anomalies along the video
streaming pipeline and diagnoses the
root cause of the issue now this really
makes it one of the leading video
streaming companies based on auto
diagnostic alerts it reduces waiting
time before the video starts it avoids
buffering and recovers the video from a
technical error and the whole goal is to
maximize the viewer engagement so this
is spark's use case where conviva is
using spark in different ways to stay
ahead in video streaming related
deliveries if we have understood and
learned about your spark components your
spark
architecture we can also see running a
spark application now a spark
application can run in a standalone mode
that is you could set up your ide such
as eclipse with a scala plug-in and then
you could have your coded application
which is written in eclipse to be run in
local mode now here i have an example of
application which can be run in a local
mode or on a cluster so this application
is importing some packages that is spark
context spark conf i have created an
object which is first app it is the main
class of your project and other classes
can just be extending app rather than
having main here we declare a variable
called x which is pointing to a file in
my project directory it looks for a file
which is
abc1.txt and this file basically has
some content what are we doing in the
application so we create a variable
where we assign the file then we define
or initialize our spark context so
remember whenever you work with ide you
don't have spark context or spark
available implicitly that has to be
defined so here we create a
configuration object we set our
application name we set the master as
local if you want to run it in a local
mode if you want to run it say on your
windows machine or if you would want to
run on a spark standalone cluster if i
would be running it on yarn then i would
remove this property that is set master
now once you have defined your
configuration object you can be
basically using spark context you can
use method of it which will result in
rtt that is what is happening in line 13
val y and then finally i can create a
variable where i would want to do a flat
map transformation on y which would
result in an internal rdd followed by a
map transformation which would again
result in an rdd and finally reduced by
key which is doing an aggregation once
all these steps are done i can decide to
display the result on the screen or i
can even use save as text file point it
to a particular location and then have
my application run now this is my
eclipse refer to other sessions where i
have explained how you can set up ide on
windows with different environment
variables and then you can run your
applications on a particular cluster if
i would want to run this application on
a cluster then i will have to give a
particular path so here in this case i
can say let's do this and i will say my
file is abc1.txt
let's save it and i'll also say my
output will be getting stored in a
default location as i intend to run it i
intend to run this application on a
cluster now in that case the cluster
would usually be set up on linux
machines would have a hadoop cluster
where you can run this application so if
i would want to run this application on
a cluster but not locally on the machine
i can just delete this part i can keep
my application now if you see my
application already compiles and does
not show any error message and that is
because in my project's build path i
have added all the spark related jars
all the spark related jars you can get
from your spark directory or you can be
getting in manually all the dependencies
some people would prefer to use maven or
say sbt for packaging your application
as jar and that can also be done so here
my code compiles code is fine it is
pointing to a file and then it is also
creating an output which will have word
count now what i can do is since i have
my code already written i know that i
have sbt installed on this machine
because i would want to package this
code as jar and run it on a cluster so
for that we can look in
our command prompt and here i can go
into workspace i can go into my scala
project and if you see here we have your
build dot sbt file you have your
binaries and you have your source so you
might not have these spark related
directories now these exist in my case
because i have been using spark and i
have done some previous runs now this is
what we have within my spark apps so to
build my package i need a build dot sbt
file we can see what does that contain
so your build.sbt contains your name
version of your package jar scala
version spark version and then
repository which spark will refer to
when it wants to have the dependencies
for all of your components such as spark
core spark sql mnlab and so on so this
is my build.sbt file which exists in the
project folder and if you are intending
to use sbt to package your code as jar
and then run it on the cluster in that
case i can even skip adding spark
related charge to the build path so that
is only done to make sure that your code
compiles now once i have my code written
i have sbt installed i have made the
file path changes i can just go to the
command line within my project folder
and i can say sbt package
now this will basically resolve all the
dependencies based on whatever you have
given in the code it will create a jar
file and place it in a particular
location and then we can use the same
jar file to run on a particular cluster
so sbd package is busy in creating the
jar now meanwhile what i can do is i can
open up a lab content and what i can do
is
i can just say for example
simply learn
and here i already have a lab set up so
you could have your own spark standalone
cluster where you could also run this
jar file you could have spark with
hadoop which is what i have here and i
will use that to submit an application
on the yarn cluster and let's go to the
web console let me copy my link i'll
close this i'll say launch lab and then
i can login here i can just to paste my
password and i'm logged in so i can just
say spark to shell now that's how it has
been configured here to work with your
spark version 2. so this is an
interactive way of bringing your spark
shell and running your application but
what we are interested in is running the
application as a jar file so let's go
and see here where we have our code and
let's see if svd has done the packaging
yes it has done and it has created a jar
file in this location so what i can do
is i need to get this jar file from this
location onto my cluster so what i can
do is i can come in here i can do a ftp
so this basically allows me to push
whatever jars i have on my web console
so i'll go in here i'll say connect now
i'll search if there is already existing
jar file which might create a conflict
so i have something here so i can for
now just delete it it's done i will say
upload file and i am interested in
getting the jar file so here we can
click on users win 10 i have my
workspace project i can get into target
scala 2.11 and take my jar file and say
open so this will upload my jar file on
the web console or the terminal wherein
i can connect to my cluster now let's go
in here let's quit from spark shell as
we want to run an application on the
cluster how do i do it so i can search
if i have my jar file existing it's here
so i'll say spark to submit and then i
will point to my jar file and then i can
simply say class and i know my code has
a package and a class name so this is
package and this is my object or class
name so i can say main dot scala dot
first app now it will be good if we
check if the file exists which our code
points to so i'll just for now comment
it out i will check in my sdfs ls in my
default user directory this is where it
will search for a file and here we can
search if i have a file called abc so i
don't see anything here so let's do this
what i can do is i can again go to ftp
and basically i can do a upload file
like what we did earlier and this time
i'll pick up this existing abc1 file
which i showed you and upload it once
this is done i can put it on my cluster
by just saying sdfs dfs put let's take
the abc1 file and let's put it in my
directory so this will be my input so
i'm putting in a file there and now i
can do a spark submit to submit the
application on the cluster so if you see
here it has basically started the
application it contacts the resource
manager it gets an application id and
now it is doing the processing of my
file where i would want to get once this
is done it will be completed and the
temporary directory will be deleted so
this is how i run a spark application on
a cluster now once this is done i can
also go to spark's history server by
saying this is the path for my spark
history server it shows an application
which was run today which was doing a
word count you can click on the
application it says it ended with save
as text file you can click on this and
then it shows you the dag visualization
it says we started with text file we did
a flat map we did a map and then there
was some shuffling because we wanted to
do reduce by key so as i said every rdd
by default has two partitions and if you
want to do some aggregate or wider
transformations like reduce by key sort
by key group by key count by key and so
on in that case
similar key related data has to be
shuffled and brought into one partition
that's where we see shuffling happening
here and it also tells what are the
number of tasks which have run per
partition so here we ran a spark
application by packaging it as jar using
your sbt so sbt created the jar file and
then basically we brought our jar file
onto the cluster and then submitted it
using spark submit so this is how a
spark application runs on the cluster so
as i said your application has a driver
program now your spark applications run
as independent processes and they can
run on a cluster across the nodes so we
just saw how we can run a spark
application on a cluster now we can
always look at spark applications
progress or after it has completed by
looking into the spark ui your spark
application as i mentioned has a driver
program and when you run your
application on the
cluster you can always specify where
would you want your driver program to
run so in our case when we ran our spark
application here we basically just did a
simple spark submit and we gave our jar
and the class name i could also say
master and then i could specify if i
would want my application to run in a
local mode or i could say yarn but that
is default or if it was a spark
standalone cluster then i could be
giving something like this your host
name and then your port so you could do
all of these options by specifying minus
minus master i could also specify how
many executors i need how much memory
per executor how much course per
executor i need and i could also say
deploy mode as client which basically
means my driver will run on this machine
however my execution of application will
happen on cluster nodes i can also say
deploy mode as cluster which basically
means my driver will run on one of the
nodes of the cluster you could submit
your application and then based on
whatever arguments you have given your
application will be submitted on the
cluster and it will run so you can have
your application running so as i said
you have an application which has a
driver and it also has either spark
session or spark context which takes
your application request to the resource
manager now if your application is
completed you can always come back and
look into the spark history server or
spark ui if i choose this as my
application which i have run i can go to
executors and that shows me that there
was one for your driver now that was
running on this particular node which is
my client node then i have my executors
on my other nodes which are nodes of my
cluster which used one core which ran
two tasks for the partitions which they
were working on and there was some
shuffling involved as we were doing a
word count which uses reduce by key so
when you run your application your yarn
or your cluster manager such as resource
manager negotiates the resources to the
slave processes your worker node
basically will have the resources
available for any kind of execution now
as i said your resource manager will
request for containers your worker nodes
will approve those containers and then
within those containers you will have
the executor which will run which will
take care of the task to process the
data so what is a task it is a unit of
work for the data set which has to be
worked upon so your rdds which get
created have partitions and for every
partition you have a task which is taken
care by the executor so the data is
loaded into the rdd when the action is
invoked and then your task is worked
upon by the executor so what does it do
it basically gets the data into the
partition of rdd and then does the
execution as a task on that particular
partition results are then sent back to
the driver and you can also have your
output saved on the disk so this is how
your application run whenever you run a
particular application you can always go
to your web console and scroll or look
into the logs for more information so
here our application was run and we can
see right from the beginning here when
we talk about spark submit which is done
here it says running spark version 2.2
it basically then will see that there
will be a driver which will be started
you can further see that it does some
memory calculations it then starts a
spark ui and here we can see that
requesting a new application from
cluster with four node managers verify
our application has not requested more
than maximum memory capability of the
cluster so the container sizing at the
cluster level is 3 gb per container and
your application should not be
requesting for a container bigger than
that it starts a application master
container with specific amount of memory
and then finally your execution starts
if we scroll down and look into the logs
we will see where my driver runs it will
also see show you how much memory was
utilized and it will talk about back
scheduler which is taking care of
execution of your tag that is series of
your rdds and finally you will see the
result getting generated or saved so
this is how you run your spark
application this is how you can see your
spark applications in history server or
spark ui and this is how overall apache
spark works utilizing your cluster
manager help getting the resources from
the worker processes and then running
the executors within those so let's have
a quick demo on setting up spark on
windows and trying out the sparks
interactive way of working for this
first thing is you will have to download
spark now you can just go to google and
type spark download and once you click
on this link it shows you a spark
release a package type which says
pre-built so we will have to get a
pre-built apache hadoop related spark so
here i will choose say spark 2.4.3 and i
will choose pre-built for apache 2.6 and
then i can just click and download on
this spark 2.4.3
bin hadoop 2.6 star file once you click
on this link takes you to the mirror
site and you can just click on this link
and download spark 2.4.3
once this is done which i have already
downloaded here i can go to my downloads
and it shows that i have a tar file now
we will have to unturn it or unzip it so
i can click on this link and i already
have winzip which allows me to unzip
spark
2.4.3 i can choose a location so i can
say unzip click on unzip choose local
and then i can choose one of my folders
so i have already unzipped it here and
that's how my spark 2.4.4
directory exists here 2.4.3 i'm sorry
now let's go and look into this
directory and what it contains so i can
click on c drive and then spark 2.4.3
and this has the folders which are
required for us to use spark if you look
in bin we have different applications
and commands which we can use and if you
also see i would have added
one of the utilities here either we can
have the win utils because spark will
need hadoop and we are planning to use
spark on windows so what we need is this
so i have in my desktop a hadoop
directory which has a bin folder and
here i have downloaded a win utils
executable file which you can always
search on internet and you can say
download win utils.exe
for spark 64-bit and then you can find
the link from where you can download
this for example we can click on this
and here we can search for
win utils so here we have the link i can
open this link in a different tab and
this basically shows me when utils for
hadoop 2.7.1 similarly you can search
for hadoop 2.6 and you can download
however 2.7 will also work fine now i
have downloaded winutils.exe
and that's in this hadoop folder within
bin i have this so we need two things
here one is spark which is untired and
in a particular location and then your
hadoop which has been and this has been
utils now once you have these things you
can set your environment variables by
just type in en vir go to your edit
system environment variables click on
environment variables and here if you
see i have added two variables so you
can just click on new and then you can
give your variable name as hadoop
underscore home and then you can give
the path where you have your hadoop
directory that contains bin and that
contains
win.util.exe i also have added spark
home which points to my spark directory
now once you have this you are ready to
use your spark on windows in local mode
once this is done i can open up my
command prompt and here i need to go to
my spark directory i can just say cd
spar 2.4.3
and then i can do a dir slash p which
shows me the folders where we have been
so to execute spark we can look into
what our bin has and it has different
programs such as you have spark shell to
work with scala and in an interactive
way of working with spark you can also
use pi spark which allows you to use
python to work with spark and you also
have spark submit if you have packaged
your application in a jar file to submit
it on a cluster so in this case we would
be using spark in a local mode so let's
use spark shell and test it so i can
just say spark shell in this way to
start my spark in an interactive way now
based on the path which you have set for
your vinnutils.exe
and spark shell you should be able to
use spark so it says welcome to spark
version 2.4.3
it also shows that spark context which
is the entry point of your application
is available as sc wherein it is
connecting to master as local and it has
an application id it also shows you a
spark ui which you can look at and it
says spark session is available as spark
so if you are interested in working with
spark core that is with rdds we would be
using spark context and if you are
interested in working with spark sql
that is data frames and data sets then
we can be using spark session so let's
try it out so we can declare a variable
that is a immutable variable and now i
will use spark context with a method of
spark context so i could just do a tab
to see what are the available options
within your spark context and here we
can use one of them to read a file so i
will use sc.text file and then i need to
point to a file so i already know that
in my spark directory i have a file
called readme dot rd and this is the
method of spark context if i enter it
will create a rdd now as i have
explained about rdds these are resilient
distributed data sets there is no
evaluation happening right now so even
if this file does not exist i would
still have an rdd created now i can go
further and do some more transformations
on this so i could say val y and then i
could say take x i would like to do a
map transformation on it and i would use
to uppercase now this is a inbuilt
function where i would want to convert
the content of this file into upper case
when i hit on enter it again creates an
rdd and this rdd is basically a child
rdd of the parent rtd created by text
file remember here we don't have any
evaluation happening or any execution
happening it is just transformations
which will lead to creation of further
rdds now we can invoke an action to see
the result and whenever you invoke an
action it will trigger the execution of
your dag starting from your first rdd
till the last transformation you did
before invoking an action so i could
just say count to see how many lines it
has and once i do this it says input
path does not exist it is not able to
find a file in this location so this
clearly explains that there was no
evaluation happening when we did this
when we tried to read a file and neither
when we did a map transformation only
and only when we invoked an action it
tried to search for file in this
location so let's quit this and check if
the file exists to quit you can just do
a ctrl d or you could do a colon quit
now here if you see some messages like
this which says unable to delete
temporary file so that's a known issue
we can fix that but my spark is working
fine now let's go and check if the file
exists so i will go in here and then i
will look in my spark directory to see
if the file exists so this is the file
readme dot md however i had done readme
dot rd so let's do it again and let's
test if our spark shell works fine so we
can go into the spark directory by just
doing this and then either i could be
going into bin directory and then start
spark shell or some people prefer to do
it this way wherein you can say bin
spark
shell and that should start your spark
shell but there was an error in the in
the slash so let's do it this way and
this will start your spark shell an
interactive way of working with your
spark and using spark context or spark
now once we have done this i can again
say val x and i can say sc which is
spark context which is already
initialized when you start your spark
shell i can say text file and i would
want to read a file which is readme dot
md now we know that this file exists
however the checking of the file
existing or not that means an evaluation
does not happen when you do a
transformation or when you use a method
of spark context it just creates an rdd
click on this and this has created an
rdd of string now we can do further
transformation on x by saying map and
then i can say i would want to convert
the content into upper case and that's
also done now finally let's invoke an
action which will trigger the execution
of my tag which contains these rdds so i
could just say y and i could say take 10
and i could say for each print ln and
this should be able to invoke an action
and it shows me the result from the file
which is converted into uppercase
remember if i do a y dot count which is
another action it will trigger the
execution of dag right from the
beginning where the first rtd was
created the transformation will be done
and then it will show me the count of
lines which exist as a result of this so
we can do this and this says me that
there are 105 lines this is a simple
example of using spark shell and using
spar in an interactive way on your
windows machine now to quit we can
always do a colon quit or we could do a
control d and that basically takes you
out of your spark shell similarly we can
work on pi spark by just saying dot
slash
bin
slash pi spark and that's python's way
of working with spark which brings your
python shell it starts the spark context
which is available as sc and if you are
interested in working on data frames or
data sets using spark sql then we would
be using spark now here i can just
declare a variable x and i can just do
sc.text file like what we did using
scala we can be referring to the same
file readme dot md and this
has created an rdd you can just type in
x and that shows the rdd which was
created you can then further do some
transformation on it using x dot
map and then i could say i would want to
convert this to upper case now in case
of python you would normally use
lambda if you would want to do any kind
of transformation so i would say lambda
x and then i would want to convert this
to uppercase so here we can check if my
rdd was correctly created and as i was
saying we can then do some
transformation on it so i can say again
y equals and then i would want to do
some transformation on x i would say x
dot map so in case of python as i
explained whenever we want to use an
anonymous function or we want to do some
transformation then we can pass in the
function to the transformation so here i
can say lambda and then i can just say
line or i could say x or a whatever that
is and i could say line i would use a
inbuilt function that is upper which
should convert the content of x to
uppercase now remember we are just doing
some transformations here so if i click
on y again and enter sorry if i enter y
it will show me that that has created an
rdd to see the content i can just say y
dot collect and that should show me the
content of first few lines which is
converted in uppercase so this clearly
shows that we can even use python to
work with spark by using pi spark now to
quit this we can just say quit and that
should take you out of your pi spark
shell so this is how you work on spark
shell or pi spark on your windows
machine so this has a local spark setup
or basically spark running in a local
mode and you could be using the
interactive way of working with spark
now if we have packaged our application
in a jar file then i could be using
spark submit to submit my application
how do we do that for this we can
basically bring up one of our ides so in
my case i'm using eclipse and i can get
into my eclipse now there are two
options here one we can be writing code
in your ide that is eclipse we can be
compiling the code based on the spark
related jars and then we can run our
application from ide which would
interact with your spark that's one way
the second way is we can use packaging
tools like sbt to package our
application as jar and then push the jar
to your local spark or a hadoop base
park and then run it using spark submit
now this is a simple sample application
for which i have
set up certain things here the first
thing is when you have downloaded
eclipse for all the people who are new
they might have to add the scala plugin
now if you see here in my eclipse it
shows up java perspective and it shows
color perspective now how did i get this
you can click on help and you can say
install new software and here you can
say add you can say scala ide and then
you will have to give a link from where
you can get the scala ide how do i get
that so i can go to my browser and i can
say scala ide dot org
and once you go to this link just scroll
down click on stable and that shows you
different releases for your different
ides now for eclipse although this shows
for oxygen and i have eclipse neon but
that works fine you can just copy this
link and here once you have copied the
link give the location here and you can
say okay now once you do that it shows
you different options from where you can
choose color ide for eclipse now in my
case it is already installed so these
options don't show up however if you do
not have this option for example let's
choose something else say i will say
scala
search and once i do this next gets
activated so scala id is already
installed in my case so i can click on
next and this should basically get scala
search plugin also which can be added to
my eclipse now once this is done you
will be prompted to restart your eclipse
and then you should have your scholar
perspective so for now i'll just cancel
this because i already have my scala id
dot eclipse so this is done i'll just do
a cancel here now once you have your
scala id or scala plugin added to your
ide you can always click on this icon
here and here you can just click double
click on scala that will open up scala
perspective so that's the first thing
then you can always click on file new
and create a scala project for example i
could say my test apps and then i can
just say finish so it has added a
project now what we need to do is we
need to make sure that our setup is fine
so first thing i would suggest is click
on this go to your build path and here
click on configure build path so where
it says color compiler it would be good
to choose for your project settings
instead of 2.12 go for 2.11 so sometimes
you might have problems with scala 2.12
which might not be able to compile for
your scala 2.11 so use latest 2.11
bundle and then you can say apply it
says compiler settings have changed a
full rebuild is required for changes to
take effect shall all projects be
cleaned now we can say ok and we can say
ok so this will build your workspace to
use scala 2.11 bundle now once that is
done second thing what we need is we
would want to write our code and we
would want our code to compile for that
as i said if we want to write our code
using an ide and then run it from our
ibe rather than using a build tool like
meven or svt i can just add the spark
related jars to my build path so i can
right click here i can say build path
and i can click on configure build path
and here where it says libraries i can
say add external charts now this needs
my spark related jars now where do i
find it so remember we have downloaded
spark so you can even find it there so
you can click on
wherever your spark is and then you can
click for jars which shows you all spark
related jars you can just do a control a
and just add it to your build path say
apply and then just say okay so once
this is done you have already added the
spark related jars which might be good
enough for you to write an application
once this is done we need to basically
go ahead and write our code now how do i
do that i can just click on source and i
can say new and then i can
say package
and here you can say main dot scala
click on finish and that has created
main dots color so that would be sour
slash main slash scala in the folders we
can always check that so i can go to c
drive i can look in users win 10 and
then look in my workspace for my project
and if you see in source we have main
and we have scala now this is where we
will be writing our code so for this
then i can just right click and i can
say new and i can just create an object
and i can give it a name so we can say
test app and then we can say finish so
in case of scala and spark we need to
create an object and then we need to
define main class here once that is done
we also need to import some packages and
we need to initialize the spark context
now for that you can take an example
here so i have already written the code
and i can look in source
main scala and i have created an app
called first app.scala now here we have
the package name we are importing some
packages which are required for us to
initialize part context and spark
configuration so it is part context
sparkconf and here is my object and for
a particular project at least one of
your object or one of your application
needs to be the main so we define the
main here by saying def main args and
array of string then we need to
basically define our spark context so
i'm creating a configuration object here
and then i say new spark conf i'm
setting my application name to hello
spark and then this is very important if
you intend to run your spark application
either using spark submit or from your
id you need to specify your master as
local now that could be given with one
thread or multiple threads so this is my
configuration and then i initialize my
spark context pointing to my
configuration so this is the most
important part here now if you see this
is something which i showed you in the
command line so i'm doing a val x and
i'm pointing it to a file in my project
directory which is
abc1.txt so this is just to make sure
that you are giving a windows path and
you are giving the right escape
characters now if it would be if you
intend to run this application on a
hadoop based cluster then you will have
to give the path of the file accordingly
which we can see later so here i have
val x i'm pointing it to a file which i
have created here and this just contains
three lines this is my sample file which
i want to test this is a new file now
here i've created a variable called x
further i would say val y and i would
use spark context method text file like
what we did in interactive way and i'm
pointing it to x i'm also using some
extra features like caching so that i
can cache the rdd which gets created
further i create a variable called
counts and then i do it flat map
transformation on y where i would split
the content based on space i would do a
map transformation where i would get
every word from the file and map it with
number one and finally i do a reduce by
key operation once this is done i do a
saves as text file now i could do a
collect i could do a take i could do a
count and i could also do a save as text
file where i would want my output to be
saved in this location plus i'm using a
java utility to append a random number
to my output directory finally i do a
spark context stop so this is my
application and if you see here my
application completely compiles because
i've already added the relevant jar
files in the build path now once this
application is done we need to run this
but before doing that we need to look
into our run configurations so you can
click on run configurations and here i'm
giving my project name i'm specifying my
main class which is first app then you
can straight away go to environment and
here i have added two variables one is
spark underscore local underscore ip
which points to this machine's localhost
and then i have said hadoop underscore
home because spark even when you are
running locally would want if hadoop is
existing so we can just set hadoop
underscore home and i am pointing it to
my desktop hadoop directory which
contains bin folder and that bin folder
contains a winneutils.exe
this is done we are fine and then i can
test my application by just clicking on
run now this should trigger my
application on my windows machine using
my ide i didn't have to package this as
jar and here
my application is completed which should
have created one additional directory
here so i can click on this i can right
click and i can try doing a refresh and
here you see a new output is created we
can look into this it has a part file
which shows my word count so this is a
simple example of setting up your ide
and running your applications from ide
on a local spark now what you also see
is a build file here what is that for so
in case you would want to create a
project and you would want to package
the application as a jar file and then
run it on the cluster using spark submit
now in that case we can avoid adding the
jars to my build path but what i would
need is i would need build dot sbt file
within my project folder remember if you
intend to package your application as a
jar and then run it on a cluster or on a
local setup you would not need the build
related charts however the build related
jars which are already here will not
cause any harm let them be there now we
have a build.sbt file also which is
existing in my project folder now just
for this run i can in fact delete this
target directory it will be anyways
recreated and if you would want we can
also clean up these just to avoid the
confusion i will delete these now i just
have my project folder and i have the
libraries i have abc1.txt and i have a
build.sbt file what does that contain so
this basically has a name i'm giving a
version which will be appended to my jar
i'm saying the scala version which i'm
using which is 2.11.8 and i'm saying
spark version which is
2.2.0 you can replace these with the
version which you intend to use other
than that we are pointing to the
different spark components and the
relevant dependency related jars which
usb t can get for you so i have given
spark core spark sql mlib spark
streaming and spark hive which will be
then fetched from the repository so this
is my build.sbt file which exists in my
project folder we have our code written
we have our
build.sbt file which is already existing
in my project folder my code is already
fine now we need to use sbt to package
my applications into jar for which you
will have to download sbt so you can
just say download sbt windows and that
should take you to the installing svt on
windows page now here you can just
download the msi installer and run
through the installer which will
basically install sbt on your machine
now i have already done that so my build
file is ready my code is ready all i
need to do is now use sbt so what i can
do is from my command line i can just
say
cd and i will go into users i'll go into
win10 and i'll go into my workspace now
here i can see for my projects and i can
go into my spark apps now once i'm in my
project folder we can double check that
it has a build.sbt which is fine sbt is
already installed on this machine and i
can just say sbt if you would want to
check you can always do sbt version to
check if you have svt and this command
is also done once you install sbt for
the first type you can always do sbt
version and before displaying it was
displaying sbt's version it will try to
fix all your dependencies it will try to
get all the relevant dependencies so
this is just to check that sbt is
installed on my machine as i said my
code is already ready i have a build.sbt
file and i can just say sbt package
which then will refer to build.sbt will
look for your code in source main scala
and then if everything is fine it will
package it as jar and it will create
folders within your project folder we
can click on this we can try doing a
refresh to see now if you see here the
project was again created a target
folder is created within scala 2.11 i
will have my jar created so we can see
that my sbt was fine it has packaged the
code and it has created a jar file as
simple project 2.11 -1 which can be used
to run on the cluster or in a local mode
let's check in eclipse i'll click on
this and i'll just do a refresh and
i see my chart is already existing which
basically means then we can do a spark
submit so this is where we see that i am
already running a spark submit command
now this might show up some error
messages but we can see how we did this
so if you see here once my packaging was
done i went into my spark folder i did a
bin slash spark submit i mentioned my
jar file and then i said my class main
dot scala dot first app so this is my
app and this is how i'm using spark
submit to submit an application which is
running in local mode so we can see
further if it starts processing so here
it says created local directory then it
starts an executor on localhost it goes
for execution and then if we see further
we could also see it will add our jar to
the class path and then finally it
should be doing the execution now if
there is any error message that might be
related to your file not being deleted
or if there is any problem with executor
so we can basically come back and check
here if there was any specific error so
it the error was that it tries to delete
a temp directory but it does not have
the permissions so we have not done that
but as per my application it should be
creating a output in this folder as park
out so let's click on this and see i'll
do a refresh right and if you see a new
spark output has been created previous
sessions we have seen how we can set up
spark on windows or set up our spark
related ide so that we can run our
applications on windows now here we have
a quick demo on setting up spark as a
standalone cluster on ubuntu machines
and then trying out spark way of working
for which we need at least two machines
and here i have ubuntu machines set up
um1 and um2 just to give insights on how
my machines look so if i look in my etc
hosts i have the ip address of multiple
machines so i can ping one machine to
other machine by just doing a ping um2
and that should work fine similarly i
have also set up ssh access for these
machines both of the machines have hdu
as the user and i can just do a ssh um2
and that locks me into the second
machine without a password similarly i
can check the same thing from my second
machine by doing a ssh um one and that
works fine too so we need two machines
which can ping each other firewall
disabled able to ssh each other so that
we can set up a standalone cluster of
spark how do we do it so first thing is
we will have to download the spark
related tar file now i can just go to
google and i can type in spark 2.2.1
download now that's what i'm interested
in and this takes you to spark release
2.2.1 however here it shows you the
latest release is 2.4 and then
2.4.2 so what we can do is we can go to
archives so i can basically look at
existing versions now here i can click
on download and this shows me a spark
release and also pre-built for apache
hadoop now what we can also do is we can
go to release archives for an older
stable version i click on this and here
i have spark
2.2.1 now i can click on this and we can
either install something which is not
already built or we can download this
one which is spark 2.2.1 bin hadoop 2.6
point t g z so you click on this link
and then save this file which i have
already done and here if you see in my
machine i have home sdu downloads which
has my different packages which i have
downloaded also if you notice i have
downloaded jdk8 so you can check on my
machines so apart from machines being
able to ping each other and being able
to do a ssh we also need machines to
have java which is already installed
once this is done now i have my spark
related package so i go into user local
directory and then you can give a
command here that is sudo star xvf home
sdu downloads and then give your spark
package now once you do this this will
untar the spark directory and create a
directory in my user local location if
you see here this is the directory which
is created but you also see that there
is a spark link which is pointing to
spark now that is because if you would
want to work on a newer version of spark
you could just do the same thing for
newer version and then make your link
pointing to the newer version of spark
how do you create a link you can just
say sudo ln minus s you can give your
spark directory and then you can create
a link so i've already created a link
and my spark path will then become this
now what do we do with this once we have
done this once we have created a link we
can go into the bash file of my user and
if you carefully see here i have given
my java path so that i can execute java
related commands and i have also added
my spark related path here which says
user local spark so in case you would be
changing your spark version to a latest
one you will not have to change things
in your bash file only thing you will
have to do is unlink the existing spark
link and create a new link to your newer
version so this is done on this machine
and now i can basically be using spark
now before doing that we can go into
user local spark and this has different
directories so if you look in bin these
has the binaries programs like your pi
spark your spark shell spark sql and
spark submit which we will see how we
can use here if you look in sbin it has
other startup scripts to start your
history server or to start your master
or worker processes if you look in conf
this has your config directories now
here by default you might see spark
minus default dot conf dot template i
have renamed that to dot conf slaves
template has been renamed to slaves so
let's look into this so i can go into
conf and then i will look in spark
default conf now here based on our setup
now here we intend to set up a spark
standalone cluster that is without
hadoop but i would want to have a spark
standalone distributed cluster so i have
uncommented this property it says
spark.master and i say spark and i also
mention that my master will run on this
machine which is um one spark event log
dot enabled is true because we would
want to track the events i have
mentioned a directory so this is a local
directory in user local spark and we
will have to create it it talks about
the default serializer it talks about
the driver memory which was by default 5
gigabyte i have reduced it to 2 gigabyte
gigabyte based on my machine
configuration you have java options and
then if you intend to run a history
server so that whenever your spark
application is complete you will have
your application stored in history
server i have given the log directory
which is user local spark and then
application history and this also needs
to be created we have spark history
provider for the class which takes care
of history server and the update
interval of looking for your
applications so this is what we have in
our spark default and if you look in
slaves i have given the machines where i
would want my worker processes to run so
that is um1 and um now once you have
made your changes in your spark default
conf and slaves file what you can simply
do is scp assuming that whatever was
done on this machine that is untarring
your spark directory creating a link
updating your bash rc and
renaming your config files same steps
need to be done on the second machine
and your second machine would also be
prepared to be used for your spark
cluster so once you have both the
machines which can ping each other which
can ssh each other both of the machines
have java both of the machines have the
same spark version downloaded and the
basic setup done i can just easily copy
the spark related config from here into
my other machine that is sdu um2 and
then i can give a path which is user
local spark conf and in this way i don't
need to edit my config files again and
similarly i can even copy the slaves
file this is all we need to basically
have our spark standalone cluster now
since we have updated our bash rc we can
give our spark command from anywhere we
have set up our config files so i can
just do a start minus all dot sh and
that based on my config files based on
the directories which are mentioned it
will start my master process and my
worker process on both the machines so
here we have a spark standalone cluster
which has two workers and one master now
we can always go to the browser
interface and we can check for the spark
ui which should be available by typing
in http
slash my master and then the port is
8080 so this shows that i have a spark
master running i have two worker
processes right now there are no
applications which are running but my
spark ui is already available when we
start using spark either by spark shell
or pi spark or even spark submit we will
see our applications getting populated
here additionally we can also start the
start history server by just saying
start history server dot sh and that
will start my history server once this
is done we have a history server also
running and we can go back and then we
can again pull out the history server
user interface by giving in the port
which is default 18080 so i have a spark
standalone cluster with one master two
workers and also a history server which
is running once we have this we can try
working with spark either with spark
shell or pi spark or if you have
packaged your application as a jar using
sbt or mevin you could also use spark
submit additionally you could also use
spark sql so to work with spark i would
just say spark shell on one of my
machines both my machines which have
worker processes running we can start a
spark shell on any of these machines
remember here our spark will rely on the
storage of these machines that is the
file system because it does not have any
hadoop or distributed file system we
have started our spark shell and that
shows spark context which is available
as sc spark session is available as
spark so to work with spark core and
rdds we would be using spark context and
if you intend to work with spark sql
that is data frames and data sets you
can be using spark let's try this quick
simple example so i'll say val x sc dot
text file and now i would want to point
it to a file so i will say the complete
path remember i am giving the spark
command from my home directory so i will
have to say user local spark and then i
can point to a file which is existing
here and this is what i would want to
use to do some processing we are using
the first step here wherein we are using
a method of spark context which will not
relate in any evaluation and it will
just create an rdt now we are using the
scala's way so let's create one more
variable and then we can do some
transformation on it by saying to upper
case i would just want to convert the
content into uppercase and this is again
a transformation so that will just
create an rdd once this is done we can
invoke an action to basically see some
results so i could just simply do a
collect which is an action and this
action will trigger the execution of dag
which starts from the farthest rtd that
is the first step where your file is
loaded into rdd now once we do this we
should be able to see our result and
that basically is execution of dag so
from the time we have used a text file
which is a method of spark context 2 we
did a transformation until we invoked an
action becomes my one job now if i would
do y dot count which is again a
different action this will trigger the
execution of dag right from the
beginning that is sc.text file where the
data will again be loaded in rdd a map
transformation will happen and then you
will have a count now we can always see
this in the spark ui by just going in
here and just doing a refresh so that
will show me that there is an
application which is running via spark
shell it has utilized three cores it has
utilized memory per executor one
gigabyte and we can click on this
application which shows that it used
both the workers one core and one gb on
this worker and two cores and memory on
this worker i can click on application
detail ui wherein i can see what are the
actions i invoked we also see the number
of tasks which are run and that is
because every rdt which is created by
default is having two partitions and for
each partition you will have one task
well we can change the partitions and
many more things can be done but that
you can learn in later sessions here we
have two jobs one ended with collect and
one ended with count now i can click on
collect and i can see the dag
visualization which tells me we started
a text file we did a map and finally we
did a collect it shows that everything
was done in state zero that is just one
stage i can click on count and that
again shows me the dag visualization
which is a different stage a different
job id which started with text file map
and then we did account if you would
want to see more details you can always
use these tabs to look at different
stages within your application if you
were doing some caching looking at
environment variables and also to see
how many executors were used including
the one for the driver on which nodes
these executor ran how many cores how
many tasks were run was there any
shuffling involved and so on so this is
how i have used spark shell that is an
interactive way of running my
application and since we have a spark ui
we can always look at applications when
they have run and we can always drill
down and know more details now since my
application is completed i can do a
refresh on history server but that does
not show anything because when we
started a spark shell it started an
application and that application is
still in running status if you see here
under running applications so this is
how we use spark shell on a standalone
spark cluster now we can just do a colon
quit and that takes me out of spark
shell similarly if i would want to work
on pi spark that is python's way of
working with spark i can just type in pi
spark which should bring my python shell
and then i can continue working with
spark and again go back and look at my
ui while my pi spark comes up i can go
here since i quit my spark shell i can
just do a refresh to see if my
application is yet coming up in history
server it might take some time and you
can always go back and look at
incomplete applications or wait till
your application is populated in history
server now if i do a refresh here on
spark ui it says this application was
completed it says finished and then now
we have started pi spark so it has
started a new application pi spark shell
and that is in running status we can
come back here and now we have our
pythons way so i can do the same thing
which i did in scala using
sc.text file i will point it to a file
which exists in user local spark read me
dot md so that's the file which i'm
interested in now this would have
created an rdt which we can confirm by
just typing in x now i can create a
different variable and i can say i would
want to do a transformation of map now
in case of python when you use anonymous
functions or when you want to apply some
functions to your transformations you
use lambda functions so we say lambda
line and then i would say what i want to
do to the line i will say i will use a
inbuilt uppercase upper function which
should convert my content into uppercase
but as of now this is a transformation
so it only creates an rtt to see the
result i can do a y dot collect and that
should bring up my result now in case
if it says the file does not exist that
is because there was a typo here and we
can repeat this step so let's bring up
here again x and i can give the right
name of the file i can do a
transformation and finally i can see the
result so this is using pi spark on a
standalone spark cluster which is
working without hadoop which has two
worker nodes and one master node we can
always come and do a refresh here look
at more details so we have our
application we can click on this again
similarly like we did for scala
application detail ui i see my
application ended at collect it ran to
tasks and i can look at my tag so this
is how we can use
spark shell or pi spark apache spark
streaming and here we will learn on what
is spark streaming spark streaming data
sources
features of spark streaming working of
spark streaming disk criticized streams
caching or persistence as we call check
pointing in spark streaming and we will
then have a demo on spark streaming so
let's learn on what is spark streaming
and what it is capable of so it's an
extension of score spark api that
basically enables scalable high
throughput fault tolerant stream
processing of live data streams now data
can be ingested from different sources
like kafka phloem kinases or tcp sockets
and then it can be processed using
complex algorithms expressed with
different kind of functions such as map
reduce join in window and when we have
the data processed that data can be
pushed out to your file systems
databases and live dashboards so if you
look on this image we can clearly see
that we would be working on a input data
stream which goes into spark streaming
component of spark which gives us
batches of input data or you could say
the streaming data is broken down into
smaller patches which would then be
worked upon by spark core engine and you
have finally batches of processed data
now when we talk about spark streaming
and the data sources you could have
streaming data sources coming in from
kafka or flume or say twitter api or
also with different formats such as
parquet you could also have static data
sources coming in from mongodb hbase
mysql and postgres so when we talk about
spark streaming it receives the input
data streams divides the data into
patches which can then be processed by
spark engine to generate your final
stream of results again in batches so
your spark streaming actually provides a
high level abstraction called disk
criticized stream and we will learn
about that or what we call as d stream
which represents a continuous stream of
data now when we look at your different
data sources from where the data can
come in spark streaming would take in
this input and then you could have even
your mlib component which could be used
that is sparks component to build
machine learning algorithms wherein you
can train your models with live data and
you can even use your trained model you
could be also going for structured
processing or processing the data which
is structuralized and that could be done
by using sparks components that is spark
sql which has data frames and data sets
so you could process your data with data
frames interactively query with sql when
spark streaming is working on the data
which is constantly flowing in finally
the data which is processed can be
stored in your distributed file system
such as sdfs or any other nosql or sql
based database now when we talk about
spark streaming it is good to know some
of the features of spark streaming and
here you have some of the features so it
enables fast recovery from failures
while it is working on streaming data
you have better load balancing and
resource usage and you can also combine
the streaming data with static data sets
and perform interactive queries now your
spark streaming also supports native
integration with advanced processing
libraries and that is one of the
benefits users can have when they are
using spark streaming let's learn about
working of spark streaming so as i
mentioned earlier at one end you have
your data streams now those data streams
are then caught or received by your
receivers which we have to enable in our
application your data streams or
streaming data which is constantly
getting generated and flowing in is
broken down into smaller batches which
will then be processed by spark so you
would have your final processed results
now if we look at the bigger picture
here we will talk about live input data
streams that could be divided into
smaller batches and when we say batches
these are batches of input data as rdds
so spark streaming performs computation
expressed using these streams it
generates rdd transformations so you
would have your spark pad jobs to
execute rdd transformations which would
give you your final processed result now
there are various examples and we'll
look at examples later so once your
spark streaming works on breaking the
input into smaller streams it can then
process the data finally giving you
batches of your result and that is again
on the streaming data now what is these
d streams let's understand about these
streams or discriticized streams so
that's the basic abstraction provided by
spark streaming now it represents a
continuous stream of data either the
input data stream received from the
source or the process data stream
generated by transforming the input
stream now here if we look at the d
stream we would say you would have
series of rdds or series of
transformations applied on the data
which is flowing in for a particular
time frame now here we say data from
time 0 to 1 and that would result in
some of the transformations which you
would perform on the data when it has
come in between this time zone or time
frame you would have again data from
time 1 to 2 and so on so that's how your
spark streaming works so if we look at
your different transformations now there
could be various transformations which
could be applied on your data so this is
something like your streaming data which
comes in you would want to say have a
receiver which monitors a particular
socket or a particular port and looks
for data coming in we would also define
the time interval and for that time
interval the data is taken so that's a
smaller batch or a d stream on which you
could have your processing done now
within your application you would have
series of steps which are nothing but
transformations which would be performed
on this data within this time frame
giving you a result which could be
stored which could be seen on your
console or which could just be pushed
further for processing and this keeps
happening at regular time intervals
whatever you have specified till the
spark streaming application continues
now when we talk about spark we already
know that there are different kind of
transformations which can be applied so
you have map transformation wherein you
have map and then you pass in a function
which basically says you would want to
perform a function on every element so
when we say map function that would
return a new d stream by passing each
element of the source d stream through a
function which is passed similarly it is
for flat map where you would be passing
in a function you would want to perform
a flat map transformation on the data
stream or t stream which comes in so
each input item can be mapped to zero or
more output elements
you could be doing a filter wherein you
return a d stream by selecting only the
records of the source d stream on which
the function returns true so filtering
is used when you want to run a
transformation where you would want to
look at the input data for a particular
time interval as i mentioned earlier and
you would want to filter that data as
per whatever your function is applied
now you could be doing a union where you
could basically be having a union of
multiple d streams so that this would
return a new d stream that contains
union of elements in the source tree
stream and a other d stream you could be
doing a transform function
that contains the union of elements you
could be doing a count you could be
doing a join so these are some of the
transformations which can be performed
on your d streams now there is also a
concept of windowing and that is
basically to process the data for a
series of time intervals so when i
mention windowed stream processing i am
saying spark streaming would allow you
to apply transformations over a sliding
window of data now this operation is
called as windowed computation let's see
how it looks like so if you have your
original d stream which is b which is
basically your data coming in now that
would be looked upon for specific time
intervals such as time one time two and
then you could be doing a windowed
computation which could basically mean
that i could have a window which is a
series of these time intervals on which
you would want to perform series of your
rdd transformations so you have a window
d stream at time 1 then at time 2 and
time 3 so that could be one window
wherein you would want to get an output
so here we see window at time three now
you could also have a another sliding
window which would take your time series
and we have time three time four and
time five where you could be performing
the series of transformations so this is
usually helpful where you would not only
want to process the data at particular
time interval but you would want a
consolidated processing for series of
intervals and that's what we mean by
windowed computation now before we
understand about caching and persistence
we can talk a little bit more on
windowing so if one would want to
understand the window stream processing
or as we say spark streaming's feature
of windowed computations we need to
think it as applying transformations
over a sliding window of data now as we
see here every time the window slides
over a source d stream the source rdds
that fall within the window are combined
and operated upon to produce the rdds of
windowed stream now in this specific
case we can say the operation is applied
over last three time units of data and
slides by two time units this shows that
any window operation needs to specify
two parameters one is the window length
which is basically the duration of
window so for example we can say three
as we see in the figure here and then
you have a sliding interval which is
basically the interval at which window
operation is performed so these two
parameters must be multiples of the
batch interval of source t stream so
that's what we do when we talk about
window now there are various other
transformations which can be applied or
window based operations which can be
done on your d streams here to talk a
little bit more on these streams which
is as i said it's a basic abstraction
provided by spark streaming it
represents a just remember it has a
continuous stream of data now either the
input data stream received from source
or the process data stream which is
generated by transforming the input
stream so a d stream is represented by
you could say a continuous series of
rdds which is sparks abstraction of a
immutable distributed data set so any
operation applied on a d stream it is
basically translating to operations on
the underlying rdds now for example we
can say converting a stream of lines to
word the flat map operation is applied
on each rdd in the lines now d stream to
generate the rdds of your words t stream
so when we talk about your discretized
streams understand that you would have a
series of transformations which would be
applied for this time interval whatever
has been specified now when you talk
about your streaming or smart streaming
architecture as i mentioned here that is
your receivers now that plays a very
important role here so your input d
streams or data streams are representing
the stream of input data that is
received from your streaming sources now
we could have different kind of data and
we could be doing different kind of
transformations so your receiver is
basically an object which receives the
data from a source and stores it in
sparks memory for processing and that's
the main role of your receiver now spark
streaming provides two categories of
building streaming sources so you have
basic sources that is sources directly
available in streaming context which is
a class we learn about it such as your
file systems or socket connections so
those could be your basic sources from
where the data is coming in you could
have advanced sources like your kafka
flume kinases etc and they would be
available through extra utility classes
so your receiver is going to be looking
into the data which is constantly
getting generated and then basically
forwarding it for processing by your
spark streaming you know when we talk
about your spark streaming one more
important aspect is basically
understanding the caching and
persistence now as we know from the spar
core engine or as you should know that
rdds are say your logical steps or rdds
are created when you perform some
transformations and these
transformations or these computations or
these rdds can be cached so that it can
improve the performance of your
application so the computed rdds or the
rdds which are result of some performing
some transformations they can be cached
so that they can be reutilized down your
application for your further processing
so when we talk about your caching and
persistence these streams also allows
developers to persist the stream data in
memory so similar to your concept of
rdds these streams can allow you to
persist the particular streams data in
memory now that is by doing or using
your persist method on a d stream which
will automatically persist every rdd of
that d stream in memory it could be
every rdd or it could be specifically
chosen rdds now this is really useful if
the data in d stream has to be or would
be computed multiple times say in your
application so for example if we say
window based operations like reduce by
window reduce by key and window wherein
you have group of operations being done
or you could have state based operations
like update state by key now in any of
these cases your d streams generated by
say window based operations are
automatically persisted in memory
without the developer calling for the
persist method now for input streams
that receive data over networks such as
kafka flume sockets etc the default
persistence level is set to replicate
the data to two nodes for fault
tolerance now one thing which we should
remember is unlike your rdds the default
persistence level of d streams keeps the
data data serialized in memory and that
we can discuss again further about your
serializations or deserialization now
one important aspect which takes care of
your fault recovery is check pointing
mechanism in sparks really now when i
say check pointing a streaming
application as uh in real scenario we
would want must operate 24 bar 7 and if
the streaming application is constantly
running then there has to be a mechanism
which can make your streaming
application resilient to failures which
can be unrelated to your application
logic so spark streaming needs to do the
check pointing it needs to checkpoint
enough information to a fault tolerant
underlying storage system such that it
can recover from failures so your check
pointing is the process to make
streaming applications more fault
tolerant or resilient to your failures
now this is usually used when you would
want to recover from failure of a node
running the driver of streaming
application now we know driver is
existing for every application and it is
basically one which knows the flow of
your application driver also has the
context in case of streaming application
we would have say the spark streaming
context which is the entry point of your
application now when we talk about your
checkpointing to ensure your streaming
application is more fault tolerant you
have two kinds of checkpointing here so
you could have a metadata checkpointing
and you could have data checkpointing
now when we talk about metadata what
does that include so metadata includes
configuration d stream operations or
even incomplete batches so when we talk
about metadata it has configurations
configuration that was used to create
the streaming application you could have
d stream operations that is set of d
stream operations that define the
streaming application that is your
series of rdds and then you have
incomplete batches or batches whose jobs
are queued but not have completed so
this would have to be check pointed so
metadata checkpointing is used for
recovering from a node failure running
the streaming application driver now
your metadata which has your
configuration incomplete batches and d
stream operations need to be saved in an
underlying storage system now when you
talk about data check pointing it is
mainly about saving the generated rtds
to reliable storage that is whatever
rdds are computed so saving the
information which is saving the
computations to a storage like sdfs now
that is used in stateful transformations
combining data across various batches so
when we talk about transformations
whatever rtds are generated that depend
on rdds of previous batches if we are
talking about stateful and that can
cause the length of dependency chain to
increase or keep increasing with time
now to avoid any kind of increase in the
recovery time intermediate rdds can be
periodically check pointed and that
could be done to a reliable storage to
basically cut off the growing dependency
changes so if we would want to summarize
we would say metadata checkpointing is
primarily needed for recovery from
driver failures whereas data or rdd
checkpointing is necessary even for
basic functioning if stateful
transformations are used and we should
remember we are talking about stateful
transformations here so when we talk
about checkpointing now the question is
when would you enable checkpointing or
what would you do to enable
checkpointing so checkpointing must be
enabled for applications with different
kind of requirements so for example if
you are using stateful transformations
where one series of rdds depend on the
result of your previous patches so
something like update state by key or
reduce by key in window now if these
kind of operations are used in your
application then checkpoint directory
must be provided to allow for periodic
rdd checkpoint when we say about
requirements then recovering from
failures of the driver which is taking
care of your application metadata
checkpoints should be used when we talk
about simple streaming applications
without the stateful transformations
they could be run without enabling
checkpointing because your one batch of
rdds really does not depend on the
previous set of rdds which were done in
the previous time frame now recovery
from driver failures will also be
partial in that case when you talk about
your stateless so some might be received
and your unprocessed data might be lost
but then that's pretty much acceptable
when you talk about spark streaming
applications so here we look at your
checkpointing so we say start now you
have a check pointing now whenever your
application is creating a streaming
context it would create it would set a
checkpoint path and then you would
define your d stream which is nothing
but series of your rdd transformations
your streaming context starts which is
basically your application entry point
into the cluster for processing and at
any point of time if there is any
failure you could always recover using
the check point which was created in
case of
spark streaming one more thing we need
to remember is that your check pointing
can be enabled by setting it directly in
a fault tolerant reliable file system
such as sdfs wherein the checkpointing
information will be saved so we will
have to add
some methods within your application
like swimming context with a checkpoint
and then pointing it to a checkpoint
directory and in that way we can have
our stateful transformations or metadata
information stored in the underlying
storage whichever we have chosen now
that we have discussed about spark
streaming some basics of spark streaming
let's also understand about shared
variables or what we call as accumulator
and broadcast variables so normally when
you talk about your spark operations
such as your map or reduce these are
executed on one of the node of your
cluster and what happens is when you
talk about your operations they work on
separate copies of all variables used in
the function now in this case variables
are copied to each machine and no
updates to the variables on remote
machines are propagated back to the
driver program now when we talk about
read write shared variables across tasks
that would be inefficient so spark
actually provides two limited types of
shared variables for common usage
patterns and those are your broadcast
variables and your accumulators now when
you talk about your accumulators these
are variables that are only added
through an associative or commutative
operation so spark natively supports
accumulators of numeric types and
programmers can add support for your new
types so when we talk about accumulators
they can be used to implement counters
such as your mapreduce or sums so as a
user you can create named or unnamed
accumulators now as we see in the image
here in named accumulator in this
instance counter will display in web ui
for the stage that modifies that
accumulator spark displays the value for
each accumulator modified by a task in
the tasks table now tracking
accumulators in the ui can be useful for
understanding the progress of your
running stages but we should remember
that as of now this is not supported in
python might be in future the support
for python will also be added now when
you talk about your accumulators you can
have say a numeric accumulator created
by calling a spark context and its
method such as long accumulator or you
could have double accumulator to
accumulate values of type long or double
respectively so tasks running on a
cluster can then add to it using the add
method now we cannot i mean in this case
the value cannot be read but driver
program can read the accumulator's value
using its value method we can look at
some examples to understand this later
now when you talk about your broadcast
variables that is one more type of
variables which allows the programmers
to keep a read only variable cached on
each machine rather than shipping a copy
of it with tasks now what we know is
sometimes you might be doing very
costlier operations like joins where you
might be working on multiple rdds they
need to be joined and these rtds could
also be pair rdds which could be key
value pairs now whenever you are
performing a join there would be kind of
two level of shuffling one within a
particular rdd so if you are joining two
rdds the first rdd which might have data
in the form of key value pairs that rdd
would have to have some shuffling where
all the similar keys can be brought into
one partition and this would happen on
the second rtd also which has again key
value pairs and then if you're doing a
join these rtds will be shipped to the
node or basically the data would be
loaded in the memory and then basically
your transformations will happen this
can be a costlier affair so what can be
done is you could create broadcast
variables so for example if we have two
rdds and we want to perform a join
operation and if one rdd is known to be
smaller then we can create a broadcast
variable of the smaller rdd so that this
variable itself can be shipped to each
machine and then this variable can be
used for your join operations with the
other rdd which is existing in the
memory of those nodes so that saves time
and that improves your performance so
spark basically attempts to distribute
the broadcast variable using efficient
broadcast algorithms to reduce the
communication cost now if for example
you have multiple nodes in a cluster and
if you would want to give every node a
copy of large input data set in an
efficient manner so spark actions are
executed through a set of stages now we
know that and stages are separated by
your shuffle operations so whenever we
talk about narrow dependencies such as
map flat map filter you would not have
any shuffling involved but if you go for
group by key reduce by key and such
operations to bring the similar keys
together there would be shuffling
involved and also this applies when
you're doing some join operations so in
that case broadcast variables could be a
really plus where one set of data or rdd
which is already computed that could be
broadcasted to other nodes so the data
broadcasted will be cached in serialized
form and deserialized before running
each task this means that explicitly
creating broadcast variables can be
useful when tasks across multiple stages
need the same data or when caching the
data in deserialized form is important
so we can create broadcast variables
using spark context and its method
called broadcast and your broadcast
variable can then be shipped to other
nodes which can be used for your other
operations now when you talk about smart
streaming it is used in various use
cases i mean you could talk about speech
recognition you could talk about
sentiment analysis you could talk about
uh streaming applications which would be
performing some kind of
analytics on the data which is coming in
it is also used widely in retail chain
companies now if you look at the example
here so big retail chain companies would
want to build real-time dashboards so
that they can keep a track of their
inventory and operations and for this
they would need one streaming data or
data which is constantly getting
generated at source which needs to be
processed on and this information can
then be populating your dashboards to
give you a real-time scenario or
real-time information of what is
happening so in case of an inventory
dashboard you could use then these
interactive dashboards
wherein you could draw insights about
the business and that's what retail
companies are doing so how many products
are being purchased or products that
have been shipped or how many products
have been delivered to customers and
this kind of information would be good
to capture in real time so when the
streaming data is basically being
processed so at one end you have your
data which is getting generated that
might be based on the sales which are
happening that might be based on the
products which are being shipped or that
might be based on the acknowledgement
that the products have been received now
while this data is getting generated at
various sources it can be subjected to a
smart streaming application which will
look into the streaming data perform
series of transformations which you
would want to process the data at
regular time intervals and then pushing
it to your dashboards or to your storage
layer wherein it could then be used to
answer such questions so when we talk
about spark streaming it's an ideal
choice to process this kind of data in
real time and there are various use
cases so at one end if you see you have
a input stream which shows the product
status that is how many products were
purchased or shipped or delivered now
this would be then handled by your spark
streaming and also your spar core engine
which would then process the data to
give you an output stream which gives
you a status
such as what was the total count of
products which were purchased products
which were shipped and products which
were delivered so this was a quick and
brief introduction to spark streaming
and how it works now we can also see how
spark streaming works or how we create
an application for that what we can do
is we can basically set up our eclipse
to have your scala based spark
applications and for that what you could
do is you could have your eclipse
which can then be having a scala plug-in
added to it now if somebody would want
to look at the scala plug-in then you
can always go to scala.ibe.org
and this is the place where you can
scroll towards the bottom you can click
on stable and that basically also shows
you a video how scala plug-in can be
added to your eclipse it also tells from
where you can get the scala latest
release and this can be added to your
eclipse so in my case it has already
been added to the eclipse i'm bringing
it up here and then you can have your
applications built using your ide people
would prefer to use intellij and that's
also fine so you could also look for
videos on setting up intellij with your
scala plug-in now there are two ways one
you can build your application run it on
your windows machine when you could have
some kind of utility like net cat which
can be used to send in some messages in
a streaming fashion you could have a
receiver which looks at a particular
socket at a particular port and you
could build a streaming application
within your ide run it on your windows
machine in a local mode which would then
be looking at your source where the data
is getting generated that's one option
the second option is you could build
your application package it as jar and
then run it on a cluster now that could
be a spark standalone cluster or spark
with yarn and then you could be
packaging your application using tools
like sbt and then use spark submit to
submit your application now i'll show
you both the ways in which you can work
with streaming applications so first is
get your eclipse and make sure that
scala plugin is already added now in my
case on the right top corner i see scala
symbol that says i can be using scholar
perspective now here i have some
projects so what you can do is you can
create a project by saying new scala
project you can give it a name so for
example i could say my apps3 and then
you can say finish so that creates a
project now within your project what you
can do is you can create a package so
for example i could say something like
main dot scholar and then say finish so
that creates your package now also one
thing to remember is it would be good to
change your compiler instead of 2.12 to
2.11 normally for different environments
you might have spark with different
versions and scala with two pointer 2.11
so it would be good to have the compiler
change to the bundle 2.11 so we can
select this project i can do a right
click i can go to the build path i can
say configure build path and then i can
click on scala compiler where i will use
project settings and i will choose to
2.11 bundle so that would make sure that
your applications can compile just say
okay it might say the compiler settings
have changed a full rebuild is required
for changes to take effect just hit on
ok so that's the first thing you need to
do the second thing is for your code to
compile it would be good to have your
jars added to your build path now we
could do that or as i said you could be
writing your application which might not
compile within your ide but you could
package it using sbt and then run it as
jar so what i'm doing here is on my
machine within my c drive i already have
spark distribution which i've downloaded
so basically i have downloaded spark and
then untied it so spark 2.4.3 i have
unzipped or untied it i have kept it in
my c and this basically has my spark now
within which i have my jars and this has
all my spark related jars so technically
speaking i can even use windows command
line and i can start working on spark in
an interactive way or packaging my
application and running it in a local
mode so you could also do this so
basically have your spark and then if
you see on my desktop i have a hadoop
folder within which i have a bin folder
and within which i have a win utils.exe
and this will be basically required when
you want to try out your spark based
applications whether that is streaming
or data frames to be tested on your
windows machine so you can always search
and download the winutils.exe
place it in a hadoop folder within the
bin folder on your machine so once you
get your vinnutils.exe
once you have your charts what you can
do is for your project you can just say
right click you can go to the build path
and you can say configure build path and
here you had add external jars so we can
select all of these jars here which i
would want to add to my build path so
that my code can compile and i can test
it on the windows machine itself i can
say open and then just basically do
apply and okay so that has created my
project with a package my compiler is
changed to 2.11 i have added the
external jars the spark related jars and
that is good enough for my code now what
we need is a streaming application which
we need to build so let me show you from
my existing project how it looks like so
within your source the same way i have
main package and here i have a streaming
application so this streaming
application is to test or to work on
capturing the data which is generated at
this particular stream on a particular
ip and a particular port and i would
want to do some series of
transformations on that so this gives me
an example of doing a word count and
then i would want to print the results i
could also be saving the output in a
particular location so for this
application we need basically to import
certain packages that is say spark
streaming spark context and also you
have spark conf so these are the
packages which we need to import now
here i have created an object i have
called as fifth app and i'm saying
extends app and this is because within
my project i already have an application
which has been defined as main so if
your application has been defined as
main one application is already existing
then you can just have your new objects
with extending app so we don't need to
define the main method here now here i'm
saying val conf new spark conf so i'm
creating a configuration object i'm
setting my application name and to test
it on windows we will have to set the
master as local and it is advisable to
give it more than one thread because you
would be creating a receiver within your
application that would utilize one
thread so here i am saying set master
local and then i am saying two threads i
am also creating my spark context which
we need to initialize based on the
configuration object we just created in
the previous step then we need to create
a spark streaming context and this
streaming context depends on spark
context and i've given a time interval
of 10 seconds so this is the time
interval which i am setting for which i
would want to work on the stream of data
which comes in every 10 seconds on a
particular socket now here we are
setting up a receiver so i say stream
rdd which is basically be spark
streaming context and then you use your
socket text stream now there are various
methods of spark streaming context for
example if i just go here and if i just
do a dot it shows me what are the
different options you have file stream
you have q stream you have socket stream
receiver stream and so on so i am using
socket text stream and i would want to
point it to this machine so i'll say
127.0.0.1
i will also specify port 2222 okay and
here once i have created my
configuration object my spark context my
spark streaming context with the time
interval and i have set my receiver to
use the socket text stream method on
this particular ip on this particular
port now then i am specifying what i
would want to do on the data which gets
generated on this machine at this
particular port so i'm saying val word
counts so i would want to work on the
stream rdd that is the d stream i would
want to do a flat map on it to split the
data based on space i would want to map
every word to word comma 1 and then i
would want to do a reduce by key now
reduce by key you can pass in
specifically the function you would want
to do i could do a count of this i could
print the result or i could even save it
with an output using the java method to
create a random string attached to the
output once you're done with this here
i'm mentioning spark streaming context
start now this will basically trigger my
spark streaming context to start and it
will run till we terminate this
application now here to run this on
windows machine you can always look into
your run configuration and what i have
done is in my environment i basically
want to use
let's say okay now let's look at the
configuration what you need to set so
here i have
my streaming application and let's look
at the run configuration which basically
shows my application has started and
it's running on the environment so if
you see here i have added hadoop
underscore home pointing to this hadoop
directory which has been and when utils
x i have also given spark local ip which
is
127.0.0.1 so that is my run
configuration now if you see here my
streaming application has started my
streaming application has not yet
started probably it is running a
different application so we can come
back and check this so we can go to run
as scala application and let's see what
it does so it tries to connect to
127.0.0.1
so receiver is trying to do that but it
does not find anything on that
particular machine on that particular
port so my receiver is not able to find
it is not able to establish a connection
now what i can do is i can go to my
command line and here i will go into
downloads so i've already downloaded the
netcat utility for windows and here we
can basically search for something which
i have on my machine within downloads
and that is your netcat utility so what
i would do is i will come back here and
i would say nc.exe
lvp and then i could say my port which i
have specified in my streaming
application and i can just start this
netcat utility now here it says
listening on 222 it says connection to
127.0.0.1
and then if i look in the background my
receiver will now be able to establish a
connection establish a connection with
this netcat utility now whatever i type
here will be taken for processing every
10 seconds and we would see a word count
while my application is running so let's
test this so i'll say this is a test
test
is being done and as soon as i pass in
this message we see that there is a word
count happening for the stream of data
which is coming in we can say winters
are coming winters will be cold and once
i given these messages we will see our
streaming application which will try to
work on the data which is coming in and
process it and show us the result so we
can say this is a test
of winters and let's see if it continues
to do the processing and shows us doubt
right so my streaming application is
running fine it is looking at the words
which we are passing in and we can say
if it is able to process my data and
every 10 seconds the tech stock socket
stream is looking on this machine at
this particular port doing a series of
transformations and these series of
transformations and then are seen within
your console now in my application if i
had
used word counts dot save as text file
then i could also have my output getting
generated at every 10 second interval
and that would get saved here i could
also decide to have my output saved and
stored on a sdfs or any other storage so
this is a simple streaming application
what we saw which is using socket tech
stream it is looking at this machine on
a particular port where we are running a
netcat utility it does
series of your rdd transformations that
is flat map map and then you're reduced
by key and finally we are invoking an
action such as print which basically
triggers these rdds which work on my
streaming data so this is one example
now what i could also be doing is this
is particularly my application now i
already have sbt for windows installed
so i can be going into my project space
so i could say workspace i could go into
my apps and i'm in my project folder so
i could say sbt package and this will
basically then based on my build file
which i already have within my project
folder so if you see here this is my
build file which says name the version
scala version spark version and the
repository with the spark to manage the
dependencies for all its components like
spark core sql ml streaming and hype so
you need to have this build dot sbt file
within your project folder which can be
used to package your application as jar
now we have done the packaging and it
shows me that it has created a jar of my
applications within this particular
folder now once i have this i can
basically then import this package into
my cluster where i can run it on a
cluster using spark submit now to run
the spark streaming application on a
cluster here i have a two node cluster
which will then have my spark standalone
cluster you could look at the previous
videos which is where and i explain how
to set up a spark standalone cluster now
here i can go into the spark directory
and then i could just say s bin start
all dot sh which will start by spark
master and worker node now i do have
hadoop cluster also set up on this but
right now i'm running a spark standalone
cluster which shows me i have a master
and worker process on this machine and i
have a worker process on this machine so
my spark standalone cluster is running
we can always bring up the ui to see how
it looks like so here i can just be
giving http
slash um one eight zero eight zero so
that's my spark standalone cluster with
two worker nodes right now there is no
application running we can come back
here and we can check if we have my jar
file so i've already placed my jar here
now at any point of time if you have
your jar which has been packaged you can
always go and do a jar minus xvf and you
can choose your jar to see what is
within your jar which i've already done
on this machine so if i look in the main
folder i have scala and within scala if
you see these are the different classes
what we have so my code was packaged as
a jar it has a fifth app class which we
would want to run here so what i can do
is i can just be saying spark
submit because now i would want my
application to run on the cluster so i
can say class main dot scala and then my
object name so i will say fifth app now
that's my class my jar is this one and
we will also say master which is going
to be spark which is running on um one
and it listens on 7077 port so that
would basically start my streaming
application but what we would also need
is like our windows we would also need
some utility like netcat so basically
what i can do is i can here use a netcat
utility to basically connect or send in
some messages for our streaming
application so let's say let me search
if i have already the net cat which i
might have used here so let's see so we
on your window machine you will have to
install your netcat utility by saying a
apt-get netcat so here i can say nc
minus l and then i can say port which is
two two two two so we can see if this is
working so this is a test and let's see
if it works so let's start our
application streaming application which
then needs the receiver to establish a
connection with the particular machine
and let's see if that is done so here i
could also be cancelling this and give
it a particular port so i can say 192
168 0.18 now the only problem is when we
packaged our application when we
packaged our application we should be
specifically giving the ip and also
comment out the local so when i package
this to run on the cluster i commented
out this part and i obviously would not
be giving 127 but the ip where my net
cat is running so right now let's test
it so we will say this
is a test new test for our application
and i'm sending in some messages so it
is already doing the word count as we
expected it to do and if while we are
doing it if you come back here so you
would see your application is now
running on the cluster so it is my
application it is using four cores what
is the memory per executor and you can
basically click on your application now
here you can look at the application
detail ui to see what is being done so
for our application we have streaming
job running receiver which says this is
my application it says it is running you
can basically click at this click on
this and it says your dag visualization
which will say the streaming job which
is running you can look at the stages if
you would want to see if there are
multiple stages which we don't have
because we are not doing any wider
transformation we can look at storage if
we have used some persisting or caching
we can look at the executors which are
being used and one of the important
things when you talk about your
streaming is the streaming tab which
gets activated now that does not show up
when you run your batch applications but
in your streaming applications you have
the ui shows you the streaming tab and
that basically says running batches of
10 seconds for 2 minutes 9 seconds
already now we see the input rate we see
the receivers we see if there is any
delay in scheduling what is the
processing time how many batches it has
completed and it basically shows me what
is the processing time how many tasks
were run and so on so my application is
running fine and unless and until we go
ahead and cancel this my application
will continue to run it will keep
looking for messages which we keep
typing in so for example if i would want
to just copy this and start again where
i would keep passing in this is say test
one test one is this where we test
streaming application right and i can be
seeing that my messages are being
processed i'm getting a word count so we
can say winter winter summer old winter
and you can always look at if your
streaming application is doing the word
count so this is a simple way where you
can run your streaming application
either on a windows machine in a local
mode or you could be running on a spark
standalone cluster or you could also
deploy your application to run on a yarn
based cluster now that we have seen a
streaming application which does a word
count it will be interesting to also see
the window based computation or
windowing operation which is supported
in spark streaming as i explained and
for that we can look at a different
application here which is streaming with
a window option let's look into this
what this application does so here i am
importing some packages that is
streaming streaming context your spark
in spark context spark configuration i
am also using the spark api java
function and then using spark streaming
api and i'm also using storage level
because i also intend to have the
persistence or caching done now here we
create an application say streaming app
extends app we create our configuration
object where we say app name and then we
set master with appropriate number of
threads we create the spark streaming
context that's we initialize it and then
we have the spark streaming context
which depends on sc and we have given a
time interval of 10 seconds we then set
up a receiver so we say stream rdd which
will use socket text stream like we did
earlier with which will look for this
particular machine at this port wherein
i'm also using storage level so what i
would want is that the data stream which
would get generated here every 10
seconds should be cached in memory now
we could use different storage levels
that is we could use memory only disk
only memory and disk you could have
memory and disk with replication factor
so you have different storage levels now
here we are then doing some series of
transformations like what we did earlier
but if you see in my previous example we
just had reduce by key and here i'm
using a transformation which is reduced
by key and window now this one basically
takes the function as i said the
windowing takes associative or
commutative functions so instead of
using the shortcut wave we will be
specifying our function so we say it
takes a and b and basically it uses this
function now here we have to give the
interval that is 30 seconds that's my
window time frame and then within that
what will be my each interval which we
would want to look at so these are the
two main aspects one is using your
window based transformation and then
also specifying your time interval for
your windowing which basically means we
would still do a word count but then
here we would basically not only be
doing a word count for every 10 seconds
for the data which is coming in here but
we would also want to have a
consolidated set of computation done
every 30 seconds so that is looking at
the last three time intervals now if you
also notice i am also doing a
checkpointing here wherein i have not
specified a specific directory but what
i am saying here is i would want to
checkpoint or i would want to basically
save my computations for any kind of
fault recovery now this is a streaming
application with window based
computation we are using storage level
for persistence we are also doing the
check pointing which takes care of fault
recovery now to run this application we
have already set our environment
variables and so on so i can basically
start this application by just doing a
run as scala application now this would
start my streaming application with
window based computations now we can
open up our command line where we would
want to start a netcat utility so i
could go to downloads let me just
minimize this window here and what i can
do is i can then be starting my netcat
utility so i could say nc.exe
minus lvp and on a port 222. as soon as
i do this in background my application
receiver will be able to establish
connection to this netcat utility
running on this particular port now
that's done so we can see if the word
count happens for our 10 second interval
so let's do that so i'll say this is my
first test and if i do this it should
give me the word count for the data
which i have passed in now i can say
this is my second test this
is my third test and if you see here it
basically is doing this now if i say
this is my first test again so since we
are doing window based operation also we
will see a consolidated set of
transformations which happen for a
window of three intervals so if you see
here now my this is giving me a count
but it is not showing me totally this as
4 or say this because it is only looking
at a window of last two or three time
intervals so now it is back because it
is looking at the last one so if i say
this is my test test is done test is
done so if you do this it will show you
the word count which is for whatever you
have passed in like test is done is
twice test is thrice but then since
windowing based operation is done you
will look at the time interval of the
messages which were passed within that
particular window now we can also since
my application is running and it is on
windows we can bring up your spark ui so
i can go to http and slash slash i can
be looking at my machine and the port so
for example i could do this this shows
my streaming application which is
running in wherein i can see the window
based application which is running but
what would be interesting is to look at
the stages if there is any kind of
shuffling which is happening
looking at the storage should show me
the persistence which we are doing now
if you see here it shows me that we have
been persisting in the memory what size
it occupies how many partitions were
cached and this is because of the
persistence or the storage level what we
have used as memory only now if we
change that to disk we will see our rdds
will be cached on disk and then you can
look at your streaming tab which gives
you more information about your batches
so this is a very simple example
obviously you can change what kind of
rtd computations you would want to do
here whether you want to do a word count
or something else whether you want to
save your processed output now here we
are able to do that you can always do a
refresh on your project and here what we
see is we see some entries of a folder
getting created right and we can decide
whether we would want our output to be
created we can also see within this what
would be containing and since we have
said checkpointing in the project folder
it would also be checkpointing
temporarily the information for any kind
of failure so this is a classic example
of streaming application using window
based computations persisting your
computations and also doing the check
pointing simultaneously apache spark ml
lib which is one of the important
components used by developers or users
for building their machine learning
algorithms now here in this tutorial we
will learn about what is spark ml lift
what is machine learning about machine
learning algorithms you have spark mlip
tools and different data types that it
supports machine learning pipelines
machine learning library algorithms and
then we can have a quick demo on spark
ml lib use case now when we talk about
spark mlip of different components in
spark such as spark streaming rdds your
data frames or data sets you have spark
ml lib which stands for machine learning
library and spark the goal of this
library is to make practical machine
learning scalable and easy to implement
now when we talk about mlib this is
spark's machine learning library and
basically it provides tools such as ml
algorithms which include common learning
algorithms such as classification
regression clustering and collaborative
filtering it also gives you
featurization that is feature extraction
transformation dimensionality reduction
and selection you have pipelines that is
tools for constructing evaluating and
tuning ml pipelines it has the features
for persistence that is saving and load
algorithms models and pipelines and then
you also have utilities for your linear
algebra statistics data handling etc so
when you talk about your ml lib it has a
data frame based api which is a primary
api now as of spark 2 onwards the rdd
based api that is in the spark ml
package entered a maintenance mode and
your primary machine learning api for
spark now is data frame based api that
is spark.ml we'll learn about that now
when you talk about machine learning and
sparks ml lib it basically works on data
which is collected it can process the
data that is you can build your machine
learning algorithms using spark ml lip
it also helps you in building data
models which can then be used for
further processing so before we
understand about spark ml lip and its
features and its capabilities it will be
good to learn about what is machine
learning now machine learning is the
science of training computers to learn
from data and perform specific tasks
without being explicitly programmed and
when i say training computers it is
basically training computers or making
your algorithms learn by themselves
based on the input which is provided you
have lot of use cases for machine
learning uh recently i have been working
in autonomous driving space and again
there is lot of usage of machine
learning algorithms especially in driver
assistance systems object classification
or even autonomous driving you have
various use cases where
think about your mailbox where you
receive emails and they are
automatically filtered and pushed into a
spam folder now how does that happen so
there is a machine learning algorithm
running in the background which looks at
the content of the data probably looks
at some words or patterns and identifies
your mail as a spam take an example of
google search where you would want to
search something and your auto complete
feature allows you to complete what you
would want to search for and then helps
you in finding something other companies
can be something like linkedin where you
have data driven services based on the
connections a particular user has based
on the posting a user has done you could
have recommendations based on courses or
job openings and so on and this is
happening based on recommendation
systems which are also a form of machine
learning algorithms so when you talk
about your machine learning you have to
have human intervention so you would
have data which might be accumulated now
that might be batch data that might be
streaming data and your algorithms or
computer or system has to learn from the
past data and then it should be able to
predict the output now when we talk
about analytics there are different kind
of analytics you have prescriptive
analytics descriptive analytics you have
statistical analytics you have
preemptive analytics and you have
predictive analytics and in various
scenarios machine learning plays a very
important role it's an important branch
of artificial intelligence now when you
talk about machine learning algorithms
they can be classified mainly into three
main categories you have supervised
learning based algorithms that is
algorithms which depend on labeled data
or data which has response based on the
features and which makes it easier to
predict the output now you might also
have unsupervised learning algorithms
that do not have labeled data or do not
have responses so they have unlabeled
data and it is used to discover patterns
from the data you could also have
reinforcement based algorithms and in
reinforcement learning algorithms an
agent receives a reward in the next time
step to evaluate its previous action so
these are three main categories of your
machine learning algorithms now if we
would want to learn more on supervised
learning look at the image here which
says labeled data of dogs and cats and
if this is the kind of data which is fed
into your algorithm would process the
data wherein it would again depend on
the labels so looking at the images
labels would say well the first part of
the image is dogs or you have cats and
so on now once the data is processed
then you could say your algorithm is
trained or the model which is being used
is trained based on the past data which
was fed in and then you have your
trained model which basically can then
look at an unknown piece of data to
predict the outcome so you could be
working on label data training your
model and then basically the same model
can be tested against a data which does
not have a label but your algorithm
would be able to successfully classify
or identify the object now when you talk
about supervised learning it is
classified into regression and
classification so you have various
different techniques you have linear
regression you have logistic regression
you have decision tree random forest
support vector machines k nearest
neighbors name base and so on so when
you talk about these one of the primary
criteria of choosing supervised learning
depends on the data what you have and
whether that data has label or no plus
it also depends on what is the kind of
output which is expected and based on
that one which is a data scientist or a
developer would choose if he or she
would go with linear regression or
logistic regression decision tree or
anything else when you talk about
unsupervised learning now this is where
your data is still fed to the algorithm
but here our data does not have a label
or a response now how does the algorithm
work in that way so algorithm would look
at the features now for example if you
look at the image we might say feature
would be color of the element or the
size of the element or basically the
shape of the element or anything else
which can categorize or help us in
identifying the object so your
unsupervised learning based algorithms
would learn the patterns in the data and
based on that you would have your
trained model which could then classify
your group your objects into specific
groups which have similar kind of
characteristics now again for your
unsupervised learning that can be
classified into clustering and
association rules so you have various
again techniques and models here such as
k-means clustering quite popular one you
have hierarchical clustering you have
dbs scan you have principal component
analysis gaussian mixture and hidden
markov process if you talk about
reinforcement learning so in
reinforcement learning it basically has
to interpret the shape now when we talk
about reinforcement learning as i said
an agent is provided a reward to
identify a particular pattern then you
could have your trained model which
basically would identify the element
based on the shape or any other pattern
now for your reinforcement learning the
proper popular algorithms or techniques
are your q learning temporal learning
and your general adverse real networks
now when you talk about spark ml lip
tools spark mlf component provides
different tools so when you talk about
your ml algorithms you have your
classification regression clustering and
collaborative filtering you also have
for featurization that is your feature
extraction transformation dimensionality
reduction and selection for your
pipelines you have tools for
constructing and evaluating tuning or
tuning your ml pipelines for persistence
you have saving and loading algorithms
models and pipelines and then you have
different utilities such as linear
algebra statistics data handling and so
on so when we talk about data types so
your spark ml lib supports different
data types so it supports local vectors
and matrices stored on a single machine
as well as distributed matrices
now for your spark mlab data types as i
said it supports your local vectors and
matrices so it supports many data types
your machine learning library now you
have local vectors and matrices which
can be stored on a single machine or you
could have your distributed matrices
which are backed by one or more rdds so
your local vectors and local matrices
are simple data models they can be
serving as public interfaces now you
have
certain tools like breeze which offers
the underlying linear algebra operations
a training example which we use in
supervised learning is what we call a
labeled point in mlip now when you talk
about your data types your categories
could be local vector it could be
labeled point it could be local matrix
and it could be distributed matrix and
then you have other criteria such as row
matrix index draw matrix coordinate
matrix and block matrix so when you talk
about your data types now on the left we
look at local vectors where we are
seeing a vector with certain values you
could have different formats supported
here that is dense format or sparse
format so if you would want to
understand about vector data types let's
see this so in your dense vector data
types a vector which is backed by a
double array representing its entry
values known as dense vector so here we
are looking at a double array
representation now when you talk about
your sparse format this is a vector
which is backed by two parallel arrays
or two parallel array-like
elements so you have indices and values
which are shown here in sparse vector
now we could we could represent a vector
such as seen on the first line 1.0 0.0
and 3.0 in a dense format as a list of
elements or in a sparse format where we
give the size of it by specifying 3 and
then we give our elements that is we are
giving here 0 comma 2 and you are 1.0
and 3.0 so here 3 is the size of the
vector vector being the base class of
your local vectors and it provides two
implementations such as your dense or
sparse vector now we can basically
create uh these tens vectors using
sparse mlib package that is linear
algebra which then supports your vector
and your dense vectors for both the
formats we would have to import also
some packages like scala dot collection
immutable vector or
algebra dot vector we will talk about
that later again in detail when you talk
about your labeled point data types
whether you are talking about dens or
sparse which is associated with a label
or a response so a label point is a
local vector which could be of any of
these types such as dense and sparse
which is associated with a label or a
response so basically when we talk about
your supervised learning algorithms they
use labeled points right because
supervised learning algorithms depend on
labels now here we use a double to store
a label therefore we can use label
points in both regression as well as
classification now a label could either
be zero that is negative or one which is
positive for binary classification but
if you have multi-class classification
labels should be class indices starting
from zero such as zero one 2 and
a label point is represented by your
case class called labeled point now you
have other data types also other than
your local vector and label point so you
basically have local matrix now this has
an integer type row and column indices
and double type values that is stored in
a single machine now here when we talk
about your mlib mlib supports dense
matrices in which entry values are
stored in a single double array in
columns as we see here with major order
now when you talk about
non-zero entry values they are stored in
compressed sparse column format now if
we talk about an example let's look at
this matrix what we are seeing here
which has 1.0 2.0 3.0 4.0 5 and 6. now
your one dimensional array is
represented in the form of matrix which
has a size of three into two here matrix
or matrix is the base class of local
matrix it provides again two
implementations you can have a dense
matrix and sparse matrix and to create
local matrices we can use different
factory methods implemented in matrices
now when you talk about your distributed
matrix that has a long typed row and
column adhesives and double typed values
so this is when you would have
your distributed matrix stored
distributively in one or more rdds it is
actually very important to choose the
right format to store large and
distributed matrices so converting a
distributed matrix to a different format
can lead or can need a global shuffle
which is quite expensive so there are
four types of distributed matrices so
you have row matrix and spark ml lip
which is a row oriented distributed
matrix without having any meaningful row
indices you can say it is mainly
dependent on rdd of its rows where each
row is like a local vector when you talk
about something like indexed row matrix
the difference with if you compare your
indexed row matrix with just your row
matrix is that you have some row indices
here so index row matrix is backed by an
rdd of indexed rows in comparison to row
matrix which is rdd of rows now here the
index is long typed and a local vector
represents its every row you could also
have a coordinate matrix which is backed
by rdd of its entries so we can say each
entry is a tuple here of you can say i
as long j is long and value as double so
it's a row index where you could have a
column index and the value so these are
your different types when it comes to
your distributed matrix you also have
something called as block matrix which
we did not see here but when you say
block matrix it is basically rdd of
matrix blocks now to understand matrix
block it is a tuple of int comma int
comma matrix so to understand these
different data types we can look at some
examples and then it would be more clear
in understanding different data types
which your mlib supports when we talk
about your mlib basic statistics now
just looking at an example here mlib
provides summary statistics for rdd that
is basically a vector through the
function call stats available in
statistics packages so we could be using
say by spark to work on mlib so you have
pi spark dot mlib dot stat and you could
import statistics you could have your
spark context initialized you could have
your rdd of vectors and then you could
compute column summary statistics using
your call stats on your rdt so here we
say summary equals statistics dot call
stats on mat and then we could print the
mean variance or num of nonzero so call
stat returns the column wise max minimum
mean variance number of non-zero values
and the total count now this is just a
simple example of using your mlib and
the statistics package if you look
further and if we look at this example
where we say mlab can perform
correlation between two series of data
again using your statistics package now
in this example we see we are using the
pi spark mlib stat where we import the
statistics package we would define our
spark context we would then have our
series now when we say series x and
series y we are talking about two series
on which we would want to perform
correlation so you have a series and the
other series must have the same number
of partitions and cardinality as your
series x now you could be computing the
correlation using pearson's method you
could enter spare man for spare man's
method and if a method is not specified
pearson's method will be used by default
so here we are saying print statistics
dot correlation that is corr on these
two series and the method which we
specify is person then we have data
that's an rdd of vectors so based on the
type of input if there are two rdds
which are of double type or an rdd of a
vector type the output would be a double
or a correlation matrix so this example
just says that you could calculate the
correlation matrix using pearson's
method and you could also be using
spearman for using your spearmin method
when we say print statistics correlation
i could be saying i would want to work
on a data which is a double rdd or an
rdd of vector and then i could be
specifying my method this is just a
simple example of using spark mlib
statistics basic package now when you
talk about samplifying methods you have
sample by key and sample by key exact
that can be performed on rdds of key
value pairs or rdds which have been
converted as key value pairs so your
sample by key exact is not currently
supported in python but in future the
support might be added now this sample
by key method or function will flip a
coin to decide whether an observation
will be sampled or not you specify your
spark context you specify the data that
is an rdd of any key value pairs you
give fractions that is specified the
exact fraction desired from each key as
a dictionary and then we use sample by
key method saying data dot sample by key
false and the fraction so this is again
one example and we can look for these
examples when we are looking into the
demo of your mlip if you talk about your
random data generation then your random
data generation is used for randomized
algorithms prototyping and also
performance testing so if you would want
to generate a random double rdd whose
values follow the standard normal
distribution of 0 comma 1 and then map
it to a distribution of 1 comma 4 we
could be using the random package here
so we say from pi spark dot random
import random rdds you create your spark
context now our aim would be to generate
a random double rdd that contains 1
million iid values drawn from the
standard normal distribution evenly
distributed in 10 partitions so what we
could do here is we could have your
random rdds dot uniform rtd and here i
specify my spark context i give the
range and then basically i say the
number of partitions so if you would
want to apply a transform transformation
to get a random double rdds following
the distribution of 1 comma 4 we could
be using u which is random rdt's dot
uniform rdd you do a map and you use the
lambda function to basically pass in the
function which you would want to apply
to get a double or a random double rdd
with normal distribution of one comma
four now when you talk about machine
learning pipelines now that is basically
understanding your different stages and
that might include something like
estimator something which is evaluated
or you could also have your transformer
so machine learning pipelines provide a
uniform set of high level apis which is
built on top of data frames and it is
usually and mainly used with your
structured data or data which can be
structuralized so it is used to create
and tune practical machine learning
pipelines so as i said when you talk
about your pipelines it would have
basically your different stages so when
we talk about data frame or in the older
version of spark which was called as
schema rdds so a data frame from spark
sql is used as a machine learning data
set it holds a variety of data types
such as text feature vectors and labels
now you also have something like a
transformer algorithm which is used to
transform one data frame into another
data frame you have estimator which
gives you a model so an estimator is an
algorithm which can be applied or fit on
a data frame to produce a transformer or
to give you a model and then basically
you can have also an evaluator which
will evaluate the model which was
created now what when we talk about
pipeline overall pipeline integrates
your multiple transformers and
estimators to specify a machine learning
workflow now when we talk about your
machine learning there are two important
pipeline components you have transformer
which basically works on a data frame
transforms it to create one more data
frame when you talk about your estimator
you have a fit method which gives you a
model or you can say a transformer which
can be used for your further data
processing now before we understand
about classification and regression in
ml lib we can just understand a little
bit more on the classification and
regression and what does that mean
before we understand what are the
different types for these two different
type of algorithms so when i talk about
classification and regression in mlib or
in specifically machine learning and
statistics classification is a
supervised learning approach in which
your algorithm or computer program
learns from the data input given to it
and then uses this learning to classify
new observation now this data set may
simply be
by class like identifying whether the
person is male or female or that male is
spam or non-spam or it may be a
multi-class tool so when you talk about
different classification problems you
can have use cases such as speech
recognition handwriting recognition
biometric identification document
classification and so on when we talk
about different types of classification
algorithms in machine learning then we
have your linear classifiers such as
logistic regression you have name base
classifier you have nearest neighbor you
have support vector machines decision
trees boosted trees random forest and
neutral networks if we talk about
regression in machine learning then
regression models are used to predict a
continuous value so predicting prices of
a house given the features of house like
size price etc or you could be having
different other examples so it's again a
supervised technique and when you talk
about types of regression you could have
simple linear regression you could have
decision tree regression random forest
you have support vector you have
isotonic you have gradient boosted and
polynomial regression now when you talk
about regression you could have your
linear regression or you would have your
logistic regression in case of your
logistic regression this is used in
different social and science
applications it is used when your
dependent variable or target is
categorical now take an example if you
would want to predict an email spam then
it could have an option as one or zero
which basically means whether the email
is spam or it's not or take an example
of
checking if a tumor is malignant and
again that could have binary values
which is one or zero or take an example
of a content and you would like to
classify it whether that content is
basically a science based content or in
social based content so in this case you
could be using logistic regression now
if we would have used linear regression
for a problem like email spam or not
there would be a need for setting up a
threshold based on which classification
can be done now if actual class is
malignant predicted continuous value of
0.4 or threshold of value 5 right your
data point would be classified as not
malignant which could lead to a serious
consequence now logistic regression can
be very useful in solving such problems
if we talk about your binomial logistic
regression it is also referred as simply
logistic regression where it can predict
the probability that an observation
falls into one of two categories of a
dichotomous dependent variable based on
one or more independent variables that
could be either continuous or
categorical now for this i would suggest
a little bit of reading on your
dependent or independent variables
looking at your variate univariate
multivariate variables so that
understanding on logistic regression can
be in depth now when we look at the
example of binomial logistic regression
where we basically would want to work on
a particular text file so here we are
using pi spark ml classification and we
are importing the logistic regression
package we would want to load the
training data and we would say specify a
variable training we say
spark.read.format
we basically give a format and we load a
text file now on that what we would want
to do is we want to use the binomial
logistic regression so here i say lr
logistic regression wherein you specify
the maximum number of iterations the
parameters which you would want to pass
and elastic net parameters you would
want to fit the model so you say lr
model and then you would want to do a
lr.fit on the training data set now you
could print the coefficients and
intercepts for logistic regression using
print and using string method str and
here you would be working on model dot
coefficients we could also use
multinomial family for binary
classification as shown here you could
fit the model on the training data set
and finally print the coefficients and
intercepts for logistic regression with
multinomial family when we talk about
clustering in ml life then your mlib
supports following clustering algorithms
such as your gaussian mixture latent
dirichlet allocation bisecting k-means
and k-means clustering so for k-means
clustering you could also be referring
to
say one of the easy examples of
clustering wherein this is basically an
algorithm which allows you to cluster
your data points based on some
similarity now if you look at this this
is just a visualization of k-means
algorithm where in your set of data
points you would select say random
points and then you would calculate the
euclidean distance or distance between
different points with this random point
you would then shift the centroid in a
cluster of points and again calculate
the distance and you would reiterate or
iterate through this for specific number
of iterations till you can identify the
right center point for set of cluster
points which could be grouped together
so key means clustering is a very
efficient algorithm when you would want
to cluster data points based on
particular criteria have a look at this
link for more details now here we also
have an example of using k-means
clustering that is you could be
importing packages or modules such as
numpy math then you could be from your
mlib use clustering wherein you would
import k-means and k-means mode you
would load your file and then you could
be doing a map transformation where you
would work on the values or the data
coming in from this
data.txt and you could be performing a
split based on delimiter or space you
would build the model using k-means dot
train method you could evaluate
clustering by computing within set sum
of squared errors and then you could
save and load the model now we can see a
demo on this and then we could see how
it works when you would create your
applications use using spark ml or mlib
and you could try and test those
applications in a windows page setup or
on a spark cluster or even where spark
works with yarn so let's have a quick
demo on using spark ml lab to solve some
of our problems and see how spark ml can
be used now here i'll take an example of
regression analysis now to understand
regression analysis or regression line
it would be good to understand a little
bit of basics about the equation of a
straight line and then we can see how
regression analysis which is a
predictive modeling technique which can
be used to estimate the relationship
between a dependent variable and an
independent variable which acts as a
predictor now to understand regression
analysis let's just have some quick
basics so for example if you would have
a line say y equals mx plus c now this
is usually a form of line or you can say
usually the equation of line so a
straight line is represented in this
equation where you basically have m and
c as constants now let's see how would
that look like when you are basically
having different points and you would
like to have a line which can represent
these different points in a particular
graph so for this equation if we would
want to understand let's take a simple
example say i would say y equals 2 x
plus c now if this is an equation and if
we want to plot a line for this equation
we could consider say for example we
could take a table which could have x
and y values so let's say x and y and
here we can just put in some values for
x so for example i would start with
minus 3 minus two you can have minus one
you can have zero and then you can have
one and two now if these are the values
of x and these values can be seen on
this particular place where we would
want to plot a line for this equation
and regression analysis relates to this
and that's why it would be good to
understand the basics of the equation of
line now here if your x value is -3 and
if we submit if we substitute that in
this equation so we would get the value
of y so for example here it would be
wherein you would say let's say this
equation is y equals 2x plus 1 let's say
this is the equation so if i had value
of x as minus 3 that would be 2 into 3
minus 6 plus 1 so that would be minus 5
for the value of y now you could
similarly if x value was -2 then it
would be minus four plus one that
becomes minus three and similarly you
could calculate so wherein you will get
values as one and then basically as
three and as four now if we would want
to point these values on the graph then
we could say say for example x you have
minus 1 minus 2 minus 3 so if this is my
x for minus 3 and then y i would go to
minus 1 minus 2 minus 3 minus 4 and
minus 5 so i could say my y point would
be somewhere here right so that would be
-3 being x and y being minus 5. now if
we have x as minus 2 and y is minus 3
then i could say i would have my point
here if i would say x is minus 1 and y
is minus 1 so it would be here so if we
already see these points are falling in
a straight line now if x is zero and
basically y is one so that would fall on
the line itself so we would put in here
then basically we can have
x value as 1 and y value as 3 so
somewhere approximately here and then
you have the value of x value as 2 and
then basically y value is 4 which would
come somewhere here so if i would join
all these points sorry for the curve but
then this would be a straight line this
would be a straight line similarly we
could take a different equation if we
would want to see if this is a
coincidence that we are getting a
straight line for these points or is
there some kind of logic so if i say y
equals minus x minus 3 and if i take a
similar table where i would have the
value of x and y and x we can start with
minus 4 minus 3 minus 2 minus 1
0 and then 1 and if we calculate the
values of y here so if x is minus 4 then
it becomes minus of minus 4 so that
becomes plus 4 and 4 minus 3 that gives
me 1. so if you have x value as minus 3
so it becomes minus of minus 3 and then
that becomes plus 3 and minus 3 so this
would give me zero and if we calculate
further for all these values we would
get say minus one minus two minus three
and minus four so this is the values
what we have got for y and x and if we
would want to plot these values where x
is minus 4 and y would be 1 so we could
get our point here if x would be -3 and
then y would be 0 we would have a point
here if we have x as minus 2 and y as
minus 1 so it would be here similarly x
as
minus 2 we have done and then we have
minus 2 and minus one and then we could
say for example if x value was minus one
y value would be minus two and so on if
x is zero y would be minus three so if
we basically plot a line joining these
points approximately it would give me a
straight line now here this is how your
equation of a straight line is following
a form of y equals m x plus c where your
c
and m are constant and here we say m is
a gradient and i'll explain what is
gradient and your y is an intercept and
your c is a constant now if we look at
these numbers and if we look at these
lines we can also see that whenever a
value of x is increased by 1 so
basically we have minus 3 and then you
increase the value of x by 1 so that is
-3 it goes to minus 2 so we would see
the value of y increases by 2. similarly
you increase the value of x to 1 so y
value will increase by 2. and so on so
if we would want to look into the graph
so if the value of x was minus 3 and if
we increase the value of x by 1 we would
see the value of y would also increase
by 2 so where my x was minus 3 and my y
was say minus 5 now when i increase the
value of x by 1 that is i move towards
the left towards the right my y value
would also increase by 2. if you further
increase the value of x by 1 you would
again see the value of y value increases
by 2. and that we can see on the line so
this is basically the equation of a
straight line now if we compare that
with the second equation even there we
would see the same pattern which would
be followed so when you increase the
value or you decrease the value of x by
minus 1 you would see the value of y
would increase by y value would also be
decreasing right so here if i say minus
4 has been increased by 1 so we would
see the value of y is decreasing by 1
and then you again increase the value of
x by 1 so you would see the value of
y is increasing by 1. so if we
understand these equations
then here we can see the value to what
we see the value of y which changes or
basically if you see the value of y here
so in first equation whenever you
increase the value of x by 1 it
increased the value of y by 2 and that
is what we see here 2 in front of x in
the second equation we see that whenever
the value of x was increased by 1 your
value of y was decreasing by 1 and that
is what we see here so these values
which is 2 or minus 1 in this case are
the gradients now at a particular time
your one of the point falls on the line
of y axis and that is your intercept so
your y value is the intercept your m is
the gradient and your c is the constant
now this is what happens when we
represent a line whether the line goes
in a positive direction or in a negative
direction line is expressed in this form
which is y equals mx plus c where m and
c are constants and if we look in graph
we see if the value of x is increased by
one unit then y value increases by two
units so this is how you can understand
the equation of a line which is
represented in the form of an equation
now sometimes you might also see that
people would represent this equation as
y equals v 0 plus b 1 x and that's also
same as your y equals mx plus c where
your b 0 is the constant your b1 which
is the gradient is the slope of the line
and we could basically be representing
this equation in any form now we could
have basically x and y plotted on a
graph so if we had a small graph we
basically would want to find out if the
value of x and if the value of y are
related that is if you increase the
value of x does the value of y increase
if you increase the value of x does your
value of y decrease so this is what we
want to find out and then we could
basically get a line or a slope here so
you could either have a line going
upwards or you would have a line going
downwards so this is how you understand
the equation of a particular line now
when we talk about real time scenarios
and when we talk about regression
analysis so if you have set of points
which you need to work upon if you have
set of points so basically finding a
line that connects all the points
possible is what you mean by regression
analysis so this line which connects all
the points or all the possible points is
called your regression line now this is
calculated based on a least squares
method and we also need to minimize the
estimated and actual value so there are
other points which do not fall on these
lines such as this or such as this and
these are called your residual points
let's take a simple example to
understand this so for example if i have
x axis which is the height of a father
and y axis is the sun's height now we
would want to find out if a change in
father's height affects the sun's height
so as we see the values of father's
height plotted over x axis we could see
or find out if that would basically
relate to a sun's height increasing or
decreasing so that could be represented
in the form of your y equals mx plus c
now if both of them increase that is as
the value of ix x is seen increasing you
see the value of y also increases then
that's a positive relationship if the
value of x increases but y decreases
while x is increasing now that is a
negative relationship which would see a
line going downwards so your regression
line or your regression analysis is
about finding the relationship between
dependent and independent variables so
let's look at this one now when you talk
about your regression analysis it's a
predictive modeling technique it
estimates the relationship between a
dependent variable that is in our case
we were saying whatever is on x-axis and
in an independent variable which is on
the y-axis so x variable can increase
its value as much as it wants so far an
arbitrary value of x we are predicting
value of y now prediction is done using
regression so when you talk about linear
regression we would basically want to
find out a line that can basically
connect all the points also find out the
points which would be your residual
points that is the points which are
close to your regression line whether
your line goes upwards or it goes
downwards so your regression analysis is
a supervised learning based powerful
modeling technique and it is basically
used for predicting the unknown value of
a dependent variable from the known
value of an independent variable now to
look at a use case what we can do is we
can look at a data set here and we can
further do we can use spark ml lib to
see an example on that now if we look at
a data set here on my machine which i
have also uploaded in the git link so
here you can look into this location
where i have a sample data set which is
called e-commerce customers and if we
would want to look into this data set
which is in a csv format let's look into
this data set and we can probably just
look at some of the entries here so we
can say head might be -5 so this is the
data set which i have and it is in a csv
format where we see fields like email
address avatar average session length
time on app time on website length of
membership yearly amounts inspect and
then we have values for these now this
is a csv file now if we would want to
find out what is the impact of yearly
amount spent based on your fields we
would have to work on this data set now
here we have some fields like email
address avatar and they would not have
any kind of impact on yearly amount
spent so those fields are not required
but then we have other set of fields
which is basically your average session
length time on app time on website
length of membership and these fields
are very important so we could say your
average session length time on app time
on website length of membership all
these are your independent variables
your yearly amount spent is the
dependent variable now how do we do a
regression analysis if we would want to
work on this so the first thing what we
will have to do is now as i explained
earlier your spark ml lib has basically
spark ml lib basically has set of
libraries and functions which can be
used for your machine learning
algorithms so first let's go to spark
that is start spark and then import some
packages now here in my machine if we
look in here we have my spark already
set up so let me see this so here if you
see i have a master and a worker running
and if i look at my second machine i
have a worker running so i have a spark
standalone cluster which has two worker
nodes and one master which we can also
see from the ui now to test an
application first you can do the
interactive way and if that works and
everything is fine you can even build an
application using an ide like eclipse or
intellij so here i see i have two worker
nodes i have my spark standalone cluster
running so let's come in here and let's
go back to this machine well my spark is
already running so i can just say spark
shell now there are other settings also
which makes my spark works with the
standalone but that's not the point here
we are discussing so we would like to do
a regression analysis on this data set
which has information about fields which
can basically affect the dependent
variable which is yearly amount spent as
i was showing we have
average session length time on app time
on website and length of membership
which are the independent variables so
how do we work on this problem so first
thing is let's import some packages
which has these classes which will be
used so i will import one of these one
by one all of these packages so import
where we have your org apache spark and
that gives me
a error here because i had a typo so
this is fine so i import the package
which is going for ml evaluation
regression evaluator similarly i'll go
for linear regression that's what we
want to do here then let's import some
more packages
and we will go for
log 4j also this would be good if you
are building an application using an ide
but we can just import the packages then
we have a feature transformer which is
vector assembler i'll show you the link
where you can read more about it and
then we have vectors because when you
talk about machine learning it would
like to take the data as input in the
form of vectors so these are some of the
packages which we have imported now what
we need to do is we need to get that
data set which we can create a data
frame from so here the path for my data
set is
this one so this is the data set i'm
interested in so let me take this one
which is e-commerce customers.csv
let's come here and what we want to do
is we want to just paste it here i will
use it and what we can do is
we can basically create a data frame out
of it using the statement let's copy
this and here
let's go into our spark shell now what
i'll do is i have imported the relevant
packages so i will say this is my file
so i'll say file colon slash slash slash
home hdu and that's the path where i
have my csv file which i just showed you
so what we are doing is we are doing a
spark spark.read.option
we are using header as true because we
want the first row of that data set to
be considered as the headings we have
option as in for schema we say format as
csv and then we are loading the file now
this should basically create a data
frame out of this file which we can
easily use to work on the regression
problem what we have here so let's just
wait till it creates a data frame we can
always assign that data frame to a
different variable so let's do that by
doing this so we know we have created a
data frame here it shows me in the last
line or capacity spark sql data frame so
now i will assign this data to ecommerce
data frame you can always do a ecom df
dot show to see what does your data
frame contain and it shows me the values
which we had in csv are now transformed
and existing in the form of a data frame
where we have fields such as average
session length time on app time on
website and length of membership which
are basically your independent variables
and you have yearly amount spent which
is dependent variable now what do we do
with this so basically now we would want
to look at the schema of this data frame
to understand the data types and we can
do that by just doing a print schema
which tells me what are the fields what
are their types which are assigned to
them so spark has inferred the data type
based on the values now what we can do
is we can filter the columns here
especially the columns such as your
yearly amount spent so that we would
want to project as label right so when
you talk about supervised learning you
would have always data which would have
a label or a response so your yearly
amount spent would be a response or a
label and your other fields would be
more or less like features so let's get
this
and here we can just do this which says
val ecom so i'm creating a new data
frame df1 i'm taking df which has been
created earlier ecomdf i'm doing a
select and i'm saying this yearly amount
spent which was the last column would be
the label and then you have your other
fields which is your average session
length time on app time on website and
length of membership so i'm selecting
all this data here and i'm creating a
new data frame out of it so that's also
done you can anytime do a ecomdf1.show
to see what is happening in this data
frame now one point as i said your
machine learning expects data in a
n-dimensional vector format that is a
matrix format it does not line the data
in an array or a list or something
although vector is also like a list
which is vertically arranged so if you
would want to read more about your ml
features or a feature transformer like
vector assembler then you can basically
refer to this link which i have given
here and if you just go to your browser
and just search for this you should be
able to reach to the spark documentation
which shows about vector assembler now
what is that it's a transformer that
combines in given list of columns into a
single vector column you see here single
vector column it is useful for combining
raw features and features generated by
different feature transformers into a
single feature vector so we have
multiple fields here that is time on app
time on website length of membership and
we would want to convert those features
into one column and that's why we are
using vector assembler which we have not
used so far but we would want to use it
so we created a new data frame now here
if you see i am using new vector
assembler wherein i am providing the
input columns as the array that is
average session length time on app time
on website length of membership and then
i am saying set the output column as
features so let's copy this
let's come here in my spark shell and
what i'll do is i will use this vector
assembler and i will say set input
columns which will then have these
fields as features so earlier we did
yearly amount spent as label and now we
have this one which will be your feature
set so now we have the data frame ecom
df1 we have also the assembler which
should have the values in the form of a
vector wherein the heading of that would
be features now we have done this let me
just close this window and now once we
have used our vector assembler we can
basically create a new data frame based
on assembler which will transform your
first data frame which had labels and
then you are also using the features so
let's copy this
and i just want to avoid some time in
typing all this and avoid any kind of
manual errors so here we are working on
this assembler which we created in the
first step and then we are doing a
transform using the first one and we are
selecting label and features all
together now so this is done it has
created a vector now if you would want
this is a vector if you would want and
you would do something like this it
shows me the label and it shows me the
features now all the features are in one
column which is basically the three
fields which we have combined together
now we have done so far we can do a show
now we can create an object of linear
regression so this is where we are then
moving towards machine learning where we
want to use the linear regression here
an algorithm which is already existing
we just need to use it so i am creating
an object with this linear regression
then i can use the fit method on my data
frame that is what we created here which
is ecom df2 so i'm using a new variable
called lr model i will use this object
of linear regression and then i'll use
the fit method so i'm doing this and
this basically is implementing the least
squares method as i said when you talk
about your regression which internally
uses the least squares so this is also
done now we have the model and basically
what we can do is we can extract
information such as coefficients and
intercepts etc that is your gradient
coefficients and so on so we can just go
in here and we can try in this this
basically gives me the coefficients and
intercept which will make obviously more
meaning to the data scientists who are
looking for the coefficient values and
the intercept values now further we can
also look at the summary based on this
model and we can do that by doing this
training summary we have the model right
which shows the linear regression
training summary that's what we have in
training summary and we can print out
how many iterations were done or
the total number of iterations which
should show me one and that's perfectly
fine and then i can also
print the objective history training
summary into in the form of a list so
that's also done and finally we can also
list down our residuals that is the
points which are not on the line which
are far from the line and one of the
main things as a part of linear
regression is that you would want to
reduce the distance as much as possible
so this is list of my residuals so this
is a simple example of using your linear
regression where we worked on a pretty
much structured file that is csv and
this will give us information on your
residuals your gradients your
coefficients and basically if we had a
plotting
integrated utility or software we could
have also seen this on a graph so this
is your linear regression and a simple
demo on usage of mlib further to this if
you would want to test or try this
application you can always refer to the
github link where i have given the
sample data set the code and also some
more applications so you can look into
this path which is the git link with my
name here and here you can be looking
into spark applications and setup you
can look into the spark mlib folder
where i have given you the sample data
set here which is ecommerce customers
which i was using for this demonstration
of using regression and linear
regression and you can also look into
this linear regression document which
has the sample code which we just now
executed now for the application which
we ran from an interactive shell
obviously we can go to the spark ui and
here we can look for our application if
you would want to look at the dag and
what it did so here is my application
you can click on this i can click on
application detail ui and which shows me
that from the time we loaded data into
data frame where we created a data frame
what was the stage what was the job
number we were doing a load and it shows
me what were the steps in the dag you
can go further and you can look at all
the show commands what you did where you
are trying to see what is there in the
data frame and even towards the end
where you have show or you have counted
linear regression or sum at linear
regression metrics so we can always see
these steps how many stages did it take
how many tasks were running and
basically dag which will give you more
information on what happened on your
application you can always look at
different stages you can look at the
storage if there was any caching done
you can look at environment variables
executors which were used for this
particular application and the steps it
had and we can also look at the sql tab
which basically shows up when you are
using spark sql and data frames and we
can look at the queries which were
completed always click on a particular
link and that can give you more details
on what was happening in the background
when you were executing a particular
query or using a statistical model so
this is how you can run your linear
regression using spark ml and you can
build a model you can build a machine
learning algorithm which is following a
supervised way of understanding from the
data separating the fields as features
and labels and finally helping us
getting the slope of the line getting
the residuals and basically also doing a
linear regression on set of data points
which finally end up in giving up a
regression line let's have a quick
demo on logistic regression and using
spark ml lib to
solve a problem which is based on
logistic regression now for that let's
also briefly discuss on what is logistic
regression now this is a technique for
traditional statistics and also goes
well with machine learning mainly to
solve your classification problems now
here outcome that is the outcome
variable or result is binary it could be
one or zero it could be true or false it
could be yes or no based on predictor
variable it's same as linear regression
but instead it predicts whether
something is true or false instead of
predicting something continuous like
what we saw in linear regression now
instead of fitting data into a straight
line it fits points into an s-shaped
logistic function or an s-shaped curve
now this s-shaped logistic function is
called your sigmoid function so you can
search for sigmoid function in google
and that could give you more information
on how this function works now it also
depends on a threshold value which we
would set now below which we would
basically have a probability of say zero
and above which we would have a
probability of one so based on the
threshold value which is set we decide
the output from this sigmoid function so
logistic regression is usually used for
classification it can work with
continuous data or discrete data now
here we test if a variable's effect on
the prediction is significantly
different than zero if not then variable
is not helping the prediction so
logistic regression's ability to provide
probabilities and classify new samples
using continuous and discrete
measurements makes it a popular machine
learning method now with linear
regression as we saw we fit the line for
data points using a least squares method
that is we find the line that minimizes
the sum of squares of these residuals
residuals are the points which are close
to the straight line which we plot now
logistic regression does not have
concept of residuals instead it uses
something called as maximum likelihood
wherein through iterations the curve
with the maximum likelihood is selected
so in case of logistic regression we
were seeing that when you have set of
data points you try to plot a graph or
try to plot a straight line which would
be to have all the data points or
maximum data points which would fall on
that particular line and that's how you
find out the slope in case of logistic
regression as i said we would want to
find out the probability of a result
either being yes or no or being true or
false so here the graph would look
something like this so it's a s-shaped
curve where you would also have a
threshold defined and below which you
could say that it would be say 0 and
above which the data points would
classify as one or below which the data
points would classify as false and above
which they would classify as true so
that is the whole gist of your logistic
regression now how do we solve logistic
regression so ml lib also comes with
different packages which can be used so
here we will try to solve a problem
wherein the statement is you would want
to predict a customer if a customer
would be bankrupt or no now this is
probably for a bank which would want to
identify if the customer is about to be
bankrupt or no and if customer will be
able to pay back the loan how do we do
this so for this there is a data set
qualitative bankruptcy text let me let
me show you that so here i have the data
set let me
come out of this and here we can look at
the data set which is in this location
and here i have qualitative
bankruptcy.text this is the location and
if i look into this data set it
basically has
some qualitative values which we will
have to convert into quantitative so if
you look at these this is the data set i
have which has p and n and a and b now
we want to work on this kind of data set
to basically classify the customer if
the customer is having more probability
towards bankruptcy or no how do we do
that so for that what we can do is first
we will start our spot when we will
import some packages which are more for
your logistic regression so here
i will start my spark shell now spark ml
lib comes with different classes and
different libraries which help us in
solving these problems so it already has
these algorithms say linear regression
logistic regression and many more which
can be used so here what we will do is
first we will import the relevant
packages which are required for our
example so import now this is what we
have so spark ml lab so i'm missing in
something here and then we can get the
others also so there is a connection
here which we can i'll update in the kit
also so it should be mlib then we will
get something else for the labeled
points and we will also get something
for vectors because when you talk about
machine learning it would expect the
data in the vector format for which in
linear regression we saw using a feature
transformer such as vector assembler so
these are the packages which we need now
if you see here i would want the data
which we have to be understood so the
data file has these different fields you
can say which are existing so p is for
positive e is for average n is negative
b is bankruptcy or nb is non bankruptcy
so
this is the schema of the data file on
which we have to work on so what we
would do is we would first transform
each qualitative data in the data set
into a double numeric value which we can
do using a function so here we are
defining a function called get double
value let's do that and this one will
basically be declaring some variables
and then we would be converting the
qualitative values into quantitative
values so that's the function so let's
copy this line by line and looks like
there was an error let me try it again
here so there was a error where there
was an extra bracket so i corrected that
so this is the function which will
basically convert the qualitative values
into quantitative values now once we
have this our function is ready what we
can do is further we would have to read
the data in memory now here i would be
using the older way that is the rdds way
to work on our data set so i would be
using val data sc.text file and then
i'll point it to my file which is
qualitative bankruptcy so let's get that
file from here so let me open up a
different terminal and here the file is
in this particular location where we
have this qualitative data set so let's
take this is what we are interested in
so
here i would say val
and then i would say basically data
equals sc dot text file so using the
text file method of spark context and
here i would say file home htu and
that's my path of the file so let's
create an rdd of this particular file
now once we have an rdd created we can
always see how much data we have here by
just doing a data dot count and it shows
me there are 258 rows which has these
fields which we intend to convert into
quantitative values using this function
now once we are done with that we need
to prepare the data for logistic
regression algorithm so basically what
we will do is we will do this where i
will say parsed data i will do a map
transformation on my data wherein i want
to split the data based on comma and
then i'm using the labeled point method
wherein i'm using the function which we
defined which will basically then
convert this data and convert the values
into quantitative values so let's do
this with say sparse data doing the map
transformation splitting the data based
on comma as the delimiter using your
labeled point wherein i'm using the
function and then basically i'm going to
convert that into a vector now once that
is done it has created an rdd which is
based on mlib regression labeled point
which we have used here once that is
done we can even print the data to see
what are the values now which should
show me that my data which was
with attributes like p a etc has now
been converted into the quantitative
values which we can use for any kind of
computation now once this is done then
you can split your data into training
and test data set which will be used to
train our algorithm so what we will do
is we would do splits wherein we are
converting this
into a 60 and 40 percent so let's do
this once that is done i could then have
my training data which will be at index
position 0 and i will have my test data
set which will have at index position 1.
once this is done then we need to train
the model so how do we train the model
now this is where we use the logistic
regression algorithm with
lbfgs we will take this and we will
apply this on our training data now once
this is done we have a model which is
based on logistic regression which would
work on our training data which is 60 of
our data set now once this is done it
has basically given me a model logistic
regression based model now here i need
to evaluate the model on training
examples and compute the training error
so i can take this wherein i am working
on test data so that is being applied a
map transformation where we would want
to see if my model is working fine so
let's get this here and that's done fine
so our model looks fine now we can
basically get the training errors based
on this
and once this is done you can print your
training error out of what you have done
in the previous step so that gives me
training error of point zero point two
zero that is twenty percent is the error
now this is a simple example of logistic
regression where we are basically
reading data in memory we are preparing
the rate of to be used by logistic
regression algorithm we are then
splitting our data into training and
test we are training our model and then
we are evaluating our model on training
examples and computing the training
error so this easily shows how we can
use spark mlib to basically work on your
problems such as linear regression or
logistic regression now since we have
run the application we can always come
back here and we can look at our
application which was launched using
spark shell we can look at application
detail ui which will show me what are
the different steps we did when we were
using spark mlib and you can go into any
one of these jobs and see what it has
done you can look at the dag of the
steps which were executed which shows
how we picked up the file what kind of
transformations we did and finally how
we got our resultant data now here this
is my spark ui if you would want to look
at the code and the sample data set you
can find in the github link in this
particular place where you have spark
mlib where i've given you the
documentation with the code i've also
given you the sample document which a
sample data which can be used and a
notepad file which also has the code
wherein there is one correction in our
function which can be
changed spark sql we will learn about
what is spark sql what are spark sql
features its architecture spark sql data
frame api data source api spark sqls
catalyst optimizer running sql queries
and then we can have a quick demo on
spark sql so what is spark sql it's
a sparks model or apache sparks module
for structured data processing now it
allows you to work with structured
semi-structured and even unstructured
data but primarily with structured and
semi-structured it originated to
overcome the limitations of apache hive
now we know that apache hive is a data
warehouse package on top of hadoop and
this basically is quite extensible it
allows you to work on structured data or
data which can be structuralized with
the various features such as
user-defined functions or support of
complex data types or custom mapreduce
scripts and many more however there are
a lot of limitations
in terms of
using apache hive such as it always
depends on map reduce as an execution
engine or processing framework or it
could also use days
you would not be able to do insert
update deletes when it comes to apache
height it is more of a batch oriented
operation and basically querying with
hive can be time consuming however how
is hive is quite extensible in the way
it supports data warehousing use cases
it lags in performance as i said it goes
for map reduce and it's not really
suitable when you would want to do
faster querying or ad hoc querying it
does not allow you to resume a job if it
fails somewhere in the middle and these
are some high level limitations of hype
when we talk about spark it performs
better than hype now spark we already
know is a in-memory computing framework
which basically works on
having the data loaded into the memory
that is in the form of rdds and then
having the dag execution whenever a
action is invoked now if we compare
latency in terms of hours we would see
spark is
quite competitive in that with hive and
is a better performance when you talk
about cpu in days or cpu reservation
time in all of these cases spark wins
over hype
now let's look at spark sql features and
let's understand how it helps so as i
mentioned spark sql is a module for
structured data processing primarily now
unlike the basic sparks rdd api the
interfaces provided by spark sql provide
spark with more information about the
structure of both the data and
computation being performed now we know
that spark has a dag scheduler behind
the scenes and if that dag scheduler
could know what are the steps which are
part of your processing application then
it would understand the steps it would
benefit from data which would be
structured and thus have a better way of
processing your data internally spark
sql uses this extra information to
perform extra optimizations now there
are different ways in which you can
interact with spark sql including sql
and data set api you could be using data
frames api data source api and also the
older way that is rtd api now some of
these features really make spark sql a
compelling framework for data processing
and analyzing especially if you have
data which is structured you can
integrate spark sql and query structured
data inside spark programs it is highly
compatible with sql-based frameworks
like hive so it can work on the data
which is stored in hive it can work on
the data which is stored in your rdbmss
which are external to your big data
setup or even on the files which are
stored on your distributed file system
such as sdfs when we talk sparks
integration with hive you can run
unmodified hive queries on existing
warehouses in spark sql so while
existing hive data queries and udfs
spark sql offers full compatibility now
spark sql leverages the rdd model as it
supports large jobs and mid query fault
tolerance for interactive and long
queries it uses the same engine so in
terms of spark 1.6 and all older
versions we had rdd api that is whenever
you do some transformations such as map
flat map filter and many more that would
create rdds and you can say logical
steps in the dag which would be executed
only and only when a in action was
invoked now in terms of older apis we
said that spark has rdd and when we talk
about newer versions of spark we have
spark data frames or data sets and when
we talk about data frames that is using
an implementation of rdd which we call
as schema rdds or you could say in older
versions of spark we were talking about
schema dds which get created based on
your transformations and in newer
versions the same schema rdds are called
data frames there are different ways in
which you can use spark sql so you could
use an odbc or jdbc connector and then
you could be connecting to your external
databases business intelligence tools
and then extract the data from your
underlying data stores and process them
remember spark does not have its own
storage it has various components such
as spark sql streaming ml lab you have
rdds and you have graphics but then
spark always relies on storage now that
storage could be a hadoop distributed
file system that could be a nosql
database it could also be a rdbms to
which you can connect using jdbcodbc or
it could be just your local file system
on which your files are stored and spark
can use those files and process the data
within those files now when we talk
about your spark architecture or spark
sql architecture you have basically at
the lowest level you have your data
sources now that could be your data in
csv format or json format or also coming
in from external sources using your jdbc
odbc connectors you have different apis
so you have a data source api we learn
about it you have a data frame and a
data set api which allows you to work
with data and then you have different
ways in using these so you could have a
data frame domain specific language that
is dsl or you could be using spark sql
or hive querying language to use one of
these apis to process your data so spark
sql is apache sparks module mainly to
work with structured data now when we
talk about spark sql it has three main
layers it has a language api so spark is
very compatible as it supports multiple
languages such as python your scala java
even r which is used in data science
activities and your hive querying
language when we talk about schema rdd
source spark sql works on schema tables
and records and what it creates behind
the scenes is a schema rdd or an rdd
which has schema within it which helps
the dac scheduler to understand the data
and the steps which are being performed
and as i said in newer versions your
schema rdd is your data frame which is
nothing but a representation of your
data in the form of rows and columns
with column headings and you could call
it as a temporary table where your data
is getting stored the third layer is
your data sources so that is your data
coming in from varied sources that could
be your files in different formats such
as csv json text parquet avro and so on
you could be getting your data from
different nosql databases such as
cassandra mongodb your hbase or anything
else you could also be getting data
directly from hive which are your
logical structures such as databases and
tables however the data is stored on an
underlying file system such as sdfs now
when we talk about your data frames and
data sets so a data frame is basically a
data set organized into named columns so
what is a data set so a data set is a
distributed collection of data it's it's
a new interface which was added in spark
1.6 which provides the benefits of rdds
such as strong typing
ability to use powerful lambda functions
and with the benefits of spark sqls
optimized execution engine so a data set
can be constructed from jvm objects and
then manipulated using functional
transformations such as map flat map
filter and so on so your data set api is
available in scala in java and
python did not support the dataset api
but i think that's been worked upon for
the future releases when we talk about
data frame it is basically a data set
organized into named columns or we can
say representing your structured data or
semi-structured data in the form of rows
and columns with columns having headings
so it is conceptually equivalent to a
table in a relational database or a data
frame in python or our programming
language but it has richer optimizations
under the hood so data frames can be
constructed from wide array of your
sources such as your structured data
files tables and hive external databases
or even existing rdds so again your data
frame api is available in scala java
python and r programming and your data
frame is represented by a data set of
rows we can just say data frame is a
simply alias of your data set of rows
now when we talk about your data frames
let's also understand about your spark
sql data source api spark sql it
supports operating on a variety of data
sources through the data frame interface
it supports your different formats such
as csv hive avro json parquet text and
so on as we know about in spark it is
lazily evaluated like your apache spark
transformations and can be accessed
through sql context and hive context so
as we have seen in previous tutorials
your spark context or your hive context
or in later versions what we have a
spark session these are basically the
classes which are your entry point of
your application so when you start a
spark shell in an interactive way or a
pi spark you would see the spark context
is initialized or your spark session is
automatically initialized if you are
building your applications using an ide
then we would have to define and
initialize our spark context and spark
session which is in later versions of
spark in older versions you had spark
context and then you had sql context or
hive context it can be spark can be
easily integrated with big data tools
and frameworks via spark core engine now
before we learn about spark catalyst
optimizer let's have a quick look so if
i look in my machine here and if i look
in my
machine i could look in my c drive and
if you see here i have downloaded spark
and spark 2.4.3
now if you could follow previous
tutorials you would know how to set up
spark on windows however just for new
people i can just give here some
information saying let's look at
environment variables and here i have
set up two important variables one is
your hadoop underscore home which points
to a folder called hadoop on my desktop
and i'll show you what is there in that
i also have spark underscore home which
has been set to my spark path now what
does my desktop and my hadoop folder
contain it basically contains a bin
folder and within that i have a win
utils executable which helps our spark
when launching to just realize if there
was a dummy hadoop support here now what
we can do here is i can go in to my
command line i can go into my spark
directory and then i can go in bin here
if i just do a dir slash p i would see
that within this i have different
binaries or different programs and what
we can do is we can just start by doing
a dot slash
spark shell so this is basically an
interactive way of working with spark
for people who would be more comfortable
with scala as a programming language
they could use spark shell or if people
are comfortable with python then they
could be using pi spark so here i am
trying to launch the spark shell which
will run in a local mode it will not be
contacting any yarn or resource manager
however it will just start an
application locally on this machine it
will initiate the spark context as i
mentioned earlier or basically your
spark session depending on which version
of spark we are working on so if you see
here i have spark version 2.4.3 scala is
2.11 it has a spark context which is
available as sc and spark session which
is available as spark so this basically
allows me to work either with rdd api
using sc or i could be creating a data
frame using spark so both of these
classes have got initialized and they
will act as an entry point of my
application into the cluster in older
versions of spark which is 1.6 we still
had spark context available but then if
we wanted to work on spark sql which was
launched and then in an experimental way
with spark 1.6 we could be using instead
of spark session we could be using sql
context or hive context so this is the
spark context or spark session which is
getting initialized if i was building an
application using ide then i would have
to depending on my use case and need i
will have to initialize spark context or
spark session within my ide coming back
and understanding about your catalyst
optimizer so when we talk about catalyst
optimizer what is it and what does it do
spark your catalyst optimizer leverages
advanced programming language features
such as colors pattern matching and
cursi quotes in a novel way to build an
extensible query optimizer so what it
does it works in four phases your
catalyst optimizer it analyzes a logical
plan to resolve the references when you
are querying the data it has a logical
plan optimization internally which will
come up with the best way to get to the
data it has a physical planning layer
and then it also does code generation to
compile parts of query to your java byte
codes when we talk about your catalyst
optimizer we can say if you have a sql
query now that sql query would result in
an unresolved logical plan which can
then help in analyzing the logical plan
and it also depends on the reference to
internal catalog which has information
about your data which you are trying to
query then there is a logical plan based
on the analysis and a logical optimized
plan which is post your local logical
optimization which then relates in
physical plans and a cost model which
helps the catalyze of catalyst optimizer
know what is the best way to reach and
access the data it gives away a selected
physical plan which will then generate
code based on the rdds which would be
implemented based on your query now
that's how catalyst optimizer works when
we talk about sql context or spark
session as i explained it is a class
used for initializing the
functionalities of spark sql so in older
versions of spark such as spark 1.6 when
you would start your spark shell or when
you would start your pi spark so we can
see that here now i could just do a
simple quit and i could then try
bringing up pi spark which is also a
binary or a program to work with your
spark but then that brings up your
pythons shell and useful for people who
are well versed with python as a
programming language now if you see here
we again have spark context initialized
as sc and then we have spark session
available as spark if i was working in
older version i would not have spark
session but i would have sql context
which could be used to use the
functionality of spark sql or basically
using spar to work with structured data
so your sql context is a class which is
used for initializing the
functionalities of your spark sql or you
can say it is the class which becomes an
entry point of your application for the
resources which your application would
need for processing so we could just
start a spark shell and basically that
would start your spark context or spark
so when we talk about this spark context
or spark session you can also create a
sql context or a spark session using
something like this on an interactive
cell so you can say val sql context
equals new org apache sql sql context sc
and you could then start building your
application i will show that how you do
that in your ide wherein you have to
initialize your spark context however as
i said in spark shell or in pi spark
your spar context gets initialized
automatically and you can work with your
rdd api or you could be using spark
session which is available as spark to
work on spark sql whether you're working
with pi spark or you're working with
spark sql using your spark shell now
moving forward when we talk about spark
session so this is an entry point to any
functionality in spark so to create a
basic spark session you could be using a
spark session dot builder if you are
working in an ide like eclipse so here
you have to import a package that is org
apache spark sql spark session and then
you could create a variable such as well
spark you could use spark session dot
builder you could provide an app name
you could also provide config properties
that is your configuration properties
and then you could say get or create now
that creates spark which can then be
used to work with your spark sql you
could then do import spark implicits and
continue to work now here let me start
my eclipse parallely and i can show you
how it looks here now when we talk about
working with data frames either we can
be doing that using your
spark shell pi spark or we could be
using our eclipse so let's see how we
can work with data frames here so let me
just quit by spark and let me get into
spark shell so i could just do this and
this will start my spark shell that's an
interactive way of working with my files
i could be using spark here and i could
be using spark session now for this we
would need some files now i could be
working on windows or i could be working
on my linux machine so here i can show
you both now this is basically a spark
standalone setup where i have set up
things you can refer to the previous
tutorials where i have shown how you can
set up spark stand alone or spark on
your windows i have started my spark
standalone cluster if i look at the
processes on these two machines that
would show me that i have a master and
two worker processes i can also open up
the spark ui if we would want to look
into our applications and here we can
just say http slash
um one and then eight zero eight zero so
that shows me my spark standalone
cluster which are two worker nodes as of
now there are no applications which are
started and we can start spark shell
here so i can go into user local spark
and then i can see that i have basically
a bin folder which has my programs or
binaries which we can use now we could
be using that from anywhere because in
my bash rc i have set up my spark path
so that will allow me to give my spark
commands from anywhere and here we can
also see that i have some data in sample
files we can pick up one of the files
here which we can then use to create a
data frame so i can just say spark shell
from my home directory where i will
target a json file which is already here
to create a data frame now once i am
starting my spark shell it basically
shows that it has started an application
it shows a ui which is available it is
basically interacting with my spark
master there is spark context available
as a sc and spark session which is
available as smark same thing we see in
our windows machine that is you have
spark context a web ui available which i
can launch i can look at spark context
available and spark session which is
available now taking this file what we
can do is we can say val x and then i
can say spark which is the short form of
spark session and then if you are not
sure what method should be used you can
just do a tab and that will show you all
the possible options which are available
within spark so here we can use read and
again do a dot and then do a tab and it
shows me that we can get our data in
different formats now by default if you
do not mention a format then it will
expect the file which you are working on
in a par k format we can use a load
method here or i can just say
spark.read.json and then i'll point it
to a file which is in my sample files
folder and i will point it to
people.json and i can hit on enter now
here since we are using spark session we
will see if it creates a data frame now
if you see here it is pointing to a
driver issue basically saying it is not
able to reach mysql or the metastore so
by default spark also expects if it can
connect to your meta store which is
being used by hive so now i'm on my
right machine um one where i have my
mysql installed which i just checked by
testing and i have my mysql installed
here which is being pointed within the
spark on by hive hyphen site file so now
i will start my spark shell again here
which should bring up your spark context
and also your spark session it will
basically interact with spark master
which is running on this machine and as
we have given in the conf and in your
spark default conf so once my spark
shell has started i can start doing this
i can say val x spark dot read dot json
and then i'll point it to a file which
is in this directory called
people.json so that's the file and it is
in sample files directory now once we do
this we are using spark session which is
available as spark and when i do this it
refers to the config files and then it
is able to internally discover the hives
metastore which is in a mysql database
that's because of the way i have set up
my spark standalone cluster also so that
it can work with hype now here we see
that a data frame has got created and we
can always look into this so i can just
do a x dot show to see what is in my
data frame so we pointed to a json file
and my spark session allowed me to
create a data frame now at any point of
time unless and until you use a show or
an action you will not see the result it
would just create a data frame now here
we have x dot show which shows my data
frame i can also do a x dot print schema
and then i can see what is the schema
assigned to this so in this way we just
easily created a data frame using a json
file now if i come here and if i do a
refresh that will show me the
application which is running which has
been started by spark shell i can click
on this and then i can go into
application detail ui to see what we
have done so i did a spark.3.json
and i can look at the dag here which
shows what happened what code was
generated what were the transformations
which were done it shows me how many
tasks were run for this and then i can
go and look back at my second job which
is basically ending with show where i
see this in a different stage i see the
code which was generated i see the map
partitions and then the map
transformation also we can always look
at the sql tab which is getting created
when you use spark sql and within that
we can see what kind of queries were run
how much time did they take and you can
always click on the query to see what
internally it did so it had a scan json
number of output rows number of files
what was the metadata time and basically
i am seeing the result so this is how i
create a symbol data frame from a file
and as i mentioned you can read any file
format however if you did not give a
format or if you do not specify
the right method then it will expect the
file to be in parquet format so we just
created a simple data frame from a file
now we can do many other operations we
can do filtering we can do selection so
we can do this i can just do a x dot
select and i can choose one or multiple
fields so either you could use a dollar
and then mention your column name here
something like this and then i could say
i would want to look at the name i would
want to look at the age but remember if
i just do this it will just create a
data frame so if i would want to see the
result i will be doing a dot show and
that shows me what i have i can always
do some more things here i can do a
filter and i can say i would want to see
the h which is more than say 20 and at
any point of time when you do these
transformations it always creates a data
frame or a data set now here i see that
when i did a filter it created a data
set so it is using the data set api now
i can just do a show to see the result
and that will show me the result in the
form of rows and columns with column
headings i could do a select i could do
a filter and i could work on my data in
this way on a particular data frame now
you could also do some computations if
you are interested in so you could
always do a x dot select and then you
could be selecting a particular field
for example i would say age and i would
say i would want to increase its value
by one and i would like to do a show so
we are working on a data frame wherein
it shows me the column name and then it
shows me the values so these are some
simple data frame operations which we
are doing based on a file which we have
here now i could be picking up a bigger
file and doing more functions or more
transformations on that i could be doing
a filter as i said is select i could be
running my sql queries by creating a
temporary view out of it now here we
could pick up a different file i would
say val my data and then i could say
spark dot read and this time i'm going
to use the format method here so i'll
say format now i would specify i would
like to work on csv file then i could
basically also use something called as
option and then i could be specifying i
would want to infer the schema from the
file so i'll say true i will say option
and then i could also say a delimiter if
you would want to specify now here i
have infer schema as true and we would
then want header that is first row in
the file to be considered as the header
or the column headings then i can just
say load and i would want to load my
file so i'm going to pick up sample
files and then i will point it to a file
which i think is existing in this
directory something like this and then i
do this which should basically create a
data frame from a csv file you see it
shows 15 fields and the schema is
understood so i can just say my data dot
print schema and this will show me the
schema which was inferred and we have
our data frame created we can always do
a my data dot show and that shows me
some rows and columns now remember it
will always show you only 20 rows if you
would want more then you could be giving
it here in the bracket and then you
could see more values so here we have
created a data frame from a csv file we
could do a filter we could do a select
from this we could basically do any kind
of computations i could give different
conditions so this is a bank related
data where some kind of campaign was
done to find out if customers would be
interested in subscribing for a deposit
now all these sample files are existing
in my github link and i'll share that
link towards the end of session you can
always use these files or you can use
some of your own files now here i could
just do a my data dot select and i could
be selecting multiple columns if i'm
interested in so i could just do a
dollar i could say i would be interested
in age i could be interested in job
marital status or even the column which
says about subscription the last one
which says y so i could say dollar and
then i could say job i would say i would
want to see the subscription and then i
could be doing this close the bracket
now remember that we'll just create a
data frame so we need to do a show to
show me the results so i'm doing a
select and i've started working on my
data frame you could be doing some other
kind of calculations say we want to find
out what are the total number of rows in
this particular data frame so i could
just do a count and then i could do show
or what i could do is i could convert
this to a double value by doing this and
it shows me the total count of entries
in this data frame is 45211.
now i could basically be assigning this
to a variable say val total count and
then i get my value so for example we
would want to find out what is the
success rate of this campaign and how
many people were really interested in
subscribing for a deposit with bank i
could do that by just saying creating a
variable called subscription count and
what i would want is i would want to
work on my data frame i would want to
basically filter the values where the
value for subscription holds true if it
is yes and then we could just do a count
of this and convert this to double value
like we did earlier for total count and
that tells me how many people were
interested in subscription so it gives
me a count of people who were interested
in subscribing for a deposit now we
could do some computation on this so we
could say val success rate and then i
could just say subscription count
divided by total count and you could
even multiply this by 100 to see the
percentage so it tells me the success
rate of this campaign was 11 percent
because this or these many number of
people were interested in subscribing
for a deposit and in this way you could
be doing many more computations you
could be using different functions you
could be using different combination of
functions so for example i could just do
a my data dot select and then i could
say i would want the average on the
balance column to find out what is the
average balance of the customers which
we would want to understand now here i
could just do a show and that could show
me what is the average balance of a
customer who was inquired about his or
her interest in a deposit in similar way
you could be using multiple functions
like average mean median percentile and
so on now there is one more thing about
data frames you could basically be
creating a temporary view and then
people could be using their select
queries to work on data so we could do
the same thing now here we could say
my data dot create or replace temp view
and we could give it a name so let's say
bank data and this basically facilitates
querying so now we can just use spark
dot sql and then start using our queries
to query structured data which we would
have basically used to create a data
frame so now i can do a select star from
bank data where
age is greater than might be 75 and i
could just close this and whenever i do
this remember it creates a data frame so
if you would want to see the result you
can just do a show and that will show
you the result of your data frame and we
are seeing the fields which are having
values greater than 80 or 75 so i not
only created a temporary view but now i
am able to query that using
spark.sql now here this is one way in
which you can work with your data frames
work on different formats look into the
schema run your queries do some
computations and then basically also
save it as a data frame we could do many
more things so here for example if i
would want to write this data in a
different format or save it i can always
do a spark dot sql now the same query
which we ran here we could put this in a
variable so for example let's say val
result and i can just do this now i know
that creates a data frame which has been
now assigned to result and now with
result i can basically look into
different methods which are available so
for if you would want to save it if you
would want to write it in a particular
format remember if you do not specify a
format then it will always be read or
written in parque so i can always do a
write dot either i could be using a
particular format or i could straight
away say save and then i could say for
example my new df data frame and if i do
this the whole point is your data frame
would now be saved on your machine in
this particular directory in a parquet
format so i can come in here and then i
can look in if i have the directory
created so we see here and we can look
in this what does this have and this
basically has a parquet file which got
created now i can always do a ssh to my
second machine because this is a
standalone cluster and then i can see if
there was any directory created on this
machine which has the data if no then
that's fine if we have a data directory
we can always look for our file so we
just saved the output of our data frame
in a par k file and that's my par k file
now there is a easier way of checking if
this was fine so this is in my new df
directory now what i can do here is i
can just say spark dot read and this
time i will not specify a format and we
know when we do not do that it expects
the file to be in a par k format so i'll
say load my new df that's the directory
i'll give the file name and then
basically i'll see if it reads the spark
a file creates a data frame and yes it
has done that we can always do a show
and we can see our new data frame now i
know you might see some error like this
and that is because this file did not
exist on both the machines and when
you're looking in a spark standalone
cluster if you are trying to do a read
operation it basically expects the file
to be existing on both the machines or
you should have been getting the file
from a distributed file system now we
can try this again and i can just do a
scp i can take this
directory and i know there is a ssh
access which i have set up across
machines so i can say sdu at um2 in the
home directory
so that this directory and file exists
on both the machines and now we will try
it again so if you see now i'm trying to
read the file i don't get any error
message so we worked on a csv file we
created a data frame then we saved the
data frame using write dot save and by
default it was stored in a par k format
we could test that by just doing a read
dot load now the way we did a write dot
save and we did not give a format we
could have chosen a format so we could
have said format and we could have said
json and then do a save and basically
give a directory name now this is also
saving my data frame but now it is
saving it in a format of my choice so i
can look in new df1 i should have my
data coming in here it might take some
time and then we can come back and check
here if it has saved my file in a json
format so in this way you can either
store the data in a default format or
basically you can store it in a
particular format of your choice such as
json or
text or some other format so this is how
we are just interacting with a file on
local file system i am creating a data
frame out of it and then basically i am
doing some computations now as i said if
you have a setup now in this case i have
a spark standalone cluster but if i i
would want i can start up a hadoop
cluster i can just say s bin start dfs
dot sh now that will start my hadoop
related processes based on the setup i
have and why am i doing it because i
would want to try spark interacting with
hive now hive is using hdfs as the
storage layer so i'm starting my hadoop
cluster i can go into my second machine
and then basically i can again start my
rest of processes so i can just say s
bin and then i can say start
yarn dot sh and that will start my yarn
related processes so i have a hadoop
cluster running which basically means
now i can also work with hive so i can
just go into hive directory i've already
set up hive i can get into hive by just
doing a bin slash hive i can look into a
database if it is existing i can look
into a table which is existing see if
that contains data and try querying it
using your spark so i can say show
databases and that basically shows me
that i have a database called testdb
let's use that in hive and now i'm in
the database i can say show tables that
shows me some tables let's select one of
the table i can say s test tbl2
might be we can just do a limit of 10
rows and see if it works fine so that
does not have any data let's look into
another table and let's see if that has
some data that also does not have any
data and
that might be if we are not looking into
the right metadata let's look into one
more and see if that's fine so we will
say test tbl tbl limit 10 doesn't have
the data so let's do one thing let's
create a table so i'll say create table
new tbl i will say id is integer name is
string i will say the table is created
you can always do a listing from here by
looking in user hive warehouse my text
database
and then i can see if that my database
has the table directory it has new table
let's look into that new dbl and then
does that have any data as of now no so
i can say load data local in path i will
take this sample files i know there is a
file called
kv1.txt which has internal format and i
will say overwrite into table and then i
can say new tbl so i'm loading some data
it does not like the
because it does not find this directory
so let's give the right path so we will
say home hdu sample files now i'm
loading some data i've done that and now
i can say new tbl limit 10 so this is a
simple example of loading some data in
hive table which has two columns we did
not give any delimiters because i know
the file also does not have any specific
delimiters now here i can just exit this
our main task was not to work with hive
but to work with spark sql in
interacting with hive which is a data
warehouse package on top of hadoop so it
is using hadoop's distributed file
system i mean hive is using hadoop's
distributed file system to store the
data and we would want to use spark sql
and especially its data frame api to
work on interacting with hive now let's
do a spark dot sql now if you remember i
mentioned that my spark conf directory
has already a hive hyphen site file so
it knows where hive is storing the
metadata and that basically means that
your spark sql can directly work with
hive and you can then start using all
your hive queries within spark benefit
from in memory processing and the data
frame api so here i can say use test db
so i basically would want to get into
the database and i'm using this spark
sql you see there is an empty data frame
created now let's say select star from
new tbl
limit 10 and i could do this and this is
basically your data frame now you could
do a show and you have started
interacting with hive directly which
creates a data frame which allows you to
look at the data and then you can store
it in a variable you can store this file
not only this you could also create a
table from spark sql so you could
basically do all your hive related
operations from here using your data
frame api so i could be saying similarly
create table new dbl2 and then i could
say id would be integer name would be
string and then i could just close this
so i'm creating a table and
i would like to close this
so
let's do that now you see somewhere it
interacts with hive metastore it has
created a new table and that should be
stored in my hive meta store and also on
your htfs where hive related data is
getting stored now we can even load data
into it so we will say spark.sql i will
use the same statement load data local
in path i will pick up the file from
sample files slash kv1 dot txt i will
say overwrite into table new dbl2 close
the bracket and that should load data
into your hive table now let's try
querying it so we'll say spark.sql
i will say select star from new tbl2 i
will say order by id descending and then
i can say limit 10 so i'm running a
query which if would have run in hive
would have triggered a mapreduce job now
here this uses a data frame and you can
always do a show which will see show you
the result so we are interacting with
hive we are creating table we are
loading data into it we are running a
query using in-memory processing using
data frames and that does not trigger a
mapreduce job if we had done the same
thing using hive let me just show you
here so let's get into hive let's start
the hive shell let's use our database
and then we can query our table so i can
do used sdb and if i say select star
from new tbl to order by id descending
limit 10 and just run this now you will
see that this triggers a mapreduce job
because hive uses mapreduce now it also
mentions on the first line that high one
mapreduce is deprecated in hive 2 will
not be available in future versions you
can use other execution engines like
spark and pace but we are querying the
table which we had created using spark
and now we are using hive to do it which
obviously takes more time it triggers a
mapreduce job and does the work for you
so this is how you can use your spark
sql and your data frames to work
let me just exit this and there is one
more option where you can be interacting
with your rdbms now that is say i have
mysql here and i have i can login into
this i can just say show databases
so i have my databases here i can say
use mysql i can say show tables and then
i can query one of the tables like for
example help underscore keyword and then
let's do a limit 10 so that shows me
some data here now it would be good if
we could interact with rdbms and then
get the data from here and for that we
will have to do certain things so that
we can connect to this and we can work
with this rdbms so if you look in your
user local spark now that has a jars
directory and if i look in my jars
directory i have a lot of jar files here
but i would be interested in doing a
graph and finding out if i have a mysql
related jar file so if you see here we
have placed the mysql jar file now where
does this jar file come from so this
mysql jar file if i look in my home hdu
downloads and then if i look in here you
would see i have a mysql connector tar
file which i have downloaded now that
particular tar connect or contains your
mysql connector jar file and this mysql
connector jar file has an inbuilt driver
class which allows any particular
service to connect with mysql so we need
the jdbc connector jar file only then we
can have our spark connect with mysql
which we already know is doing because
your spark is able to look at the hive
meta store and hive metastore is getting
stored in mysql now how do we establish
a connection from spark sql to this
mysql like we connected using spark hive
you can always use spark to connect to
an external rdbms as i mentioned and you
can always search for that you can just
say spark sql jdbc data frame and then
look into the data frame documentation
which will show you the syntax but for
this remember you will have to set up a
mysql instance you will have to get the
driver and then you can be giving all
these options such as url db query your
driver and then other options to connect
to an rdbms you can connect to any
particular rdbms by just basically doing
this spark dot read dot format connect
to an rdbms get the data from it create
a data frame and work on it for many
more examples you can always look into
the data frame documentation you can
always be clicking on this and then you
can see how you can connect with hive
how you can work with data sets and data
frames you can also look into different
data formats which are selected and you
can do much more with data frames pi
spark tutorial and here we will learn
about what is pi spark what are pi spark
features pi spark with python and scala
pi spark contents pi sparks sub packages
companies using spy spark and also we
will see some demos using pi spark so
what is pi spark now it is in python's
api to support apache spark now all of
you would have known about apache spark
or would be knowing a little bit about
apache spark as of now that that is a
in-memory computing framework which
basically gives you a faster processing
capability and it is widely used in
terms of real-time processing or machine
learning and then there are various
other use cases so when we talk about
apache spark it supports different
programming languages such as python
scala r and even you could be working on
structured data structures using spark
sql now we all know that spark context
is the entry point to any spark
functionality so we'll see that now here
when we talk about pi spark it is
basically a way of using python or for
people who are more comfortable with
python programming language to use
python and work with apache spark and
that's what you have as a component from
spark called pi spark now here just to
show you i have two machines
now i have already set up a spark
standalone cluster on these two machines
so if you see here i've given a start
all command and this has basically
started by spark master and two worker
nodes so we can check this by just doing
a jps on this machine and if i go to my
second machine and if i do a jps to see
the java related processes i see two
workers in a master node running so my
spark as a standalone cluster is running
now we can always check this using the
spark ui if i go to my browser and then
if i just do http
slash slash and then if i say um1 and
8080 so that shows me my spark cluster
which has two worker nodes it shows
their address and all these details now
if we come back to the terminal and if i
look in binaries so i see a lot of spark
related programs like you have spark
shell if you would be interactively
working using scala and you would want
to work with spark you can use spark r
if this has been set up and you can use
your r programming language knowledge
you can be using spark sql to work with
structured data you can use pi spark
which is python's api allowing users to
use python to work with spark and
obviously you also have spark submit now
the other way would be that if your
machine has python installed you could
write your applications in a python file
that is a file with an extension of dot
py and then you could be using that so
here if i would want to work with pi
spark i can just say bin by spark and
that should start my
interactive shell in python and then
basically i can be using my pythons
language now here if you see it says
spark session is available as spark and
then by default when you start your
spark shell or basically pi spark it
would have spark context which is the
entry point of your application
available so that you could do your
processing now there are different ways
of doing it for example if i would just
say x
sc dot text file now text file is
basically a method of spark context and
as i said when we use interactive way of
working with spark such as using pi
spark or spark shell then we have spark
context and spark session automatically
getting initialized if we are building
our own application using an ide for
example in case of python using a
pycharm or you writing your code in dot
py files then in that case you would
have to initialize the spark context now
here i could be pointing to a particular
file which could be coming in from my
machine so for example i could do this
home slash sdu
slash
sample files
slash let's take a file which i think
should be existing here in this location
and this file and this directory would
be existing on all your worker notes so
if i just do this we know that this
since we are using spark context which
is an entry point it would have created
an rdd now rdds are the building blocks
of spark you might have learnt about
that through the previous tutorials now
if i just say what is x it shows me it
is a map partitions rdd which has got
created because we used a spark context
now if we do further transformations on
this rdd it will further create multiple
rdds so we'll see that but this was a
quick look at using your pi spark now we
have not seen the complete execution but
if i go here if i say refresh my ui it
tells me that there is an application
running so we have started the pi spark
shell which is using all the cores of
the machine
it is basically
using 1gb memory and then we have an
application which was started because we
started pi spark shell now i'm clicking
on this i can go to application detail
ui and as of now i have not done any
execution in terms of spark until and
unless you invoke an action everything
would be lazily evaluated so we don't
see anything here but we do see that pi
spark shell has started an application
that application is using some resources
and basically as we do further
processing we will see the application
regulated dag getting built up now when
we talk about pi spark as i said it's
python's api now if we look further into
pi spark features it basically as i said
when you work with spark it is a
in-memory cluster computing framework
which is polyglot which basically
supports different programming languages
such as you could be doing things with
the scala you could be doing things with
python you could be working with r or
you could also be using spark sql when
we talk about other features spark also
allows you to do faster processing it
allows you to do real-time analysis and
there are also features where you can be
caching in your computation that is the
intermittent computation so you could be
cashing in and you could also have disk
persistence so those are the features of
your spark and when you work with python
you will be able to leverage all sparks
features now when we talk about spark
with python and scala and if we do a
quick comparison if we talk about
performance then python is slower than
scala when used with spark however when
you talk about spark since it is written
in scala it integrates well and it is
faster than python now learning curve
obviously we know that both of these
languages support concise code and
python is very rich with the amount of
libraries which are available community
support and so on but python has simple
syntax and being a high level language
it's easy to learn scala has a little
bit of complex syntax since it is newer
in comparison to python but then it also
allows you to write concise code and
sometimes it might be for the new
programmers learning scala might not be
so easy in comparison to python when we
talk about code readability so in case
of python readability maintenance and
familiarity of code is better in python
api now scala is a sophisticated
language developers have to pay a lot of
attention towards the readability of
code and if we talk about data science
libraries as i already mentioned python
provides a rich set of libraries for
data visualization and model building
now scholar lacks in providing data
science libraries and tools for data
visualization there is a lot of work
happening when it comes to data science
and machine learning with spark
different components such as mlib and ml
which allows you to work with data
science kind of projects however python
would be more advanced in that case now
when we talk about pi spark contents so
these are a quick list of pi spark
content so you have a spark conf now
that is basically how we define our
configuration so we would be creating a
configuration object using spark spark
conf class spark context is basically
the entry point of your application
which will basically take your
application to the cluster manager
whether that is yarn or it is spark
master in case of spark standalone or
even local now we have spark files now
that allows you to read files from a
file system whether that's a local file
system or a distributed file system you
have rdd these are the building blocks
of spark that is anything you do
starting from using a spark context or
spark session till you invoke an action
that is anytime you use a method of
spark context or spark session you do
some transformation you are always
creating an rdp that's a resilient
distributed data set of memory and that
is in one way a logical step which is
part of a dag that is direct acyclic
graph which gets executed when you
invoke an action now you also have
storage level and different classes
within that which allows you persistence
you can be using sparks higher api such
as data frame or data sets and then you
also have ways where you can be
efficiently doing wider transformations
or wider operations using broadcast and
accumulators now when we talk about
spark conf spark conf provides
configurations to run a spark
application now we will see that further
when we build our applications using pi
spark now if we look at the code block
of spark conf class which is used so
that would show you class by spark dot
spark conf and that has load defaults it
has for jvm and j configuration which
can be passed now if we look further
these are some of the most commonly used
attributes of spark conf so you have
something called a set key and value to
set a configuration property and this is
where we can be passing in our
configuration properties and passing in
values we can basically say how many
executors we would want for our
application
we can say how much memory per executor
or course per executor and many other
properties which can be set in the form
of key value now you can also be saying
set master and then pass in a value now
that will take your master's url you can
set an app name which is basically value
to set an application name and you can
do a get key and default value to get a
configuration value of a particular key
now there are various other options
which you can use with your pi spark dot
spark conf so if we look into spark
context now as i said when we look or
when we understand spark architecture
which you would have learned from
previous tutorials or of some of your
ways of self learning that's spark
basically has or whenever you build
applications to work with spark as a
processing framework your applications
would have a driver program and driver
program basically has a spark context
now spark context is the main entry
point in any spark program so if we look
at the data flow so in terms of local we
are talking about spark context which
basically allows you to talk to local
file system and then you basically have
something called as pi 4j so when you
run any spark application a driver
program starts which has the main
function and it has your spark context
which gets initiated now the driver
program then runs the operations inside
the executors so what are executors
these are jvm processes now spark
context uses pi 4j to launch a jvm and
creates a javaspark context by default
your pi spark has a spark context
available which i just now showed on the
machine and that's your sc so creating a
new spark context would not be required
if you are working in an interactive way
but if you are developing your
application using an ide or basically in
a file then you would have to initialize
your spark context now if we look here
so we see that spark context has some
kind of socket connection with spark pi
4 j implementation that's the jvm and
then you could be having a cluster
underlying which has multiple worker
nodes wherein on those worker nodes you
would have executed processes which will
take care of your execution now if we
look at this code we see that this is an
implementation of pi spar class and the
parameters are context can take so we
can be passing in values for all these
parameters such as master app name spark
home pi files and so on so master now
this is where you will say the url of
the cluster it connects to right so we
would be interested in using python to
work with spark and spark would be
either as a standalone cluster or that
would be integrated with hadoop or
apache mesos and so on so your master
will point the url of the cluster app
name is basically your application name
spark home basically says where your
spark related jars or config files or
what's your spark installation directory
pi files basically tells the dot zip or
dot py files to send to the cluster and
add to the python path so this is where
you would specify what are the python
files wherein you have written the code
which needs to be added to the class
path you have a parameter environment
where you would specify worker node
environment variables such as your jvm
or your memory and cores which need to
be used you have something called as
batch size so this is
number of python objects represented as
a single java object now
it is set 1 to disable batching 0 to
automatically choose the batch size
based on object sizes or minus 1 to use
an unlimited batch size then you can
also be specifying serializer and this
is the serializer which will be used so
rtd serializer now here we can be
specifying say for example pickle
serializer so by default we know that
when we work with spark and we work with
rdds spark internally uses either a
cairo serializer or java serializer you
have something called as conf now this
is an object of your spark conf to set
all your spark properties right so this
is where we are creating a configuration
object we have something called as
gateway now we can use an existing
gateway and jvm otherwise initialize a
new jvm you have java spark context
instance that is jsc and you have
profiler now this is a class of custom
profiler used to do profiling and for
example we can pass in pi spark dot
profiler dot pass batch profiler so in
all these above parameters master and
app name are mainly used now we could
basically write a particular code and
i'll show that in further slides wherein
we can just say from pi spark import
spark context and then we can be
specifying parameters which go into the
spark context if we go further we can
see how that looks so spark files now
what is this used for so you have spark
files which allows you to upload your
files using
methods of spark context such as add
file and you can even get the path on a
worker node using spark files dot get so
this is just a simple example which we
can use so you have these class methods
one is get so you can get the file name
and you can even say get root directory
if you would want to look at the path so
this is a simple example now get root
directory function here or method here
specifies the path to the root directory
which basically contains the file that
is added through your add file method so
if i would be writing the code in a file
and not doing it interactively i could
be doing from pi spark import spark
context from pi spark import spark file
so if we are doing it from the
interactive way we don't need to really
use spark context we can just import
spark files and that should be enough
then here i am saying find distance and
i am specifying a path to a file then
basically i am saying find distance name
and then i'm pointing to this file here
i'm creating my spark context or i'm
initializing my spark context by passing
in parameters such as uh what would be
my master and i'm saying local what will
be my app name and i'm saying spark file
app
and then i'm using a add file method
where i'm passing in this fine distance
where we have created a variable to
point to a file finally i am doing a
print absolute path and i can also say
spark files dot get to
get the root directory for this
particular file so we can be just doing
this in a simple way and i'll show you
some examples here so when we talk about
your pi spark rdd now rdd is the
building block of spark so you have
resilient distributed data set that is
basically the basic abstraction in spark
so anything you do in spark until you
would want to see the result starting
from using your sc dot method till you
doing transformations like map flat map
filter or any other transformations all
that would be creating a resilient
distributed data set and what is that it
is basically a logical data set when
data is not evaluated you're not doing
any transformation every step in your
application is ending up creating a rdt
and that rdd is basically a step in the
tag and this dag will get executed when
you invoke in action so it's an
immutable partitioned collection of
elements now by default whenever an rtd
is created it will always have
partitions and we can always look at the
partitions we can see how many
partitions are there and the more number
of partitions you have the more number
of parallel tasks you will have so when
we talk about rdd there are mainly two
kind of operations so you have
transformations so these are operations
such as map filter join union and so on
which are performed on an rdd that
basically results in a new rdd now how
is the first rdd created on which you
could do a map or a filter or a join or
something else is by using a method of
spark context like i showed you example
in this session in the beginning action
is when you would want to see the result
so these are operations such as reduce
first count take and so on which
basically trigger the execution of dag
right from the beginning so this is a
simple example of creating a pi spark
rdd so here you are using class pi spark
dot rdd and then you are saying jrdd you
can have your whatever name you would
want to give like context you can be
specifying your serializer which you
would want to use okay so if i would be
doing this in a file i would be writing
in code like this now this is just a
simple pi spark program to return the
number of elements in the rdd so you are
creating a spark context you say
dot parallelize now sc dot parallelize
is a method to work on collection of
elements and here you have some words
which are being passed so this is just
like a collection or a list you can say
and then you are doing accounts where
you take this rdd
and you're just doing an action on it
now that would give you the result and
finally you are printing it out let's
just have a look at some examples where
we can use pi spark and in an
interactive way so let me go to my
console here and what i can do is for
example i can be
referring to a file now as i said with
your spark your spark context and spark
session both get initialized so here we
can use sc and then with sc you have
different methods which can be used to
work with your spark now here we can be
looking at method like text file which
basically allows you to pick up a file
so let's say text file and then i can be
pointing it to a path so i can say home
hdu
sample files now that's a directory in
my machine and that this directory
exists on both the worker nodes because
we are working on a spark standalone
cluster and here for example i can pick
up
people.txt so i know that there is a
file here in this path and let's also
give this in quotes so this would have
created a rdd if i just do x it shows me
that it has created a map partitions rdd
using a text file method now i can do
some more transformations on it so for
example i can say y
x dot map
and map is basically
a transformation which i'm doing on an
rdd which is already created using a
method of spark context so here when i
would want to do a map i would have to
pass in a function now in spark and when
you are using python you can be using
lambda functions which is for anonymous
functions so i can say lambda and then i
can say take every element here and what
do you want to do with that so i can say
n dot upper now that's a inbuilt
function which we can be using and when
i do this this one would again create an
rdd and here we see it has created a
python rdp and this rdd again has not
really done the evaluation now unless
and until we would want to look at the
result there is no evaluation happening
here so in the first one we created an
rdd using a file in second one we
applied a function using map now i could
do a filter i could just do a simple y
dot collect and that's basically an
action which you are invoking which will
let this dag get executed and then i
look at the content of my file which has
been converted into an upper case this
is one example now i could also be say
creating a list for example let's create
a list of strings so let's say hello
let's say world let's say cool
let's say
winter okay and let's say summer so i
could be giving in some words and this
usually creates a list right so i've
created a list and i can basically see
what is this so it has created a tuple
and that's also fine so basically now
you have created a list or a tuple and
you would want to work on it so it's a
collection of elements now i can
basically say b and then i can use again
sc dot and this time i would be
interested in using this method which is
parallelized which allows you to work on
collection of elements so i can just
pass in a here and if i look at b it has
basically created a parallel collection
rdd using the parallelize method of
spark context now we can be printing out
some values from here so for example i
could also be invoking an action so i
can say b dot count and this should give
me the count of elements in this
particular rdd so these are two
applications which i just ran starting
from creating a list passing it in
parallelize and then doing account or in
our previous example we read a file we
applied a map function and then
basically we did a collect so if i would
go back to my spark ui if i would do a
refresh now here it shows me the
application which is
now running you can look at application
detail ui and that shows me the two jobs
which have run starting from the first
rdd created till the action was invoked
so if you look at this one so this one
shows me the dag and it shows me it
started with a text file and then
basically you you did a map so it also
shows me how many tasks which were run
so this also means that there were two
partitions created for this particular
file and i can also be looking at say
different stages what were there in my
application which has two jobs you can
look at storage if there was any caching
done you can look at the environment
variables you can look at how many
executors were used for this particular
application and how much memory was used
for storage how much was it for
processing if there was any shuffling
happening and you can also look at a
spark sql although we are not using any
spark sql component here if i look at
the second one which shows me four tasks
so it started with parallelize and then
basically we created a python rtd we
finally ended up with a count and this
tells me how many tasks we had run so we
can always go and look at the number of
partitions of a particular rdd so
whenever you would be creating an rdd so
for example we have b here or in this
case we have y here so you can always do
a y dot and search for different methods
which are available and then you can
basically be checking so for example if
i would want to look at the number of
partitions what was created for these y
when i was converting my text into
uppercase and then i can be just doing
this and this will tell me how many
partitions were created similarly if you
would search for b which was when we
worked on a list and if you would want
to see so it shows me the number of
partitions for four and that also tells
me that based on the number of
partitions you are seeing the number of
tasks which were executed so
automatically based on your data size or
based on the number of codes which are
being used it has created partitions and
per partition you would have a task
running right so for example we had this
where we were creating a list
and then in b
is what i was doing was i was doing
sc.parallelized now what if i had done
something like this
so if i would have done something like
this then my b would have created two
partitions right and then if i do a
execution on b like what we did for
count so it still gives me the count but
now the partitions were two so we can
again see how many tasks were run so if
i go back here and if i go to the jobs
and then i see one more job which was
run and you see it shows me two tasks so
the same job which was showing four
tasks earlier is showing now two tasks
and that basically means that the number
of partitions was changed and per
partition you will have a task running
so this is just a simple example of
seeing how you can be basically using pi
spark now i could also be taking this
whole thing and putting it in a file and
then executing it and i'll show that
later so when you talk about storage
level now that's a very important
concept and if you have followed
previous tutorials where we would have
spoken about storage level so basically
this decides whether the rdd should be
stored in memory or should be stored on
disk or both so when we talk about your
storage level now if we look into the
package which comes for spark it
basically has storage level and you can
always go to google and check more for
this one so for example i could
basically be checking this so for
example if i would say storage
level and just check this so storage
level and then you can do a spark and
you see it says you have different
options memory and disk you have memory
only serialize memory and serialize disk
only memory only so there are different
options here and this one you can also
search what package it comes in for and
then you can see there should be a
package which talks about storage level
and that would be for example let's see
so here it says org apache
spark dot storage dot storage level now
this is a way wherein you would be
importing a package in terms of scala
when you're doing but then storage level
as a class comes within your org apache
spark storage storage level and
similarly you would have your storage
level for pi spark also wherein you have
to import the particular package and
this storage level then has different
options like memory only disk only
memory and disk serialized and so on so
here
what we can do is we can basically see
what is the usage of storage level so in
this example if you see we are saying
class by spark dot storage level now we
could be saying it should use disk or it
should use memory it should use offheap
or should it be deserialized what should
be the replication so storage level is
one way wherein you can have your rdp
which gets created at any step of your
application to be cached so that's
basically making your computation cached
or computation persisted so that if down
your application if you are using the
same step again on same series of step
you will not have to have your complete
dag executed right from the beginning
but you could benefit from the cache or
persisted computed rdd now here we are
saying from pi spark import spark
context we are saying import by spark
and here we are creating a spark context
that is spark context local storage
level then i say i would want to do a sc
dot parallelize on these elements and
then i can basically say that this rdd
which gets created in this step needs to
be persisted using pi spark in storage
level and then you can say memory and
disk with a replication of two now i
could then just be checking if my rdd
was persisted and i can check for the
get storage level i could even print it
so this basically tells me that if i was
doing something on rdd1 for the first
time it would have cached my computation
or whatever we did in this step in one
of these options which comes as a part
of storage level and if next time i
would be executing that series of step
it would benefit from getting the data
from cache now here we have a quick
example of using storage level and then
caching your rdd and we can then also
see how we can recognize if that is
coming from your ui the information can
be seen in ui and you can see if the
caching is really benefiting so for
example like what we did earlier we can
basically create a list and then i am
doing a b s c dot parallelize and here
before we can use the spice bar we will
have to import the package so for
example i could be just doing this now i
could import this by spark package here
which we will be using to use the
storage level class now what we were
doing earlier is we were just doing a b
dot sc dot parallelize now that creates
an rdd and we can do that and here i am
doing a persist where i am saying that
sc.paralyze which creates an rdd that
rtd or that stage of computation should
be persisted using pi spark storage
level and i'm specifying memory only and
as i said you can have different options
here like memory only memory and disk
only memory and disk replicated so you
can give different options here with
storage level now we could be straight
away doing this where we will be caching
in this in memory now once i've done
this i can basically just do a b dot
count and when i do this now this b dot
count would have triggered the execution
of dag right from b onwards so basically
this list would have been created that's
not part of your dag here i am basically
using sc.parallelize so this is where my
first rdd is created you are persisting
it and then you are doing account now if
i go back to my ui right now if i do a
refresh it basically shows me an
application which completed with two
tasks if we see here we see that there
was a parallel collection cached now
which we have done that and it shows the
duration is 2 seconds if i look at my
storage it shows me that the parallel
collection was 100 cached and the size
in memory is 175 bytes and then it says
how many partitions were cached and we
can look at the executors to just tell
me we had one for driver and then you
had two executors for two tasks each one
of them were running on two different
nodes they were using by default two
cores how much memory was used for
storage how much was used for execution
it tells how many tasks were run by each
executor and that gives me an overall
summary now if we basically run this
again now what will this benefit from we
will not again start with sc dot
parallelize because
your that rtd is already persisted in
memory so i could just be doing a b dot
count where it will get the persisted
rdd from memory and give me account so
if we do this and we go back here in my
jobs it shows me the second job look at
the time difference so this is 2 seconds
and this is 0.2 seconds and if we look
at this one it basically says the input
is 175 bytes now that's what we know
that rdd was cached in memory and we are
benefiting from caching so this is a
simple example of using storage level
where i could have written the whole
code in basically a file and done it now
as it says you can also do a get storage
level so you know which rdd you have
persisted and basically you can if you
would want to check that so we have b
dot get and then i can do a tab which
shows me different options so we will
use storage level to basically see what
was the storage level and it basically
based on different storage levels it
gives me v when we used memory only it
shows the value as true so you can also
be looking at the storage level here you
can be printing out the storage level if
you would be interested in doing that so
the same thing what i have b dot get
storage level i could just wrap it using
a print to see what it shows here and
that shows me memory serialized with 1x
replicated that means it was not
replicated so i could be using storage
and then i could be using memory and
disk too so that's one more option which
you can do and then you can see how is
it cached where is it cache where is it
persistent right so that's an example of
your storage level now when we talk
about pi spark it also has something
called as data frames and we look at
that so when you're working with spark
spark's basic or core api was rdd and
then there were higher level apis that
is data frames and data sets which were
introduced as experimental features in
sparc 1.6 but then they became the main
apis which are extensively used these
days when you're working with structured
data and they were introduced from spark
2 onwards now pi spark or basically
using python you can also be working
with data frames and data frames is
basically a structured way of looking at
data or you could say if your data is
already structured it would be good to
inform about the structure and format to
the backend dac scheduler and then it
would be more efficient in accessing the
data now when you talk about data frames
in pi spark data frame is basically a
distributed collection of rows with
named columns now that's what you would
have seen if you have worked with
python's pandas library or you also have
you can be using or creating data frames
using scala as a programming language so
data frames is basically a table of data
with rows and columns now when you talk
about rdds we know that they are
immutable in nature by default if you
are working on a collection of elements
you could have basically have mutable or
immutable structures created but when
you talk about rdds these are immutable
in nature you have basically lazy
evaluation so rdds are lazily evaluated
and they are distributed across memory
so when you talk about creating data
frames in spark you can be creating
using different data formats you can be
loading data from existing rdd you can
also be programmatically specifying
schema so there are different ways in
which you can work with data frames so
let me quickly show you an example here
now when we go to our machine and let's
do let's get to pi spark so here i'll
just say bin slash pi spark that brings
my pythons python prompt to basically
allow you to work with spark now as i
said your spark context gets initialized
automatically and when you use a method
of spark context you are moreover
working with rdds and if you would be
interested in working with structured
data then you would be using spark
session so for example what we can do is
we can say x equals and then i can just
say spark dot and then i can check what
are the methods available here so you do
have a method which is called create
data frame now we would be interested in
reading a file which might be say json
or a csv file and then creating a data
frame out of it so we can do that using
read and then i can again say what are
the methods which are available with
read so you have an option like format
which can be used or you can straight
away be using csv or json or text or orc
so i can say format and for now i will
select a json file and what i would also
do is i would want to infer the schema
so i can basically use option and with
option i can say for example infer
schema and then i can say true what i
can also do is i can specify one more
option and i can say header if there is
a header then i can set it to true if
there is no header then basically it
will just look at your data and then we
can do a load where we would want to
point to a file so i'll say home slash
hdu
sample files and here i have a file
people.json which does not have used
data we can take a look at bigger data
set also and here when i do this this
would have created or should create a
data frame so data frame where it infers
the schema where it understands the
first row as the header and it creates a
data frame and whenever you would want
to look at a data frame i could just do
a x dot show that shows me it is a data
frame which has got created now since we
are in python we could do a type and
that shows me this was the data frame
created you can straight away start
doing a select and here i could say for
example show me the age now at this
point of time if i do not do a show then
it just shows me that it is a data frame
and it has one field and that's of the
type begin so i could again do a show
and that shows me the result of data
frame so you can be then doing multiple
other operations you can do a filter you
can basically do a group by you can do a
count so you can do all that and if you
have any doubt just do a tab and it will
show you what are the options for
example i'll say let me get age which is
greater than 19 and here you are working
on basically a string so you can do
these things but then you will have to
follow different syntax but if you see x
dot and then i can search what are the
different options which are available so
only the syntax has to be corrected but
then i have something called as x dot
filter and then basically i can be
specifying what i would be interested in
and then filter out the values okay now
this is basically a data frame so
similarly i can be also looking at a
bigger file for example let's say i have
a file called bank underscore full one
dot csv if i'm right
and then we can basically point this to
format as being csv
let's quickly check if we have this file
so let me open up a new terminal i look
into the sample files and i have a bank
underscore full dot csv so that's the
file i'm interested in and that's a csv
file unless like last time we saw a json
file
and here we gave the path which is wrong
and that's why it was giving me an error
so let's go back here and change this to
the right path and then basically it
should create a data frame out of this
if i do a x dot show that should show me
the data frame and by default when you
look at your data frame it shows me only
the top 20 rows and then you can start
doing a select on this you can filter
the data you can do a group by you can
do operations you can do functions on it
and you can do various ways in working
with a data frame so this is just a
simple example of using pi spark to
create a data frame and then you can
start doing your other operations on it
now when it comes to your broadcast and
accumulator so broadcast and accumulator
so broadcast variable allows the
programmers to keep a read only variable
cache on each machine rather than
shipping a copy of it with tasks now why
do we need this so for example you are
doing a bigger operation such as join or
union on two rdds or two data sets or
two data frames now in that case we know
that whenever we basically have a data
frame created or an rdd created it would
have partitions so for example we had
this here and i can do a x dot and check
what are the different ways in which
i can be looking at this so as i said by
default each rdd or data frame which
gets created that would have your
partitions now you could convert your x
into say an rdt if you would want to do
it right and then basically i could have
done this by saying y equals right and
then you can check at your y what are
the different options like you have get
num partitions right so i could just do
it this one and i could see how many
partitions are created so that was a big
file and it shows me there is only one
partition created right so based on the
partition you would have the number of
tasks now if you have multiple data
frames or data sets on which you would
want to do a join operation then the
point here is that if both are large and
if you would be doing a join based on a
particular column now in that case there
would be lot of shuffling involved so
basically if you have your data in the
form of a pair rdd or if you have your
data frames where you would want to do
join on a particular column it would
have to shuffle the data for both the
data sets or data frames or rdds so that
it can be doing your operation now in
that case we can always use a broadcast
variable and in that what happens is
that the smaller data set or data frame
can be converted as a broadcast variable
and then this variable is shipped to the
memory of each machine which can then be
used to directly do your join or other
operations with the variable or with the
smaller set of data in memory with the
larger data set on that particular node
now that's where broadcast variables are
useful so for example you can be saying
dot broadcast so like what we were doing
earlier you can create a spark context
you can say broadcast and i would want
to broadcast this particular list as a
variable now you can always be looking
at the value of it okay now once this
broadcast variable is created we can
then be using this so for example b is
my broadcast variable and a could be a
huge list of elements and if i would
want to do a join or some other
operation between them then this b would
be shipped to the memory of every node
now what would have happened is on every
worker node the memory would have a
partition of your larger data set so
this small variable or this broadcast
variable having less number of values
could be used to do a join operation
with each partition on each node now
that's the benefit of broadcast now when
you talk about accumulators these are
variables that are only added through an
associative and commutative operation so
for example if i would want to use
accumulator so here i would say
sc.accumulator now i'm defining a
function here so i'm specifying global
num and then i would want to increment
the value of num based on x now here you
create an rdd so you say c dot
parallelize on a particular number and
for each element here you would want to
apply this particular function so
basically this function which takes x as
a value and it keeps adding all the
values we are applying this function to
every element in the list so once we
start iterating through the list 20
would get added to 30 then the total
would get added to 40 and so on or you
could say other way that you will start
with 20 and then 30 plus 20 and then 40
is added to the sum 50 is added to the
sum and finally look at the value so
when you are talking about accumulators
here so we can basically looking at the
accumulator value here which would show
me 150. so you can try this out like
what i have shown other examples either
this one or the broadcast and basically
you will get a better idea of how
broadcast variables and how your
accumulators work so moving forward now
that we have looked at broadcast and
accumulators let's also look at some sub
packages in pi spark now as i said
whether you work with python or scala or
r or spark sql you have spark has
different components which allows you to
handle different kind of workloads
handle different kind of work packages
and work on different kind of data sets
so when you work with pi spark it has a
component for sql so you can also be
using pi spark.sql module and that
basically allows you to work with
structured data like what we were seeing
in the example of data frames you could
be using pi spark dot streaming module
and that is if you are interested in
working on streaming kind of data
wherein you could be doing stream
processing if you would be interested in
building machine learning algorithms
then you can use pi sparks dot ml
package and also the ml lib package so
these are two different packages one
mainly for data frames and one with
other machine learning algorithms so
there are a lot of sub packages in pi
spark which you can use and you can be
appropriately using the modules now
there are different companies which are
using pi spark and i would say all the
companies which are using spar would be
having their applications either in
scala or written in python where they
would be benefiting from pi spark or
spark shell and thus working on
structured data so you have amp lab now
that's basically where spark started you
have mine tree you have walmart repro
tech systems tridents cab gemini alibaba
and many more so there are different
other companies which are using pi spark
now to look at the demo we can be
looking at a particular data set and
then we can see how we can use pi spar
to analyze that particular data now for
our demo we will look at this walmart
stock related data what we have and this
is basically saved in a csv format so as
i showed earlier we can be using the csv
format we can create a data frame out of
it and then we can basically ask some
questions to it so for example
if i would be interested in working on
this one so here if you see i have
imported find spark and i've initialized
it and then from pi spark i'm using the
sql module where i import spark session
and then i can be doing a spark session
builder app name walmart i can just say
get or create now you would not be doing
all these things if you were working in
an interactive way like i was showing in
our spark setup so you could straight
away start from here where you are
reading a file into a data frame so you
could be loading the data now if that
data is existing so here in this step
you are basically doing a read dot csv
you are pointing into a file wherever
your data is stored and then you say
infer schema and you say header true so
that it knows the first row is basically
your heading now once you're done with
this now in certain cases if you are
using a notebook to do it or if you
would want to do it from your command
line right now in that case you will
have to make sure that if you are doing
it from the command line you will have
to get these packages so for example
what i can do is i can be going into say
in my case i have anaconda installed and
that's where i'm showing you this
notebook so what you can be doing is
going to your anaconda prompt if
anaconda is installed or if you have
your python then you can just be doing a
pip install find spark you can be doing
a pip install pi spark and it should get
your modules and then it also installs
pi 4j which i was explaining earlier it
will basically set up all these packages
so pi 4j and pi spark shows you the
version and then you should be all set
so if you are using anaconda which has
basically all these different ways of
working with your python so you have
jupiter you have basically spider you
have visual studio code so if you would
want to use anaconda then just install
anaconda navigator where you can use
notebook then you can also get to your
anaconda prompt and install the packages
and then you can start your jupyter
notebook so here you could be doing this
other way is you could be doing it from
your command line provided you have
installed these packages the third way
is you can be doing it from your spark
standalone cluster and in that case you
don't have to do all this stuff you can
straight away start reading the csv and
then start working on it so here we are
reading a walmart file now this is what
we have open what was the open price
what was the high low and closing price
right shows me the date and it shows me
the volume so if you want to do some
analysis on it so you can create a data
frame out of it then you can be looking
at the columns what are part of those
data frames you could be just looking at
the first row of the data frame using
head and you can see the values you can
check the schema using a print schema
you can be printing in first five rows
so for line in the data frame dot head
and you are saying i would want to look
at first five rows and i would want to
print it in line by line now i can be
getting some general statistics out so i
can just be using a data frames dot
describe now that's the method which
gives you just a summary right so when
you are looking at these values so it
gives you count and mean standard
deviation minimum max so that's like
your final summary or your describe
summary
you could also be formatting columns to
just show two decimal places so up here
i'm using from pi spark.sql functions
within the sql package i'm importing
format number and what i'm doing is i'm
doing a describe to look at the stats
and then for the same stats i would be
doing a select where i would be
interested in looking at this summary
and what i would want is all of these
columns which we were seeing here open
high low close volume all of these i
would want to just look at values with
two decimal points so i'm just
specifying from my data frame what is
the column name how do you want to cast
it as and basically giving the limit and
then i'm saying what would be this
called so you could change the name if
you would wish to and here we have
reduced the information what we were
seeing here just to two decimal points
so this is a simple example where you
are doing some formatting now you can
create a new data frame with a column
called hb ratio that is ratio of high
price versus volume of stock and how do
you do that you use the with column
method so with column method now here we
are doing this now with column i could
also be passing a function if i have
created my user defined function so up
here i am saying df that's my data frame
i say with column
what would be my column called so that's
your hv ratio now how do you get that
so out of your data frame you take the
high column divide that with the volume
right and then you would basically do a
select on this hb ratio so what we are
doing is we are not only in this part
creating a new column into the data
frame so my this data frame df
underscore hb the new one will have this
particular column and what we are doing
is with this with column it would have
added hv ratio as a column in your data
frame and then i'm just doing a select
on that so here it shows me the hp ratio
and the values so if you would want to
answer some more questions like which
day has the peak high in price you can
do an order by so here you are again
working on your data frame you say df
you would be interested in looking at
the high column you would want to sort
it in a descending way and then whatever
is the result you would want to
basically select the date and head value
for your first index position so you
could also be doing a mean of the close
column so here we are using import mean
and then we are applying the mean
function on the close value what is the
maximum and minimum value of volume
column so you could be doing this by
just doing import minimum and max and
apply this on your volume column how
many days did the stock close lower than
60 dollars and you can be looking at 60
and you can be doing a filter so what
percentage of time was high greater than
80 dollars again you're doing some
computation on the high column where
you're looking for the value which is
greater than 80 which is given in this
brackets and you're doing a filter what
is the pearson correlation between high
and volume so you can just use the
correlation method here on high and
volume column and you can get the value
you can import correlation and you could
also be doing it in this way where you
could do a df dot select use the
correlation method or you can say
function on high and volume and then
basically show the results if you would
want to find out what is the max high
per year now in this case you would be
importing some other packages like day
of month hour day of year you have month
year week of year and so on and then you
are using with column where you are
creating year and you are extracting the
year aspect from the date and that would
become your year column and then what
you're doing is using this year column
you're doing a group by and finding out
the max high value per year so what is
the average close for each calendar
month and basically you create a month
column using with column by extracting
the month out of this date and then you
do a group by month and do a mean or
order by month and then you can do an
average close so these are different
ways in which you can answer the
questions
on a particular data set using pi spark
and then obviously once you have run
this you can always go to the spark ui
and basically look at this so this code
will be available for you and here you
can always look at this which basically
gives me an idea of working with your
data frame using by spark and different
modules and functions and different
packages which we are using to extract
useful information from a particular
data set we've almost reached the end of
this tutorial now ajay will help you
learn some of the important spark
questions that you might tackle in any
big data and spark interview let's have
a quick look at some spark interview
questions which will just prepare you
with different aspects of spark
and its competence and can help you when
you are facing an interview now here we
have some generic spark questions such
as
how is apache spark different from
mapreduce now this is one of the common
questions which you might be asked about
you would have to answer about
differences between apache spark and
mapreduce right now mapreduce is a
programming model and apache spark is a
processing framework so when we talk
about spark you can basically say that
spark processes data in batch but then
it is also good for real time processing
in fact it is one of the features of
spark that it is good with real time or
faster processing
spark runs nearly 100 times faster than
hadoop mapreduce well that actually
depends on how your spark application
has been written
and in comparison to how your mapreduce
application has been written but then
if you would say spark application
whether that is written in scala python
ur
in any way if it has been well written
then spark can give you a performance
benefit it would be 100 times faster
than your traditional mapreduce now
spark as i mentioned earlier does not
have its own storage so for processing
it would be picking up the data from say
an rdbms or from hadoop distributed file
system or from a data warehouse packet
such as hive but then spark is known to
do a in memory processing now it stores
data in ram in the form of rdds and that
is why it gives you a faster performance
now when you talk about mapreduce
mapreduce is slower due to the reason
that it has two phases mapping and
reducing wherein the intermittent result
that is the result of your map phase is
basically written to sdfs and then it is
picked up from sdfs for your further
reducing so mapreduce also processes the
data stored in sdfs but as i mentioned
while processing also the staging data
or the data which is result of map phase
and has to be picked up by reduce phase
is also stored in sdfs spark also has
features such as caching and in-memory
data storage so you can have your
computations that is the result of rdds
getting stored in cache
now that could be different ways so you
can use a storage level and then you can
specify whether the caching is going to
be in memory is it going to be in disk
or is it going to be a combination of
memory and disk but those possibilities
are there in spark now mapreduce does
not have this well you have a feature of
distributed cache but that's not as
efficient as spark so hadoop is highly
disk dependent
now if somebody asks you what are the
important components of spark echo
system so
spark basically has language support for
different
programming languages such as java
python scala and even our programming
language and spark has different
components for different use cases and
different kind of data so it has a core
api that is your spark core engine
you have spark sql to process your
structured data you have spark streaming
which helps you in processing streaming
data mlib to create your machine
learning algorithms by using different
statistical methods and algorithms which
are available
and graphics which is for your graph
based processing now when you talk about
spark it can be set up as a standalone
cluster that is having one master and
multiple worker nodes
it can be integrated with apache mesos
and then you also have yarn with which
your spark cluster can be integrated so
if you are describing about important
components of spark echo system then you
will mainly speak about the mid layer
that is the core components you could
also speak about your language support
and the cluster management solutions
which can be used when you're working
with spark explain how spark runs
applications with the help of its
architecture now when we talk about
spark application it runs basically as
independent processes or basically you
have application which would be split
into tasks and these tasks would be
running across your different machines
now you could have basically spark
session or your spark context which are
these important classes or you can say
the entry point of your spark
applications every spark application
would have a driver and what does that
driver have it basically knows the flow
of your application at the back end you
also have a dag scheduler so for all the
steps what you're doing in your
application dac scheduler is aware of
what are the different steps which make
your dag that is direct acyclic graph
for your in-memory processing now your
spark session or your spark context
which is your entry point of your
application interacts with the cluster
manager now in this case we can be
specifically speaking about yarn which
has resource manager is the master of
the cluster and node manager as the
slaves of the cluster so your spark
session or spark context speaks to
resource manager that is the cluster
manager which basically would request
resources from the worker nodes where
the execution would happen now worker
nodes would have a processing slave that
is node manager which grants the
approval of usage of resources to
resource manager now this request which
we are talking about that is requesting
resources is called container so
resource manager request containers from
one or multiple worker nodes worker
nodes or the node manager process
running on them grants these containers
and it is within these containers a
executor process is launched which is
responsible to take care of the
application related tasks so when you
talk about iterative algorithms they
apply operations repeatedly to the data
and they can benefit from caching data
sets across iterations so you can also
have the rdds which are created or the
computations which are done they could
be cached and this cache can be
beneficial for your further run of the
similar tasks or similar computation now
what is a task here it is basically the
unit of work to the data which is coming
from the respective disk to basically
transform or work on it so when you talk
about execution which is taken care by
executors which could be either one or
multiple on a particular node now which
depends basically on the data on the
node which depends on the resources
available on the node you could have
multiple executors the result is then
sent back to the driver and that's how
your application execution happens in
case of spark one of the common
questions which is asked is what are the
different cluster managers available in
apache spark or how does spark work with
different setups so by default you can
have spark in a standalone mode that
basically means spark would be running
with one master in multiple worker nodes
with one master and multiple worker
processes across machines you would not
have any hadoop setup or message or
anything else so by default here
applications would be submitted to the
standalone mode and they would run in a
fifo order that is first in first out
and each application would try to use
the resources on available worker nodes
spark can also be integrated with apache
mesos and that's an open source project
to manage computer clusters and can also
run hadoop applications in fact
spark initially came into existence to
prove the credibility of apache spark
and then later became a independent
project you have spark integration with
hadoop yarn so that is where yarn is
taking care of resource allocation in a
hadoop cluster and spark leverages the
benefit of using yarn you could also
have spark working with in a kubernetes
environment now kubernetes is an open
source system for automating deployment
running your micro services scaling and
management of containerized applications
so spark can even work in a kubernetes
setup one of the important things of
spark which really makes it powerful is
lazy evaluation so
what is lazy valuation in spark when
spark operates on any data set that is
the data which you are interested in
processing it would take care of the
processing based on various steps within
your application each step basically
creates a rdd a resilient distributed
data set so for example if i would want
to read a file i could use a method of
spark context called text file and this
would create an rdd then you could do a
map or a flat map or a filter and all
these steps what you code in your
application are lazily evaluated that is
they are not evaluated as soon as the
step is created they are evaluated they
are executed only when action is invoked
so whenever you do a transformation such
as map or filter or flat map or you just
use a method of spark context in this
case it will only and only create an rdd
a resilient distributed data set which
exists in the memory but this rdd does
not have any data loaded does not have
any transformation done so
transformations in spark are evaluated
only when one would invoke an action so
till then it is called as lazy valuation
that is it does not evaluate the file
which you are processing or any map or
filter or any other transformation so
the question is what makes spark good at
low latency workloads like graph
processing and machine learning so how
does spark achieve that so as we
discussed earlier your apache spark is
good in storing data in memory for
faster processing and model building so
any component of spark you use such as
spark sql spark core spark mlib spark
streaming or graphics in any of these
cases it is in memory processing that
means the data is loaded into the memory
of the respective worker nodes and then
the processing happens plus the data
which is loaded in memory which is
undergoing some transformations and
results in some kind of intermittent
data that data can be stored or cached
in memory for further processing when
you talk about machine learning machine
learning algorithms require sometimes
multiple iterations to create a optimal
model even your graph algorithms
traverse all the nodes and edges so
basically these low latency work nodes
that need multiple iterations can lead
to an increased performance because you
are doing the processing in smaller
iterations by
loading data in the memory so there is
also a concept of automatic cleanups so
the question is how can you trigger
automatic cleanups in spark to handle
accumulated metadata and there is a
parameter or you can say property which
needs to be set to trigger the cleanups
you need to set parameter spark.cleaner
dot tt lx time to live and that's where
your job which is running which is
divided into batches and writes the data
to the disk you could trigger a clean up
based on this parameter now how do you
connect spark to apache missiles so
suppose you have apache meso setup but
then you would also want to do in memory
processing using park how do you do it
so first thing what we will have to do
here is configure the spark driver
program to basically connect to apache
mesos that is you have to give your
connection details to connect to apache
mesos then you will have to put your
spark binary package that is spark
installation package or binary package
in a location accessible by mesos so
mesos knows that where spark is existing
spark can install in the same location
as that of apache mesos and then you can
also configure some properties which
says what is the spark mesos executor
home pointing to location where spark is
installed so basically your apache
message has to be informed about spark
and spark can be existing with apache
resource or within apache missiles so
that it can use apache missiles now one
more question which you can expect in
interview or if somebody is testing your
knowledge is about different data
formats now other than your regular
format such as json xml text csv there
are other intelligent formats such as
binary files or sequence file formats
you have avro you have par k and so on
so parquet is basically columnar format
which is supported by several data
processing systems so if you have say
for example you have data which is in
csv which has multiple fields or
multiple columns and you do not access
all the fields or all the columns all
the time it would be advisable to go for
a parquet format wherein spark can
perform read and write operations by
default that is whenever spark tries to
data set it will assume that data is in
a par k format and if your data is in a
different format then you have to
specify that so advantages of having a
columnar storage is you can fetch
specific columns for access it consumes
less space obviously uh brings down your
disk usage by 62 percent approximately
it follows type specific encoding and
controls your i o operations so if you
would be interested in reading about
different formats i can share a good
link with you which talks about formats
and here can find let's look at formats
this is the good link which basically
shows you details about different data
formats such as compression schemes you
have metadata management you have
different common file formats you have
binary files or sequence file formats
which can be compressed at a block level
or record level and support split
ability
you also have other formats such as avro
and parquet and this is a very good
document you can refer to now coming
back let's look at the next question so
what is shuffling in spark and when does
this happen now shuffling as we know
would basically mean similar kind of
data being brought together so shuffling
is the process of redistributing your
data across partitions now what we know
is whenever we do a transformation
whenever we use a method of spark what
does it do it creates an rdd now unless
and until you have specified how many
logical partitions of that rdd you want
it will by default create number of
partitions based on either the data set
size or based on the number of cores
which are available in your cluster or
it could be that you are basically
creating partitions by default that is
true so say for example you have a data
which you would want to process and that
data is converted into a key value pair
so take an example you have a sentence
welcome to my world now if i want to
split this in a key value combination
where i would say my first word will
become the key and the complete line
becomes the value so my key would be
welcome and the value would be welcome
to my world now if you have similar data
like this which is key value pairs and
that is because of some transformation
you did on a data set all these data
would be in a rdd during the time of
evaluation and this rdd would have
partitions so you would have some key
value pairs in partition one some key
value pairs and partition two now
suppose you would want to do something
like a join or suppose you want to do a
group by or a sort by based on key now
how would that happen that would be
possible when the similar keys are
brought into the same partition so that
will trigger shuffling so that your key
value pairs which are stored in rdd
which are stored in rdd in partitions
you will have your similar keys shuffled
and brought to the same partition where
then you can do some key based
operations now that's where your
shuffling in spark happens there is also
an operation called colase and why is
that used in spark so spark use colase
method to reduce the number of
partitions in a data frame now what we
know is whenever you are working on
structured data and this structured data
basically whenever you do a
transformation on it it creates a schema
rdd or what we call as data frame so
what is data frame you know it like a
table which has rows and columns with
headings so scholas is basically used to
reduce the number of partitions in a
data frame so for example you have four
partitions which have some values and
what you would want to do is you would
want to filter
the data in such a way that you will
remove the multiples of 10. so here you
see we can be using colase for this
which will remove all the values which
are multiples of 10. so data is read
from a csv into an rdd the rdd has some
empty partitions it makes sense to
reduce the number of partitions why not
and using colace you can bring your data
together in less number of partitions
and get rid of the partitions which
really do not have any data now the
question is how can you calculate the
executor memory or calculate the memory
which will be required by the executors
which will take care of your tasks okay
so let's continue learning on some spark
interview questions now here's our next
question so how can you calculate the
executor memory right now when you talk
about executor it is the jvm process
which will take care of your spark
application related tasks that would be
executed so let's say this is your
cluster so you have 10 nodes each node
has 16 cores that is you can then take
away one for your operating system
itself each node has ram which is 61
gigabyte of ram and when you talk about
your course your course is the number of
concurrent tasks an executor can run in
parallel so the general rule of thumb
for optimal value is phi now it depends
now when you talk about number of
executor identification how do you do
that so number of executors is equal to
number of cores that the machine has
divided by the concurrent tasks so if we
say we have 15 cores and we have five
concurrent tasks so we get number of
executors is three and depending on the
number of nodes you have you can
multiply that with the number of
executor in each node which would run
for your data processing and that will
give you number of executors for your
spark job so in our case we have 10
nodes we are talking about the number of
executed in each node which we just
calculated as three and then that gives
me the total number of executors right
now this is how you can basically
calculate the executor related memory
now let's look at some spark core
questions so what are the various
functionalities supported by spark core
so what is parkour spark is the engine
for parallel and distributed processing
of large data sets so you could be
scheduling and monitoring your jobs you
could be doing memory management fault
recovery and task dispatching so these
are various functionalities which are
supported by your spark core now what is
the significance of rdds that is your
resilient distributed data sets in spark
now rdds are the building blocks in
spark so spark core is embedded with
rdds which is basically the fundamental
data structure of apache spark what are
rdds these are immutable fault tolerant
distributed collection of objects that
can be operated in parallel and when are
these rdds getting created whenever you
do some transformation so either you
would be using a method of spark context
or say the initial entry point for your
application that's your spark context so
methods could be something like text
file whole text file parallelize and so
on or you could be doing some series of
transformations so per transformation
you do on your rdd it creates a further
rdd so you could be doing a map flat map
filter and many more so rdds by default
whenever they are created they are split
into what we call as logical partitions
now when we are creating an rdd we could
also mention how many partitions we want
so rdds are split into partitions and
they can be executed on different nodes
of a cluster how do you convert a spark
rdd into a data frame now we know that
spark core comes with the rdd concept
that spark rdd is the basic api and then
you have other apis in spark such as
data frame and data sets so if you would
want to convert a rdd into data frame
you could be using a helper function
called to df so here we are importing a
package and then we would want to create
a data frame so we use the spark context
we load from map rdb so we basically are
getting the data from a table we are
also giving some conditions like where
field is something you are doing a
select and finally you are doing a two
data frame which will convert your rdd
into a data frame now you could also be
doing that using spark sessions method
create data frame so as we know that
when you work with spark rdd you use
spark context and when you would want to
work with spark sql you would be using
the internal class that is spark session
and that has different methods so you
could be creating a data frame using
create data frame so you can convert an
rdd of row to a data frame by calling
create data frame on a spark session
object looking further so if somebody
asks you explain two types of operations
supported by rdds now as i said earlier
rdds are created either when you use a
smart context and a method of spark
context like text file parallelize whole
text files or when you do some
transformations so there are two kind of
operations which are mainly supported by
rdds one is your transformations and
second is your action so any or every
transformation you do it will only
result in an rdd which basically means a
logical step but there will be no
execution happening so your
transformations are operations that are
performed on an rdd to create a new rdd
how is this rdd initially coming into
existence so if i would have said val x
equals sc dot text file and then i pass
a file into that that would create an
rdd or if i do a sc dot parallelizer if
i do sc dot whole text files or a
sequence file so that would have created
my initial rdd and then i could be doing
any transformations on that you could
also be doing the second kind of
operation which actually leads to the
execution of your spark tag and that's
your actions so whenever you launch an
action you would have your spark
applications execution happening so when
you talk about actions it could be take
it could be collect it could be reduced
it could be first count and so on so
these are your two kinds of operations
which are supported by rdds now how do
you programmatically specify schema for
a data frame so we know that we can be
reading say csv or text or json or avro
or parquet so you could be reading any
kind of data in different data format
and if you use spark sessions method
like read or read dot format dot load
now that creates a data frame but
sometimes you may be interested in
working on a data where you would want
to specify the schema for every field
that data has for example you have a
list which has id name and salary and
what you want to do is you want to
assign a schema to it and that can again
be done in two ways one you can be
creating a case class and then passing
in the schema to every field or you
could be using struct field so here we
are doing a dot map we are selecting
every field and then we are using a
struct field which will basically get
the data type and apply that to every
field what is a lineage graph now when
you talk about spark as i said every
step you do in a spark application
starting from your initialization or
starting from using your spark context
method it creates a rdd and each rdd is
like a logical step in your spark
applications dag right so when you talk
about spark applications dag it has
series of steps which are which you have
coded which have either a method of
spark context or series of
transformation so this whole dag is
basically like a lineage graph now spark
does not support data replication in the
memory well we can have persistence
which can be done so if you would want
spark to benefit from a rdd graph or a
rdd lineage which was already created
then spark has an internal way of
capturing the lineage of your steps so
lineage is basically a flow so it is
also called an rdd operator graph or rdd
dependency graph now let's look at some
spark streaming questions so one of the
question is what do you understand by d
streams in spark so when you are working
on streaming data or when you intend to
process streaming data you would be
interested in capturing the data at
various time intervals now your d
streams or disk criticized streams is
basically the abstraction so what
happens is when you have a continuous
stream of data that is coming in as
input coming from some source or you
have a process data stream by some
application this data stream or this
input stream is broken down into smaller
batches of data and these smaller
batches are called your d stream so if
we see here we see data from time 0 to 1
1 to 2 2 3 and 3 to 4 so this is nothing
but my d streams and each the stream is
a smaller batch of data on which you
would have series of transformations
which will be applied based on what you
have coded in your spark applications
now let's learn about caching in spark
streaming so if somebody says what is
caching in spark streaming so we know
spark does in memory processing so does
it have caching yes so that is your
persistence so caching is also known as
persistence or optimization technique
for spark computations so basically when
you have your processing happening from
1d stream to other d stream you could
have persistence implemented now that
helps you to save interim partial
results so that they can be if required
reused in subsequent stages so when we
talk about the default persistence level
that is to set to replicate the data to
two nodes for fault tolerance so when
you have your streaming and stream
processing happening we can have the
persistence of that computation across
nodes now one of the main problems which
also is seen when you talk about spark
application is operations like joints so
if you intend to do joins across
multiple rdds one of the problem it
poses is that first of all the rdds
which you are working on should be like
a pair rdd or what we call as a key
value pair rdd and if you do something
like join then in that case in every rdd
which is nothing but a pair rtd or you
can say the data within the rdd is in
the form of key value pairs so all the
similar keys and we know that rdds have
partitions so all the similar keys have
to be shuffled across partitions so that
similar keys land in the same partition
now this would be happening on other rdd
also which you would want to join so you
have rdd1 which has partitions and this
rtd1 has key value pair and all the keys
have to be sorted and brought into same
partition similarly it will be on the
second rdd and then a join can happen so
this can be
triggering a lot of shuffling which
would be happening when you're doing a
join kind of operation now that could be
tackled by using broadcast variables so
basically this one allows the programmer
to keep a read-only variable cached on
each machine rather than shipping a copy
of it so you could be creating a
broadcast variable and this broadcast
variable can be used in operations like
join so this broadcast variable will
then be shipped to memory of every node
so if you do a join in two rdds one of
the rdds can be broadcasted as a
broadcast variable and when you do a
join using this broadcast variable and
the other rdd it will be faster it will
avoid lot of shuffling and then you
could do your operations more
efficiently so which transformation
returns a new d stream by selecting only
those records of source d stream for
which function returns true so if we
have this question so the answer would
be filter so filter transformation will
give a new d stream by selecting only
those records of source d stream for
which function returns true now does
apache spark provide checkpoints and the
answer is yes there is a checkpointing
mechanism which can be used in streaming
so apache spark provides an api for
adding and managing checkpoints so
checkpointing is the process of making
your streaming app applications
resilient to failures so you could be
creating a streaming context you could
set also a checkpoint path and you could
define a d stream so when you start your
streaming application it will not only
be capturing data at regular intervals
based on how your receiver has been set
but you could also have a check pointing
mechanism which makes sure that every
computation which happens over a d
stream can then be using a checkpoint
mechanism if any kind of recovery is
required what do you mean by sliding
window operation now that's one more
extensibility of your spark streaming so
you can not only do streaming on at
regular intervals using your spark
streaming context but then you can also
control the transmission of data packets
between multiple networks you could be
using spark streaming for it so spark
streaming library provides windowed
computations so windowed computations
basically means a set of intervals for
which the data was received and you
would want to do a processing based
window based operation it will look at
the last three instances and then it
gives you a window based output so
that's your windowing now what are the
different levels of persistence in spark
so spark as we know whatever steps you
create in your application those steps
lead to an rdd whenever you're doing
some transformation on using a method of
smart context but if you are triggering
an action that basically triggers the
execution of your application now at
certain times in some steps whatever
computation was done you may want to use
the same computation again down your
application now in that case caching can
benefit so you could do persistence by
default it is memory but then you could
use all these different options of
storage level such as disk only so you
can have the rdds or the computations
stored on the disk you could have memory
only in a serialized way so that is
storing the rtds serialized java objects
with one byte array per partition you
have memory only that is storing the
rtds as d serialized java objects in the
jvm and if an rdd is or cannot fit into
memory it will be recomputed now you
could have something like off heap so it
works with memory only serialization but
stores the data in off heap memory you
have memory and disk and you can choose
the percentage so memory and disk
basically means the rdds which are
getting created as a part of your
application those rtds are stored as dc
realize java objects and if in case the
rdd is not able to fit in the memory
additional partitions are stored on the
disk so you could also have memory and
disk serialize so all of these come with
storage level and this is how you can
have persistence achieved in spark where
you would want to persist some rdd
computations now somebody might ask you
a difference between different
transformations like you have map and
flat map so what's the difference
whether it is spark streaming or spark
core so when you talk about your map
function it basically in terms of spark
streaming gives you a new d stream by
passing each element of the source t
stream through a function so technically
speaking you are applying a function on
that d stream which is getting collected
or which is getting created now spark
map function what does it do it takes
one element at a time and based on
whatever you have given in your code it
applies that function of the data it
takes every time or of the element it
takes every time when you talk about
flat map it is basically a combination
of map and flattening or it is basically
flat map does the flattening so it is
similar to map function it applies the
function to each element of rdd so your
flat map allows returning zero one or
more elements from the map function so
it is basically flattening it or it is
splitting your data into individual
elements now how do you compute the
total count of unique words in spark so
this is basically you doing a word count
in spark now in layman terms you could
take a file depending on if you are
doing a word count you would want to
split that file and get individual words
in the file and then you would want to
write some kind of loop which looks into
these words and does a counting of these
words if the words serve if the words
are repetitive so you can load the file
as rdd using sc.text file you could then
apply a function to the particular line
so you could be doing a tokenizing that
is splitting your line into individual
words then you could do a flat map so
that you can get all the words split and
exploded or extracted from the file you
could convert each word into a key value
pair because you remember we are doing a
word count so we can have a key value
pair where key is the word and the value
is say number one which is assigned to
every word then you could be doing a
reduce by key action so reduce by key
action is basically going to reduce the
data based on the keys and give you a
total okay and finally you can print the
result so this is how you can do a word
count in spa so suppose you have a huge
text file how will you check if
particular keyword exists using spark
and that's pretty simple so you could
already be doing a if line dot find and
then give your keyword and you could be
pushing it to say minus one you could be
doing a return one or return zero
depending on what you are trying to do
so here we are creating a function which
basically takes the lines does a map and
applies a function called is found and
then what it does is you want to search
for a particular keyword now that could
also be done using something like
starts with or contains so there are
other ways in which also you can search
for particular keyword that exists using
spark now one of the important questions
is what is the role of accumulators in
spark now like we discuss broadcast
variables which are basically shipped
into the memory of nodes and then can be
useful when you would be using joins
similarly when you talk about
accumulators these are variables which
are used for aggregating information
across the executors now this
information can be about the data or api
diagnosis like how many records or are
corrupted or how many times a library
api was called and you can always look
for this information in the spark ui so
accumulators play an important role when
it comes to aggregating information
which can then be used across executes
let's look at some spark ml lab
questions so basically understanding
about spark ml lab or spark ml library
which is used for machine learning
algorithms so what are the different
mlib tools available in spark now when
you talk about ml algorithms you have
algorithms for different kind of
statistical or machine learning problems
like you have classification regression
clustering and collaborative filtering
you also have for
featurization that is for feature
extraction transformation dimensionality
reduction and selection of data you have
pipelines these are tools for
constructing evaluating and tuning ml
pipelines that is basically having a set
of different algorithms which can be
used you have persistence that is saving
and loading algorithms models and
pipelines so you could always be
persisting your algorithms and you have
utilities for linear algebra statistics
and handling so these are different
tools which are available in mlib in
spark what are the different data types
supported by spark ml lib now this is
again a common question asked so spark
ml lib supports local vectors and
matrices stored on a single machine as
well as distributed matrices so you have
local vector which when you talk about
local vector that's a data type which ml
lib supports so mlip supports two types
of local vectors which is dense and
sparse so if you would have vector in
this particular form you could create a
dense format out of it or a sparse
format and if you talk about label point
which is mainly for your labels or
responses so this is a local vector
which is either dense or sparse and
mainly associated with label or response
so in binary classification a label
could be just 0 or 1. if you look at
other data types so you also have local
matrix and distributed matrix so spark
ml lab supports local vectors and
matrices stored on a single machine as
well as distributed matrices so when you
say local matrix it has integer type row
and column indices and double type
values that is stored in a single
machine so here we are looking at a
matrix of three into two size and if you
look in one dimensional array this is
how it would look if you talk about
distributed matrix a distributed matrix
has long type row and column indices and
double type values so it is stored in a
distributed manner in one or more rdd
and there are various types of
distributed matrix
so you have row matrix you have
indexedrow matrix and coordinate matrix
for data types you can always go and
type say spark mlib data types and that
takes you to the spark documentation
wherein you can look at these different
data types which we are talking about
like local vector label point local
matrix and distributed matrix and that
basically has your four different types
such as row indexed coordinate and block
matrix so moving further what is a
sparse vector now we were talking about
local vector local matrix which has
dense and sparse vector so sparse vector
is a type of local vector which is
represented by an indexed array and a
value array so for example if we have
sparse 1 and you create a sparse vector
so here 4 is the size of the vector 1
comma 3 are ordered indeces of the
vector and 3 and 4 are the value so you
have an indexed array and a value array
which is represented by sparse vector
now if somebody asks you describe how
model creation works with mlib and how
the model is applied so basically spark
mlm has two main components it has a
transformer now that's swot which reads
a data frame and returns a new data
frame with a specific transformation
applied now that transformation could be
anything it could be map it could be
flat map it could be filter or you could
have other transformations when you talk
about estimator estimator is a machine
learning algorithm that takes a data
frame to train a model and returns the
model as a transformer so the output of
estimator would be a model which could
then be tested against our data if you
look at the model creation and if
somebody says how model creation works
with mlip and how model is applied so
spark mlib lets you combine multiple
transformations into a pipeline to apply
complex data transformations now if you
look at the image on the left it says
pipeline for training a model so you
would be looking at estimator so you
have a tokenizer which will basically do
the tokenizing or splitting of data you
have hashing tf and then you are
applying a logistic regression model so
this would be your estimator now you
could have a transformer so model
produced can then be applied to live
data so that is you have a pipeline
model so you are using this would be
called as a transformer so you again
have tokenizing hashing tf and you're
applying a logistic regression model now
based on this pipeline where you have
estimator so you could be doing a fit
method so pipeline dot fit which will
then be working on a raw text it gives
you say tokenized output that is words
it will give you feature vectors that is
where you are doing featurization and
then you are solving the problem using
logistic regression model if you talk
about pipeline model so where we are
talking about transformer so you can say
pipeline model dot transform and this
basically will work on raw text gives
you words or feature vectors and finally
gives you the prediction so this is how
a model creation and application is done
in mlip now let's look at some spark sql
questions so spark sql is again an
important component in spark when it
comes to processing your structured data
so what are the functions of spark sql
now spark sql is a apache sparks module
for working with structured data or data
which can be easily structurized so what
are the different functions here you can
load data from a variety of structured
data sources you can then query the data
using sql statement so you could be
having your sql statements within a
spark program or from external tools
that connect to spark sql through
standard database connectors such as
jdbc odbc so you could be using spark
sql to connect to say hive data
warehouse on top of hadoop it can be
used to connect to rdbms and you can get
in your structured data or you could be
accessing the structured data which lies
on sdfs and then run your sql queries
which would still be using sparks in
memory processing capability your spark
sql also provides rich integration
between sql and your other programming
language code such as python java scala
and so on and you can also join rdds and
sql tables and expose custom functions
in sql so these are some of the
functions or you can say features of
apache spark sql component how do you
connect hive to spark sql so we all know
that when you work with hive hive would
have a hive hyphen site file which would
have different properties for spark for
hive and this hive hyphen site file
would also have the metadata information
or the location where hive stores the
metadata and this particular config file
of hive needs to be placed in the config
directory of spark now once you place
this hive hyphen site file in the config
directory of spark if you would use
spark either spark shell or pi spark or
even running a spark application you
could directly say spark.sql and then
give your select queries targeting your
hive table so this is how you can be
directly working with hive using spark
sql now one important question is what
is the role of catalyst optimizer in
spark sql so what does it do catalyst
optimizer it basically leverages
advanced programming language features
such as colors pattern matching and casi
quotes in an oval way to build an
extensible query optimizer which is used
by spark sql so you would have your sql
query which is in intending to access
some data and that would have some kind
of unresolved logical plan to get to the
data now you also have metadata which is
stored in case of hive which spark would
need to access so this unresolved
logical plan is converted into a logical
plan based on some logical optimization
you have optimized logical plan now this
plan is nothing but your execution path
so these physical plans what we are
talking about use a cost model and they
select a physical plan which will be
used to access the data which is then
used by rdds and the code is generated
so this is how catalyst optimizer
performs or helps you in an optimized
way of sql query now these are some
examples here and this shows how can you
manipulate structured data using domain
specific language and spark sql so spark
sql as i mentioned allows you to work on
structured data now you could be
creating a data frame which is a schema
rdd so you could be using spark sessions
method which would be reading a file or
you might be interacting with directly
hive in any of the cases you would have
a data frame and then on the data frame
you could do a select and select a field
you could be selecting multiple fields
and also do some computation you could
be doing a filter or a group by and all
of these functions work very well with
your data frames finally let's look at
some spark graphics questions to see how
graphics helps us in graph based
processing so what are the different
type of operators provided by apache
graphics library now we know that spark
graphics will allow us to work on graph
based processing so there would be
vertices there would be edges and there
would be a property graph so when you
talk about different type of operators
provided by apache graphics you have a
property operator now this modifies the
vertex or edge properties using a user
defined map function and produces a new
graph
you also have a structural operator now
this operates on the structure of an
input graph and produces a new graph how
about join operator so join operators
will basically add data to graphs and
generate new graphs so these are three
important operators which are used in
apache graphics what are the analytic
programs provided in apache spark
graphics so there are some important
analytic algorithms provided by graphics
for your graph based processing
requirements you have page rank
algorithm you have connected components
and you have triangle counting you can
read about these more by looking into
the spark graphics documentation where
all these algorithms and what they do is
explained in a very crisp and a
explanative way so what does the page
rank algorithm do and you might have
heard of page rank algorithm which is
used by google or some other search
engines so page rank basically measures
the importance of each
vertex in a graph assuming an edge from
say u to v represents an endorsement of
v's importance by u now what we are
doing here is we are looking at two
different vertices we are looking at a
relationship between them and we are
looking at the overall graph which is
created by this u and v and how v is
endorsed based on use importance so for
example if a twitter user is followed by
many other users that handle will be
ranked high so we are looking at a
connection where one twitter user is
followed by many other users now
internally when you talk about page rank
algorithm you can understand this by
looking at or thinking about what google
does so where you could have multiple
pages which are being searched and each
page is initially assigned a rank and
based on the searches based on the
possibility of a page being found every
time the rank is incremented now that's
how page algorithm works so these are
some of the important and
critical questions when it comes to your
spark role based interview you can also
look into other aspects of spark such as
partitioning different kind of
partitioners which are used
look at spark data frames and data set
api and what are its capabilities look
into spark mlib and how you could have
your code written in scala or python to
solve ml problems or building your
machine learning algorithms for
different statistical requirements or
also look in spark graphics where you
can build graphs out of your data and
then basically use that for graph
processing i hope this helps you in your
interview with that we've reached the
end of the complete apache spark
tutorial i hope you enjoyed the video do
like it and share it thank you for
watching keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
[Music]